OKAY.
WELCOME TO THE JUNE FIFTH
HEARING ON AG WE HAVE A ROBUST --
SCHEDULE TODAY -- WE HEARING TO
BILLS BY MISTER MCGUIRE BUT
FIRST -- WE WILL DISPENSE WITH
THE BUSINESS OF ROLE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MATHIS HERE COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM HERE FLORA.
LAURIE GRAY I WENT.
HERE JONES SAWYER.
CANCELING.
GAME [inaudible]
SALAS.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED AN IAC WE HAVE ARE
FINE AUTHOR SITTING RIGHT THERE
SO MISTER MCGUIRE CENTER MCGUIRE
FREE COME UP PLEASE.
AND YOU HAVE OUR FILE ITEM ONE
AND FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO BUT I
THINK WE'LL START WITH THAT SB.
SIXTY SEVEN CANNABIS INTEMPERATE
LICENSEES THANK YOU SO MUCH
RENDON CHAIR AND MEMBERS AT GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING TO BE HERE WITH YOU.
YOU'RE RIGHT AND HERE WE HAVE --
CALIFORNIA'S.
FAMOUS AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS BOTH
CANNABIS IN WIND TODAY SO --
BOTTOM LINE IS IS A MAN CHAIR.
IS IT THIS BILL PROTECT CAMPUS
FARMERS IN PARTICULAR THOSE WHO
DID THE RIGHT THING AND APPLY
FOR STATE LICENSE BUT THEIR
TEMPORARY STATE LICENSE HAS
EXPIRED OR IS ABOUT TO EXPIRE.
IN BECAUSE THE INABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO EXTEND THEIR LICENSE DUE
TO EXISTING STATE LAW -- HAVE
DROPPED OR WILL BE DROPPING INTO
THE BLACK MARKET.
CURRENTLY WILL THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- IN WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT AN APPROPRIATE TIME AND CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIRST PERSON
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
SURE -- MADAM CHAIRWOMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
MY NAME IS LINDSAY ROBINSON AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE WEBER REPRESENT
OVER FIVE HUNDRED BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE STATE.
SEE SEE I A IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SENATE BILL SIXTY SEVEN
AND I'D LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
AS YOU KNOWS SIXTY SEVEN ALLOWS
CANNABIS BUSINESSES THAT WERE
ISSUED TEMPORARY CANNABIS
BUSINESS LICENSES PRIOR TO
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY NINETEEN
TO REMAIN OPERABLE UNTIL STATE
LACING AGENCIES.
PROCESS ANNUAL APPLICATIONS OR
UNTIL SEPTEMBER TWO FIFTEENTH
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
WHICHEVER IS SOONER.
THE TEMPORARY LICENSE PROGRAM
WHICH WAS ENACTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WAS ESTABLISHED TO ALLOW
CANNABIS.
BUSINESSES TO OPERATE WHILE
STATE LICENSING AGENCIES DEVELOP
PROCESS AND REVIEW APPLICATIONS
FOR ANNUAL LICENSES LAST YEAR
WHEN IT BECAME CLEAR THAT THE
TEMPORARY.
STRUCTURE WOULD EXPIRE BEFORE
ALL OF THE ANNUAL APPLICATIONS
WERE REVIEWED ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONAL LICENSE CATEGORY WAS
CREATED TO SB.
FIVE FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE THE
CREATION OF THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSES THOUSANDS OF APPLICANTS
WITH CORRESPONDING ANNUAL
APPLICATIONS HAVE HAD THEIR
TEMPORARY LICENSES EXPIRE WHILE
THEIR APPLICATIONS ARE PENDING
REVIEW.
THIS IS HAD DRAMATIC EFFECTS ON
FOLKS TRYING TO NAVIGATE THE
LEGAL CANNABIS SPACE.
AND HUMBLE COUNTY A CULTIVATORS
WHO HAVE CHOSEN TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE WITH EXPIRED LICENSES%
HAVE HAD THEIR BANK ACCOUNTS
SHUT DOWN AND IT HAD. FOR NON
COMPLIANCE AND THEIR INSURANCE
CANCELED IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
WE PROVIDE PATHWAYS TO KEEP
COMPLIANT BUSINESSES TRYING TO
DO THE RIGHT THING WITH IN THE
LEGAL SYSTEM.
BUSINESSES IN POSSESSION OF
TEMPORARY LICENSES HAVE WORKED
INCREDIBLY HARD TO OBTAIN LOCAL
APPROVAL HAVE INVESTED THOUSANDS
IF NOT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
MEET THE RIGOROUS STAY COMPLIANT
MESSAGE.
ABOUT COMPLIANCE STANDARDS WE
SHOULD NOT LET THESE BUSINESSES
FALL OUT OF THE LEGAL SYSTEM.
OKAY -- PASSED THE PASSAGE OF
SIXTY SEVEN IS CRITICAL FOR
CONTINUED SURVIVAL OF ILLEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND SEE SEE I
A STRONGLY RECOMMEND SUPPORT WE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OFFER THE
TIME TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS PERSON SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TERROR
CARVER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE --
WE SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION
BECAUSE IT EXTENDS THE VIABILITY
OF THE REMAINING TEMPORARY
LICENSES THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED TO THE STATE THAT ARE
PENDING A FINAL DECISION BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND ADD
ESPECIALLY OUR SMALL FARMS AND
HUMBLED WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE BECAUSE SUPPORT
PLEASE AT THE MICROPHONE NAME
AND AFFILIATION.
A MERRY ON WARMER GENERAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORTED THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
CAROLING OVER THE MENDOCINO IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS BUTTONS ON SPORTS I
THINK YOU.
CARE MARIN SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY STEVENS ON
BEHALF OF NOR CAL CANNABIS ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE INTERNATIONAL CANNABIS
FARMERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
RENDON RYAN WITH MANY SERVICES
AND SUPPORT.
KATHY VAN AWESOMEON BEHALF OF
SAM G. KHALIFA IN SUPPORT.
I'LL HANDLE SO LEASE ON BEHALF
OF UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JOHN BROWER WITH A LICENSE
CANNABIS GROWERS ATTORNEY COUNTY
URGING SUPPORT.
AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
COSTA GROWERS ASSOCIATION CAN I
CRAFT AND TERROR ATTACK IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN YOU MAKE ON BEHALF OF
CONNECTED CANNABIS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS MONICA'S
WORKING TUNNEL IT'S AN APARTMENT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MAX BECAUSE ABOUT FLOW CARLIN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RENDON MURPHY ON BEHALF WITH
MAPS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL TODAY. TO THIS FINE BILL
THAT BREAKS DOWN BERWICK
BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS NOBODY
HITS BEGIN OPPOSITION MR MATHIS --
WIT WITH THAT BREAKING DOWN
BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS MADAM
CHAIR -- I LIKE TO THINK THE
OTHER FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
YOU KNOW IT ALWAYS TAKES A LOT
OF WORK TO BREAK DOWN THOSE
BARRIERS AND CUT THAT RED TAPE
AND YOU KNOW YOUR BILL VERY
CLEARLY IS JUST LOOKING AT
KEEPING LICENSES IN THE PEOPLE
THAT I'VE WORKED HARD TO GO
THROUGH THE LOCAL PROCESS IS
RIGOROUS AS AS IT.
IS -- YOU KNOW I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF CONCERNS OUT THERE WITH
RECREATIONAL AND EVERYTHING ELSE
BUT THIS IS VERY SIMPLY SAYING
THESE PEOPLE ARE LICENSED LET'S
ENSURE THAT THEY STATE LICENSED
AND STAY LEGAL -- WITH THEIR
OPERATING SPACE THAT THEY'RE
DOING SO THANK YOU FOR DOING
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
TO ENSURE THAT WE KEEP PEOPLE ON
THE RIGHT SIDE OF THE LAW ON
THIS ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER YOUR SPOT ON THANK YOU SO
MUCH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATOR LEASES ON THEIR
MATHIS -- AS A CLOSE SO VERY
MUCH SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL TO MANTA KNOWS HOW TO GIVE
OUT.
SB SIXTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
EGGMAN BY EGGMAN ONLINE MATHIS.
MATHIS SITE COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING FLORA.
FLORA I GRAY -- WHEN -- WHEN I
JONES SAWYER?
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I ROBERT RIVAS
[inaudible]
SALAS.
SOUTH SIDE BILL FOUND OKAY THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU SENATE
MCGUIRE.
AND NEXT -- WILL HAVE SB FOUR
FORTY NINE EXTENDING PIERCE'S
DISEASE AND THE GLASSY WINGED
SHARPSHOOTER MOVE THE BILL.
REPORTER THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I'LL BE A VERY QUICK THIRTY
SECONDS OR LESS LONG STORY SHORT
THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE WORST.
THAT IS IMPACTED THE VERTICAL
TRAIN HISTORY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
HI AND LONG STORY SHORT AS
BEFORE FOUR NINE EXTENDS THE
EXISTING PIERCE'S DISEASE
CONTROL PROGRAM THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY SIX I TO CONTINUE
IMPORTANT RESEARCH.
IN IT ALSO CODIFIES FUNDING FOR
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CONDUCTING
RESEARCH WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I THOUGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FIRST PERSON SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT PLEASE.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL OVER THE
CALIFORNIA'S WINE GRAPE GROWERS
I THINK THE OPRY LEADERSHIP ON
THE BILL THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THE ANALYSIS AGAINST ALL THE
HISTORY OF THE PROGRAM THE
DETAILS.
OF MY GROUP OR INDUSTRIES BOB
THE TWO SEVEN FOUR SIX BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY CALIFORNIA AND ABOUT
HER FOURTEEN BILLION NATIONALLY.
OTHER PIERCE'S DISEASE IS EITHER
IN I IT'S A FORTY SEVEN
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS THE
CROSSWORD SHARPSHOOTER OR IS A
RISK OF PIERCE'S DISEASE SO
EVERY NUMBER THIS COMMITTEE HAS
PERSONS DISEASE OR THE
QUESTIONING SHARPSHOOTERS IN
YOUR DISTRICT.
AND THAT PROPER SHEER I BOUGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
TYLER LACKEY WITH THE WINE
INSTITUTE WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR FOUR NINE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS -- THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN A
GREAT TOOL FOR OUR VINEYARD
OPERATORS TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
NOT JUST PURE SISSIES BUT IN
DISEASES IN THE VINEYARDS AND WE
DO RESPECT AFTER ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
SPEAKING SUPPORT PLEASE NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
MELISSA OR NOR THE FAMILY ONE
MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
A QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YET THAT WE HAD A HEARING
YESTERDAY DEALING WITH THAT
TRADE AND TARIFFS.
WITH THAT MISTER LEVIN SO WE
CAN'T WE CAN'T FIX IT TERRACE
BUT WE CAN DO THIS SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I WOULD RESPECT FASTER I DON'T
THINK SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB FOUR FOUR NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS EGGMAN
BY ADMIN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS SIGNED COOPER CUNNINGHAM.
IN HIM I FLORA.
FLORA I'D GRAY.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I ROBERT RIVAS SALAS.
THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VENTURE THANK YOU COMMITTEE
VERY MUCH OKAY.
AND AS COMMITTEE MEMBERS KNOW WE
HAVE A OVERSIGHT HEARING ON
FAIRS AND HOUSING AND EMERGENCY
STAGING AREAS NEXT.
OR WELCOME TO STAY -- I WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR MAYBE
[inaudible] TWO MINUTES
[inaudible]
YEAH
ADVOCATES.
OF THE MEMBERSHIP.
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
LIKE THAT IS A GREAT.
AHEAD SO WE CAN LIFT THE ROLE.
SB SIXTY SEVEN I'LL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
COOPER.
GRAY HI GREAT I ROBERT RIVAS.
SB FOUR FOUR NINE COOPER.
GRAY HI RAY I ROBERT RIVAS --
OKAY I THINK WE WAITED THE
REQUIRED THAT I GIVE EVERYBODY
AND SO WE WILL OFFICIALLY A CALL
TO AN ADJOURNMENT THE THE
COMMITTEE HEARING.
AND WE WILL OPEN THE HEARING.
ON A FAIR AND EMERGENCY SERVICES.
US SO THANK YOU EVERYBODY VERY
MUCH FOR COMING TODAY FOR THIS
HEARING AS WE KNOW WE HAVE SEEN
MORE AND MORE OF OUR FAIRGROUNDS
BEING USED FOR EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS FOR STAGING.
FOR A WHILE FIRES BOTH FOR
HOUSING FOR HUMANS AS WELL AS
FOR ANIMALS AS WELL AS FOR
EQUIPMENT -- IN THE LAST DECADE
THERE HAVE BEEN COUNTLESS
NUMBERS OF OF INCIDENTS AND SO
WE WANT TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
DO IT BEST -- HOW DO WE BEST USE
OUR RESOURCES SO WE ARE VERY
PLEASED TODAY TO HAVE WITH US
THREE PANELS -- WHO ARE GOING TO
DEAL WITH -- KIND OF OVER VIEWS
OF FAIR AND THE FEARS ROLE
DURING DISASTERS OUR SECOND
PANEL WILL DISCUSS USED AS A
STAGING AREA EMERGENCY SHELTER
FOR ANIMALS PEOPLE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS WITH THE
INFLUX ON THE FAIRGROUNDS.
AND THE PANEL THREE WILL BE HOW
DO WE MOVE FORWARD TO ENSURE
FAIRS CAN CONTINUE. TO BE STRONG
PARTNERS WITH LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL EMERGENCIES.
SERVICES DURING THESE DISASTERS --
SO ON OUR FIRST ONE WE HAVE
KEVIN.
MASS MATTHEW HARPER.
ARE YES THAT MEASURE HOW CAN
CAUSE GHOST AT WOULD DEPUTY
SECRETARY MINISTRATION OF
FINANCE OF CDFA.
AND MITCH MEDICAL WHICH GIVE IT
WILL GIVE EACH DEVRY DIRECTOR OF
LOGISTICS -- FOR YES -- THANK
YOU GERMAN VERY MUCH ANNA PLEASE
FORESHORES.
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- WERE
ACTUALLY ALWAYS PLEASED TO GET
THIS KIND OF ATTENTION TOWARDS
OUR FAIRGROUNDS BECAUSE THEY'RE
VERY VALUABLE ASSETS.
AND THEY HAVE HAD STRUGGLES IN
RECENT YEARS AND I'M NOT GOING
TO BORE YOU GUYS ALL WITH A LOT
OF HISTORY ABOUT THAT BUT
THERE'S BEEN FUNDING SHIFTS THAT
HISTORICALLY THEY WERE FUNDED
THROUGH HORSE RACING ACTIVITIES
AND THEN THAT WENT AWAY. FOR
ABOUT TWO OR THREE FISCAL YEARS
THERE WAS A GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
IN AND ALL THE SUDDEN THAT GOT
PULLED AWAY AND ESSENTIALLY VERY
QUICKLY AND WITHOUT MUCH NOTICE.
AND SAT CREATED A LOT OF
STRUGGLES.
MORE RECENTLY WE HAVE RECEIVED
SOME GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
DIRECTLY FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS WE GOT
SEVEN MILLION -- TWO FISCAL
YEARS AGO AND WE GOT FOUR
MILLION IN THE MOST RECENT
FISCAL YEAR.
AND THAT COMES IN VERY HANDY ON
ALL OF THESE PROPERTIES BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS IF I
HAD A CHANCE I'M SURE THAT
EVERYBODY HEARS VISITED THEIR
LOCAL FAIRS.
BUT AS YOU GO AROUND TO THESE
FACILITIES A LOT OF THEM ARE
VERY AGED AND A LOT OF THEM HAVE
A LOT OF CHALLENGES WITH
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
AND SO IN THE CONTEXT OF WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY
TO USE THESE FOR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE EFFORTS.
YOU CAN SEE HOW IT'S PARAMOUNT
TO HAVE THESE THINGS IN HIS BEST
A CONDITION AS WE CAN BECAUSE AS
MY COLLEAGUE MITCHELL TALK ABOUT
LATER -- ALL THE DIFFERENT
FUNCTIONS AND REQUIREMENTS THAT
NEED TO BE MET AS WE DEPLOY THEM
FOR THOSE PURPOSES -- ARE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT AND YOU REALLY
CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE THIS
REPAIRED Và FACILITIES AND TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE AN EXPECTATION
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN CARRYING OUT THIS
EMERGENCY MISSION.
AS A WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT THAT WE
RECEIVED FOR THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
AND WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE AB
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE THAT SET
ASIDE THREE FOUR SO 1% OF SALES
TAX PROCEEDS THAT COULD BE
ATTRIBUTABLE TO FAIR GROUNDS.
AND THAT'S GENERATED -- THE LAST
ESTIMATE I HEARD WAS ABOUT
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS THEY
CAN ALSO COME BACK TOWARDS THESE
FAIR GROUNDS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND THEN ALSO THAT
MONEY CAN BE USED FOR SOME OF
THE OPERATIONAL SUPPORT.
I'M JUST A QUICKOVERVIEW OF THE
FAIRS I KNOW YOU HAVE THIS
MATERIAL IN YOUR PACKETS -- BUT
THE DISTRICT AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS MAKE UP THE BULK OF
THOSE AND THOSE ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE UNDERNEATH --
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD NAG AS FAR AS
OUR OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY
GOES ON THESE ARE STATE
FACILITIES FORTY ONE OF THEM ARE
STATE OWNED -- OTHER ONES HAVE
DIFFERENT ARRANGEMENTS LIKE
LEAST FROM A LOCALITY OR SOME
OTHER PARTY.
AND THIRD DISPERSED.
ALL OVER THE STATE AND SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT THIS IS
TO THEIR SUCH GOOD ASSETS IN AN
EMERGENCY RESPONSES BECAUSE YOU
NEVER KNOW WHEN EMERGENCIES CAN
OCCUR.
AND FRANKLY YOU DON'T EVEN
REALLY KNOW WHAT THE EMERGENCY
IS GOING TO REQUIRE AND TILL YOU
DEPLOY AND YOU START ASSESSING
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WILDFIRESOBVIOUSLY YOU'RE GONNA
LOOK FOR THE NEAREST LOCATIONS
TO BE ABLE TO STAGE EQUIPMENT
MOVE EVACUEES MOVE ANIMALS THAT
ARE DISPLACED.
THINGS LIKE THAT -- BUT IT WAS
ONLY SO. THREE YEARS AGO NOW
THAT WE HAVE THE OROVILLE DAM --
SITUATION WHERE THERE WAS THE
POSSIBILITY OF HAPPENING
CATASTROPHIC BREACH OF THAT.
AND SO OBVIOUSLY YOU COULD GO TO
THE NEAREST FAIRGROUND AND SO
THEY HAD TO LOOK -- QUITE A BIT
FARTHER OUTSIDE THE REGION TO
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL FAIRGROUNDS
BECAUSE THE SIZE AND SCOPE OF
THE EVACUATION OF THE AND THEN
ALSO THE SPECTER OF WHAT COULD
HAPPEN IF WE STARTED TO
EXPERIENCE THAT FAILURE.
AND SO THAT'S WHY I SAY IT'S
IT'S KIND OF A COMPLICATED THING
THERE IS NO EASY ANSWERS ON A
SIGNING FAIRS OR YOU KNOW PRE
POSITIONING A LOT OF OF OF
EQUIPMENT AND ASSETS TO BE READY
FOR THINGS ALTHOUGH THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT TOOLS TO DO.
AND SO WHAT WE DO AS A
DEPARTMENT IS AS WERE ORGANIZED --
TO DEPLOY ALL OF THIS VERY
QUICKLY WE HAVE A DEDICATED
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT COORDINATOR
BUT WE ALSO HAVE A DEDICATED
BRANCH THAT PROVIDES THE OTHER
AREAS OF OVERSIGHT FOR THE FAIRS
AND EXPOSITIONS.
WE HAVE AFFAIRS AN EXPOSITION
FUND THAT FUNDS -- SOME OF THE
SUPPORT FOR SOME OF THE MORE
FISCALLY STRUGGLING FAIRS.
AS WELL AS HE HANDLES ALL THE
ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES WITH
GETTING THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
MONIES OUT THERE AND VERIFYING
THE PROJECTS AND THINGS OF THAT
SORT.
AND THE STAFF ALSO GO INTO A
DIFFERENT MODE WHEN THEY DO GET
ACTIVATED DURING AN EMERGENCY
PERIOD.
AND THEY BECOME A VITAL LINK IN
THE COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDING
INFORMATIONS ABOUT THE FAIR
GROUNDS -- TO YES AS WELL AS ALL
THE LOCALS THAT MIGHT NEED SOME
OF THAT INFORMATION EVERYTHING
FROM WHAT TYPE.
OF FACILITIES DO YOU HAVE WHAT'S
THE CAPACITY WOULD OF THE SIZE
OF SOME OF THE BUILDINGS A
DIFFERENT THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE SO
DEEPLY INVOLVED IN THIS.
AND ANOTHER THING TO NOTE JUST
TO KEEP ALL THIS IN CONTEXT IS
THAT ADDS TO THE COMPLEXITY OF
FAIRS.
IS THE TRADITIONAL PERCEPTION OF
A FAIR IS IS A ONE TIME FARE OF
AND USUALLY IN GOOD WEATHER
HOPEFULLY NOT TOO OFF THOUGH
BECAUSE SOMETIMES SECOND.
NOT YOUR ATTENDANCE DOWN.
IN SOME FAIRS ARE MORE ACTIVE
AND THEY HAVE A CHANCE HAPPENING
PRETTY FREQUENTLY THEY'LL HAVE
CAR SHOWS OR THINGS LIKE THAT OR
THE ANIMAL EVENTS WHERE THEY
SHALL LIVE STALKER.
THE THINGS LIKE THAT IN SO
PEOPLE FORGET THAT THAT
EMERGENCY FUNCTION OF FAIRS THAT
THAT ASSET IS AVAILABLE THE REST
OF THE TIME.
BUT ALSO THE COMPLEXITY AS AS
WITH THE UNPREDICTABLE NATURE OF
EMERGENCIES AND WHEN YOU DO
DEPLOY AFFAIR.
THEN YOU HAVE TO THROW IN WHY
THE COMPLEXITY OF THEIR FAIR
VANCE OR OTHER EVENTS THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE SCHEDULED.
THAT VERY MUCH UNDER RIGHT THERE
FISCAL VIABILITY.
AND SO SOMETIMES WE LOSE SIGHT
OF THAT AND A LOT OF ACTIVITY
HAPPENS DURING AN EMERGENCY.
AND SO FROM OUR DEPARTMENT'S
PERSPECTIVE WE TRY TO BALANCE
ALL OF THOSE NEEDS AND THAT'S
WHY WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AND WITH ALL THE VARIOUS FAIRS
OUT THERE TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THESE DIFFERENT FACTORS ARE
KNOWN BY EVERYBODY AND THAT THE
COMMUNICATION CHANNELS ARE OPEN
SO THAT THE INFORMATION.
CAN FLOW FREELY AND EVERYBODY
CAN MAKE DECISIONS BASED ON
WHAT'S THE THE BEST WAY TO
RESPOND TO THE EMERGENCY.
AND UTILIZE THE FAIR IN THE BEST
MANNER AVAILABLE -- WITHOUT
ALTERNATE OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM -- YES TO DRILL INTO MORE
SPECIFICS ABOUT EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND HOW THE FAIRGROUNDS
FIT IN WITHOUT WITH SOME FAIRLY
SPECIFIC DETAILS OF WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU KEVIN -- AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS IT'S A
REALLY.
GREAT TO BE HERE TODAY AND AND
TALK ABOUT CRITICAL -- TOPIC
IT'S IMPORTANT TO US -- IT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING FOR ALL OF YOU
BECAUSE EVOLVED SEEN THIS
FIRSTHAND BUT SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN WE'VE HAD PRESS TWELVE
PRESIDENTIAL -- MAJOR DISASTER --
DECLARATIONS HAVE FOR THE STATE
AND TO ACHIEVE THAT NUMBER MEANS
IN A WERE ALWAYS IN EXCESS OF
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN DAMAGE
JUST TO GET TO THAT THRESHOLD TO
QUALIFY SO THIS IS.
AN EXCEPTIONAL TIME AND AND
THERE WAS A TIME AND PLACE WHEN.
VERY FEW FAIRGROUND -- MANAGERS
WERE IN FACT PROFICIENT AT
HAVING TO USE -- AND ALL OF THE
DISASTER -- AREAS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT HERE.
THAT IS NO LONGER THE CASE NOW --
JUST IN THE LAST TWO YEARS WE
HAVE FORTY THREE DIFFERENT
FAIRGROUNDS -- THAT WERE USED
AND UTILIZED OUT THERE SO WE
START TALKING ABOUT --
SHELTERING OPERATIONS WHICH IS
USUALLY THE PRIMARY PIECE THAT --
COMES UP AS AS WE CAN WITH OF
ACTIVITIES.
BUT BEFORE THAT THEY'RE STARTING
TO BE USED TO STAGING AREAS
RIGHT AWAY FOR FIRST RESPONDERS --
WE START MOVING -- SUPPLIES
MATERIALS THERE FOR THEM WE USE
MISS POINT TO DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS -- THERE'S JUST A
MULTITUDE OF REASONS THAT WE USE --
THE FAIRGROUNDS NOW AS PART OF
OUR RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
EFFORTS OF FOR US.
I WAS PLEASED TO SEE ON THE
AGENDA -- MANY OF THE THE
REPRESENTATIVES COME TO TALK TO
US BECAUSE JUST LOOKING BACK
RECENTLY HERE WITH DIXON AND
SILVER DOLLAR AND NAPA AND BUTTE --
ALL OF THEM ANSWERED THE CALL --
WHEN WE NEEDED THEM -- THEY WERE
QUICK TO RESPOND AND TO OPEN
THEIR ARMS AND BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
WHAT WE CALL THE WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT RESPONSE TAKES PLACE --
FOR THESE DISASTERS SO FOR US.
HAVING SAID ALL THAT I DO I DO
KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME AREAS
THAT YOU WANT TO HEAR ABOUT WERE
AND WE CAN MOVE PROVED IT'S AND
SO I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TELL YOU WERE -- WE
WERE CAN IN HAND WITH -- CDFA --
ON A REGULAR BASIS AND TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE TRENDS THAT
WE HAVE SEEN SO -- DURING.
AND THIS DOESN'T APPLY TO ALL
JUST WANNA GIVE SOME GOOD
GENERALIZATION SO.
MANY THERE IS WE GO TO SOON AS
WE GET -- START DEALING WITH
SHELTERING OPERATIONS -- WITHIN
THE WITHIN THE FAIRGROUNDS -- WE
START SEEING SOME ADA COMPLIANCE
ISSUES THAT ARE THEIR THEIR
CHALLENGE FORCE WEATHERED
SHOWERS -- BATHROOMS -- AND
OTHER FACILITIES WICH ARE
AUGMENTING THOSE RIGHT AWAY WITH
PORTABLES BUT THERE'S A TIME AND
AND AND OBVIOUSLY -- A TIME
COMPONENT THAT HAS TO BE THERE
TOGETHER STUFF MOVED IN AND
WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO GET FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND BROUGHT INTO SITES -- BUT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WORK ON
AGGRESSIVELY AND THEN --
ACTUALLY EVERY TIME WE HAVE A
DISASTER WE DISPATCH SOMEBODY
FROM OUR OFFICE IT'S AN EIGHTY
SPECIALIST AND GOES OFF THEIR
SHORES LOOKING RIGHT AWAY.
AND WE START WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT CDSS CDFA AMERICAN
RED CROSS AND OTHERS -- FEMA AND
START TRYING TO BRING RESOURCES
AND TO AUGMENT THEM.
ANOTHER AREA THAT -- WE SEE --
THAT'S ALWAYS AN ISSUE ONE IS IS
THE COLOCATION AT SHELTERS WITH
PETS AND ANIMALS SO -- TO
FASTENING DISCUSSION BECAUSE
WHAT WAS TRADITIONALLY A CAT AND
DOG -- THIS KIND OF OPENED UP
AND YOU HAVE A MORPHING OF OF
WHAT IS YOUR PET AND AND WHAT DO
YOU WANT THEIR HOW WHAT
ALLERGIES DO YOU HAVE -- HOW DO
YOU REACT RUN THOSE ANIMALS --
AND SO -- WHAT WE SEE IS A LOT
OF FOLKS THAT BRING THEIR CARS
FOR TRAILERS IN -- WE SELL IT
REPETITIVELY THEIR PARKING IN
THE PARKING LOT FOR TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE SERVICES THE
MEALS SHOWERS EVERYTHING ELSE
BUT MANY CASES ARE SLEEPING IN
THEIR TRAILER OR THEIR CAR
BECAUSE THEIR PETS FOR THEIR AND
ARE KEEPING THEIR WITH THEM --
FOR THAT SO -- WE CONTINUE TO
WORK THAT TRY TO FIND THE RIGHT
SOLUTION THE RIGHT ANSWER IT'S
HARD -- JUST IN A IN A GROUP
SETTING WHERE YOU HAVE PEOPLE --
ON TOP OF ONE ANOTHER AND IN AN
EMERGENCY THERE'S ALREADY ENOUGH
STRESS AND SO.
WHAT CAN BE GOOD IT CAN ALSO BE --
A CHALLENGE FOR OTHERS AND SO
FINDING THE RIGHT BALANCE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE TAKE US
SERIOUSLY AND ARE ALWAYS WORKING
FOR A GOOD SOLUTION.
ON THE OTHER AREA -- FOR US IS
THAT -- WIFI INTERNET -- IT'S
NOT UNCOMMON FOR SOMEBODY TO
COME OUT AND NOT HAVE ANYTHING
OTHER THAN.
OTHER SMARTPHONE ON THEM AND SO --
FEW HOURS THAT PHONE MIGHT NOT
BE CHARGED AND SO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING AGGRESSIVELY WITH OUR
CARRIERS AND THEY TEND TO BRING
IN CHARGING STATIONS FOR US TO
BRING IN A WIFI HOTSPOT --
USUALLY CALL THE CULTURE CALLOUS
SELLING TOWER A LIGHT TRUCK HER
CELL ON I WE'LL SEE IN A CAO CAO.
AND THEY'LL TURN AROUND THE
BRING THOSE IN.
THEY WORK OKAY -- JUST DEPENDS
ON THE POPULATION DENSITY IS
HAVE THERE SO -- IF IT'S A
REALLY -- IMPACTED FAIRGROUND
AND THEN THAT THAT CONNECTIVE
ITTY IS GOING TO BE A PRETTY
SLOW IT'S LIGHT AND AND SMALL
AND THEY WORK FINE -- FOR THE
SMALL NUMBER THERE SO -- BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE BETTER BECAUSE WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH YOUR
INSURANCE CARRIER TALKING YOUR
FAMILY AND FRIENDS -- HAVING
GOOD CONNECTIVITY IS OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT -- FOR EVERYBODY
THAT'S USED IN THE SITE -- REAL
HANDLING EQUIPMENT SO IT'S NOT
JUST LIKE IN A CONTROL START
DROPPING SUPPLIES RIGHT AWAY
INTO AN AREA THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE BALLOTS -- PALLET TRUCK
JACK'S -- FORKLIFTS THE ABILITY
TO MOVE THAT MATERIAL AROUND AND
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT ON THAT CAN
CREATE A DELAY THERE SO -- WE
JUST SEE A WIDE VARIANCE OF OF
PREPARATIONS AT EACH SITE THAT
WERE OPERATING AND SOME ARE
BETTER PREPARED THAN OTHERS AND
HAVE BETTER RESOURCES AND THEN
FINALLY.
I WOULD SAY -- SYSTEM
INFRASTRUCTURE -- AS POINTED OUT --
BY KEVIN YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE
ARE MANY CASES THERE'S DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THERE SO IF YOU HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH -- INFRASTRUCTURE --
WITH WATER OR WITH SEWER OR WITH --
POWER OUR H. BACK -- ESPECIALLY
A HOT DAY LIKE IT IS TODAY --
THAT BECOMES A CHALLENGE -- FOR
THE EVACUEES ARE THOSE ARE USING
THE SITE.
SO AFTER EACH DISASTER WE SIT
DOWN AND WE GET WITH OUR OUR
PARTNERS AND WE START WORKING ON
AN AFTER ACTION REPORT AND WE
MERELY START FIGURE OUT WHERE IS
IF THERE IS A WE CAN IMPROVE AND
WHAT WE CAN DO BETTER.
AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS
THAT -- AND START LOOKING FOR
SOLUTIONS IN TRYING TO GUIDE --
OUR PARTNER AGENCIES AND THOSE
THAT WERE WORKING WITH EITHER
THAT STORE GRANT OR THROUGH
ANOTHER FUN SOURCES THAT ARE
THERE OR FOR YOURSELVES
OBVIOUSLY AND ANYTHING THAT CAN
BRING.
ON IMPROVE THE RESILIENCY OF THE
READINESS OF THESE FAIRGROUND SO
THAT -- WHEN WE DO NEED THEM --
THAT THEY'RE IN AN OPTIMAL SHAPE --
FOR USAGE -- WHAT?
IN ADDITION TO WHAT I POINTED
OUR SOME THERE IS IMPROVEMENT
HERE IS THAT -- ARE WORKING WELL
GOOD COMMUNICATIONS RIGHT NOW --
IT'S AMAZING HOW HOW WELL --
THAT'S WORKING ON HOW QUICKLY
WERE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THEIR ONE A LOT OF PREPARATION
IT'S BEEN DONE FOR SITE MAP SOME
LAYOUTS THAT REDUCES TIME INTO
SO -- DISORGANIZATION AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE RESPONSE EFFORT
BECAUSE THEY'VE MAPPED OUT WHERE
THEY WANT RESOURCES TO GO --
WHEN YOU COME INTO A THE
FAIRGROUNDS THAT'S A GREAT AREA
AND THEN THERE'S BEEN -- AN
INCREASED AMOUNT OF TRAINING
THAT WE'VE SEEN -- AT THE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND PART OF
THAT IS OF COURSE IN THE
INCREASED ACTIVITY -- THAT WE'VE
HADHERE IN THE STATE -- SO
THOSE KIND OF GO HAND IN HAND SO
THAT PROFICIENCIES LED -- TO
MORE EXPERTISE AND THEREFORE HAS
REDUCED A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT --
YOU SEE THERE -- WE CONTINUE TO
DO TRAINING TOGETHER -- WE DID
LAST YEAR WE DID -- THE YELLOW
COMMAND EXERCISE AT THE BAY AREA
AND AND WE USED TO OUR FOR OUR
PERSON IS THERE AND THEN -- CFA
LEAD SO WHAT WE CALL EMERGENCY
SUPPORT FUNCTION -- ELEVEN IT'S
A CRITICAL -- SUPPORT FUNCTION
IT'S PART OF OUR A STATE
EMERGENCY PLANNING AND AND HOW
WE PROTECT LIFE AND PROPERTY AND
A COORDINATED RESPONSE IN THERE
THE PRIMARY LEAD.
UP FOR THAT WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS THEIR THEIR HAVING
SAID THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
AND MOVE FURTHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO DO YOU HAVE LIKE
BEST PRACTICES THAT YOU HAVE
COORDINATED TOGETHER.
AND I KNOW -- IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN CDFA THEY DID A REPORT ON
FAIRS AND DISASTER AND HAD ABOUT
A DOZEN RECOMMENDATIONS.
HOW HOW IS THAT IMPLEMENTATION
GOING OR ISN'T IS IT EVEN STILL
RELEVANT SOME ALMOST A DECADE
LATER AS WE CONTINUE TO EVOLVE?
I THINK WHAT'S RELEVANT IS
LOOKING AT THAT FRAMEWORK OF
IDENTIFYING SOME OF THESE
DEFICIENT AREAS AND THEN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH BOTH
AGENCIES TO ADDRESS THAT AND
COME UP WITH WAYS THAT WE FEEL
WOULD MITIGATE THAT.
AND WE ACTUALLY DID LOOK BACK
OVER THAT IN A LOT OF THOSE
AREAS HAD BEEN ADDRESSED -- ONE
OF THINGS THAT ALSO HAPPENS ON A
ROUTINE BASIS AND THIS IS
ACTUALLY MULTI AGENCY.
IS IS THAT THERE'S ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MEETINGS HELD OUT AT
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
FOR EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
AND SO THERE'S ALWAYS A
CONTINUAL DIALOGUE IN AN
EXAMINATION OF THE BEST
PRACTICES ACROSS A MULTITUDE OF
DIFFERENT TYPE OF EMERGENCY
SCENARIOS.
OF WHICH OBVIOUSLY WE PLAY A BIG
ROLE BECAUSE OF THE FAIRGROUNDS --
BUT ALSO ANY OF THEM THAT MIGHT
INCLUDE ELEMENTS OF A FOOD
PRODUCTION OR AGRICULTURAL
ISSUES AND HOW THAT MIGHT IMPACT
THEM.
AND SO LIKE I SAY I MEAN THAT'S
A MULTI AGENCY EFFORT WE ATTEND
THOSE MEETINGS I BELIEVE
QUARTERLY.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
AGENCIES COME TOGETHER SO THE
WHOLE EFFORT OF EXAMINING BEST
PRACTICES AND HAVING GOOD ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT'S WORKING.
OCCURS ACROSS A LOT OF THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND STATE
GOVERNMENT.
AND AND I WOULD ECHO THAT --
MANY THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
TAKEN HEART AND ADDRESSED --
THERE THERE'S A FEW THAT.
HAD NOT BUT FOR THE MOST PART
THEY'VE ALL BEEN ADDRESS FORMAT
AND THEN FROM.
AS THE GROUP TECHNOLOGY AND
ORDERS RELIANCE ON TECHNOLOGY IS
CHANGE SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE HAD.
AND REALLY THE FOCUS -- THERE'S
IN THAT PRIMARY CORE COMPETENCY
THAT THEY DEAL WITH -- FOR
ANIMALS AND THAT IS A CORE
KAPATID AT THAT -- A SEE IF IT
HAS TO BE A READY -- FOR BUT WE
SEEN SUCH A A LARGE USAGE ON
THOSE OTHER AREAS -- THAT'S KIND
OF CHANGED -- THAT SHIFT AND SO
WE'VE OF MADE A A GREATER FOCUS
TOGETHER AND AND MEETING
REGULARLY AND WE'RE TO CONTINUE
TRAINING AND ADDRESSES ISSUES.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE A LOCALS
COME UP AND TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW
THEIR EXPERIENCE AS WELL SO I
MEAN SITTING UP HERE FROM THE
STATE LEVEL WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
WOULD BE THE ISSUE THEIR BIGGEST.
THE BIGGEST COMPLIMENT. TO HOW
THE THIS INTERACTION WITH THE
STATE GOES AND THEIR BIGGEST
COMPLAINT ABOUT WHAT WE COULD DO
BETTER.
WHAT YOU START?
JUMP IN.
WELL THE BIGGEST.
COMPLIMENT IS IS HAVING THE
ACCESSIBILITY AND THE RAPID
NISSEN WHICH WE CAN GET THE
ASSET DEPLOYED AND BEGIN THE
ACTIVITIES BECAUSE WE CAN JUST
DEAL DIRECTLY WITH SOMEBODY WHO
IS THERE UNDERSTANDS THE
CONDITIONS OF THE CAPABILITIES.
AND CAN ALSO RESPOND TO THOSE
INITIAL FLURRY OF QUESTIONS THAT
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AS
TO WHAT YOU HAVE WHAT YOU NEED
THINGS LIKE THAT -- AS FAR AS
WHAT I WOULD SEE IS SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS TO BE IMPROVED.
WOULD BE I THINK PROBABLY AT THE
STATE LEVEL HAVING A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF SOME OF THE
LOCAL CHALLENGES THAT THEY MIGHT
FACE.
AND A LOT OF TIMES WE END UP
DEALING WITH SOME OF THOSE
CHALLENGES AT THE SAME TIME
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE EMERGENCY
WHICH ISN'T ALWAYS THE BEST
ENVIRONMENT -- FORGE OUT SOME
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE AGREEABLE TO
EVERYBODY ON MOVING FORWARD.
AND SO I GUESS IF I WAS GONNA
SAY ONE THING WE COULD DO A
BETTER JOB OF THIS IS IN BETWEEN
INCIDENTS.
IS IS.
TO HAVE A COMMUNICATION CHANNEL
IN PLACE WERE CONTINUALLY HAVING
THAT DIALOGUE THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY FOCUSED ON AFTER
ACTION FROM THE LAST EVENT OR
SPECIFIC TO WHAT WE ANTICIPATE
IS WHAT MIGHT BE IN OF THAT BUT
JUST IN GENERAL.
YOU KNOW HOW THINGS WORKING AT
THAT FAIR GROUND IN OUR THEIR
CHALLENGES LOCALLY THAT WE THINK
MIGHT BE IMPORTANT FOR US TO
KNOW SO THAT ONCE WE DO GET INTO
THAT ENVIRONMENT OF RESPONDING
TO AN EMERGENCY.
THAT WERE AWARE OF IT COGNIZANT
OF IT AND CAN.
YOU KNOW MOVE WITH A LITTLE BIT
BETTER CLASS MOVES NESS IF YOU
WILL TO BE ABLE TO DO WHAT WE
NEED TO DO.
AND WE HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN PLACE THAT EVERY GROUNDS HAS
LIKE A EMERGENCY PLAN BUT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IF SOMETHING
HAPPENS LIKE A PRE ASSESSMENT
APPROACH.
OR IS IT THAT THE MERGE THESE
TWO FLUID TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT --
I WOULD SAY EMERGENCIES MIGHT BE
A LITTLE TOO FLUID THERE'S
EVERYBODY HAS PLANS IN PLACE.
AND I'VE NEGLECTED TO MENTION
EARLIER TO THAT WE PUT OF MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL AND THAT
INCLUDES A COMPONENT FOR US TO
INCREASE OUR FOOTPRINT THE
ANIMAL CARES ARENA WHICH IS ALSO
RESPONSIBILITY OF OURS -- BUT
THROUGH BUDGET ISSUES OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS WE HADTO REDUCE
SOME OF OUR STAFFING RESOURCES
THERE WE OPERATED IT BY TAPPING
INTO EXPERTISE AROUND THE
DEPARTMENT WORD EXISTED.
WHICH WORKS FOR THE MOST PART
UNTIL IT DOESN'T AND HONESTLY
CAMP SHOWED US THAT IT DID WORK
THAT WELL BECAUSE WE HAD -- A
FOREIGN ANIMAL DISEASE THAT
STILL ON GOING DOWN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE HAD A LOT OF
PEOPLE DEDICATED.
TO AND SO IT REALLY STRETCH TO
OUR BENCH IF YOU WILL OF WHO WE
COULD TAP INTO TO RESPOND.
AND SHOW THE NEED TO HAVE
DEDICATED STAFF RESOURCES TO NOT
ONLY BE READY TO RESPOND AND
PERFORM THEIR ANIMAL CARES
FUNCTIONS.
BUT ALSO TO CARRY OUT THE
TRAINING IN THE HELP WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT UPDATING OF ALL
THESE DIFFERENT PLANS OF WHICH
THAT'S A BIG COMPONENT IN THE
FAIRGROUNDS IS HOW ARE WE GONNA
SHELTER ANIMALS.
ARE WE GONNA HANDLE THEM WHAT
TYPES OF ANIMALS IN AS MITCHELL
MENTIONED EARLIER JUST ASSESSING
DIFFERENT POSSIBILITIES WITH
WHEN YEAR COHABITATING DIFFERENT
TYPES OF ANIMALS LARGE AND SMALL
AND YOU KNOW.
WHAT WHAT ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
WE SHOULD ANTICIPATE BEST
PRACTICES TO HAVE IN PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT AS BEST WE CAN
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES?
AND SO WE'RE KEEPING OUR FINGERS
CROSSED THAT.
ARE PROPOSAL AS SUBMITTED WILL
BECOME PART OF THE ENACTED
BUDGET AND WILL BEGIN THE HIRING
PROCESS AND HAVE THOSE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE SO THEY'LL DEFINITELY
BE SPENDING A LOT OF TIME WITH
ALL THE DIFFERENT FAIRS LOOKING
AT THESE PLANS AND HELPING THEM
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
BE.
READY.
AND I WOULD.
CLING I WOULD ADD TO THAT IS
THAT I THINK -- IN ANOTHER
FAIRGROUNDS WANT TO FAIL THEY
THEY WANT TO PUT THE BEST FOOT
FORWARD A LEGITIMATE IN THE
OTHER TRYING AND WE'VE.
TAX THEM IN WAYS THAT WE HAD NOT
SEEN BEFORE AND YOU LOOK AT
DIXON AND WHAT THEY HAD TO DO.
WITH THE RELOCATION OF THE
HOSPITAL AND AND WITH -- THE
UNIQUE -- CHALLENGES THAT THEY
FACE AND SOME OF THE LONG TERM
HOUSING THAT WE'VE HAD TO DEAL
IN SOME LOCATIONS -- WE'RE
ALWAYS TRYING TO LEAVE THE SITE
IN BETTER CONDITION THAT WE HAD
IT -- BUT THAT'S A CHALLENGE FOR
THEM AND I THINK THEY I THINK.
THEY WOULD OBVIOUSLY LOVE TO
HAVE MORE RESOURCES TO HAVE A A
BETTER CONDITION SO THAT THEIR
SET I MEAN THAT'S JUST.
OF FORT.
BUT YOU CAN GO MANY YEARS
WITHOUT HAVING ANY ISSUES LIKE
WE DID.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN -- BELIEVE TAKEOVER LIKE
WE'VE HAD NOW AND IT'S JUST BEEN.
ON A REGULAR BASIS AND SO -- YOU
KNOW HOW YOU YOU KNOW WHERE THAT
WHERE THOSE INVESTMENTS ARE AND
AND HOW THEY CAN DO IT.
AND THEN OF COURSE THE AS SECOND
POINT OUT LOS REVENUE IS A
CHALLENGE -- FOR THE FAIRGROUNDS
IT'S TOUGH AND MEAN OBVIOUSLY
WERE RENTING IT AT A FAIR RATE
WHEN WE COME IN RENTS SPACE OUT
AND SET UP LEASES -- WITH THE
SITES BUT IN THE THIRD THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY COSTS THAT THEY'VE
LOST AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT AND
SO -- IT'S SOMETHING THAT SAYS
AS CHALLENGE FOR THEM WHEN THAT
HAPPENS COURSE ARE DEALING WITH
PEOPLE HAVE LOST EVERYTHING SO
YOU'RE TRYING TO BALANCE OUT HOW
I TAKE CARE OF MY LOCAL
COMMUNITY WHO.
HAS LOST THEIR HOMES WITH OKAY
HAVE LOST A POTENTIAL REVENUE
TIME IN THERE AND SO I WE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE.
ON THE STRUGGLES IN THE
CHALLENGES AND EMOTIONAL --
COMPONENT THAT.
AND I THINK THEY WOULD LIKE US
TO PROBABLY DO A BETTER JOB ON
POST EVENT WHEN WE'RE TRYING --
TO SHUT DOWN OPERATIONS -- IN A
SOMETIMES THERE'S A DELAY IN
THERE'S A CHALLENGE WITH CERTAIN
FOLKS FOR LEADING OTHER SHELTERS
AND HOW THAT'S COMMUNICATED IN --
ELIGIBILITY AND FOR THOSE THAT
ARE -- NOT NECESSARILY THAT
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF SERVICES ALL
THE WAY TO THE VERY VERY END.
AND ARE I'M SLOW -- TO EXTRACT
THEMSELVES ON TO SAY THAT.
THE QUESTIONS MISTER CHOI.
AND AND I THANK YOU FOR A FOR
BEING HERE AND IN A PREVIOUS
LIFE IN MY MISSPENT YOUTH
OCTAMER TO BIRD IS COORDINATOR
FOR STATE LOS ANGELES.
AND I WENT THROUGH FLOODS AND
EARTHQUAKES AND WHY THINGS WE
DIDN'T REALLY PREPARE.
FOR WAS WE HAD A LITTLE BITTY
PARAGRAPH CALL RIGHT.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN NINETY TWO
WHERE BROILED IN THE LARGEST
CIVIL.
UNREST IN HISTORY.
OF THE COUNTRY.
AND WE WEREN'T REALLY PREPARED
BECAUSE NOBODY EVER THOUGHT.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT OF THAT
MAGNITUDE AND THAT'S WHAT REALLY
MESSES UP OR YOU KNOW WE WE
START TO GET.
YOU KNOW IT WAS A TIME WE JUST
HAVE FLOOD UNNOTICED SOUNDS
WEIRD NOW BUT IT WAS A TIME IN
THE EIGHTIES WHERE.
I HAD TO BUY MILLIONS OF
SANDBAGS TO STOP LOS ANGELES
FROM FLOATING AWAY -- BUT WE
BECAME PRETTY GOOD AT THAT
BECAUSE YOU GOT PRACTICE BEING
PRETTY GOOD AT DEALING WITH
EARTHQUAKES I THINK WE COULD
HAVE BEEN DEALT WITH A TSUNAMI
BUT SOMETHING OF MAN MADE --
CATASTROPHE COULDN'T DEAL WITH
AND SO MY QUESTION IS REALLY
KIND OF I'VE HEARD YOU SPEAK OF
A LOT OF THINGS THAT YOU KINDA.
CAN PREDICT AND AND MAYBE I WANT
TO PUT ONE THING ON YOUR OF THE
THINGS YOU YOU NEED TO LOOK AT
IS -- THE HOMELESS SITUATION.
IF ALL OF A SUDDEN EVEN IF IT'S
JUST A SMALL COLONY A SMALL
GROUP OF PEOPLE TO SHOW UP AT
THESE DISASTER AT THE STILL
CONTACTS TO STILL GO TO SEE STI.
WE STILL GO TO EMMITSBURG OFFER
TRAINING ON ALL OF THE ABOVE
OKAY -- IF THEY SHOW UP -- THEY
HAVE UNIQUE SET OF OF CHALLENGES
THAT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO DEAL
WITH WHICH YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH
AND YOU'RE PUTTING TOGETHER
THOSE TWO COMMUNITIES.
AND I I DO HEAR ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS OR PEOPLE
BRINGING IN.
DRUGS INTO THAT DOES DISASTER
ACTION ON CENTERS I REMEMBER
PEOPLE BEING AFTER SEVERAL
ARRESTS.
BEING THERE FOR SIX MONTHS.
OR MORE -- BECAUSE THEY LOST THE
BUSINESSES AND HOMES AND SO UP.
IN YOUR AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT ALL
OF THIS BECAUSE YOU COULD BE A
STAGING AREA FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
IT AND YOU LOOKED INTO MAYBE THE
OTHER SERVICES THAT YOU WOULD
NORMALLY THINK ABOUT IN A
REGULAR DISASTER.
FROM -- YES SIDE -- WE CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH THOSE CHALLENGES
THAT'S WHY CDSS A SUCH A A
CRITICAL COMPONENT AND THEN THE
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH -- TEAMS ARE
THERE IDENTIFYING -- AND WORKING
HAND IN HAND COLLABORATIVE THEY
ARE YOU KNOW WHERE THEY EXISTING
PRE EXISTING HOMELESS.
THE PRESIDING MENTAL HEALTH CARE
RECEIVERS AND THEN HOW TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES IS ARE
GOING INTO IT -- WE DO THAT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE ART
AMERICAN RED CROSS AND WE DO
THAT -- AT THE COUNTY SHELTERS
THAT WERE WORKING WITH THEIR
WHEN WE ARE ESTABLISHING THEM.
A HAND IN HAND OF COURSE --
WE'RE LOOKING AT EVERYTHING IN A
HOLE OF A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
ALL MERGING MANAGEMENT AND I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH YOU --
WE'VE -- HAD A OUR FAIR SHARE OF
OF MUD SLIDES AND FIRES AND
EARTHQUAKES AND OTHER ISSUES OF
TAKE PLACE AND OFFICE OPEN WE
WOULD HAVE TO GO OVER THE RIGHT
WORD HERE ALREADY -- BUT WE'VE
WE PRETTY MUCH COVERED
EVERYTHING ELSE AND AND OUR
PLAYBOOK AND BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS -- CHALLENGE FORCING WE
CONTINUE WORK REALLY CLOSELY
WITH THEM AND I WILL TAKE THAT
ARE.
THE EFFORT ON CBS FACE
PERSPECTIVE AND FROM THE FAIRS
AND I AM SURE THAT SOME OF OUR
SUBSEQUENT PANELS PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE BETTER INFORMATION TO SHARE
BUT SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
DID DESCRIBE I THINK WE'RE
ACTUALLY EXPERIENCE IN A RECENT
EVENTS.
WHERE WE HAD HOMELESS
POPULATIONS WHO SAW THE
AVAILABILITY THE SERVICES
UTILIZE THEM BUT THEN IT WAS A
CHALLENGE BECAUSE IT'S -- YOU
KNOW NOT.
TRYING TO TRANSITION THEM BACK
INTO -- TRADITIONAL HOUSING
SITUATION BE THAT GOING TO A
HOTEL STAYING WITH RELATIVES.
YOU KNOW THEIR SITUATION ON THAT
FRONT DOESN'T CHANGE.
AND SO I THINK FOR US WILL
CONTINUE -- TO BE OPENED
UNDERSTANDING THESE DYNAMICS
EXIST OUT THERE AND TO JUST BE --
WILLING AND ABLE PARTNER TO ALL
THE OTHER AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT OUR FACILITIES THAT WITH
THOSE SERVICES BECOME AVAILABLE
AND THAT WE DO WHAT WE NEED TO
DO. TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
HAPPENS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
STREET IS MISSING.
OKAY -- WHAT PREMIERES?
STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE -- I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN SOME LEGISLATION TO
ALLOW FOR BOTH.
HOUSING THE HOMELESS AS WELL AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY DO ON FAIRGROUNDS
PROPERTY.
IS THAT ARE THOSE VIABLE ISSUES
AND AND HOW HOW WOULD THE MIX
BECOME AT A TIME OF AN EMERGENCY
THAT -- THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION AND ACTUALLY -- I WAS
HAVING A DISCUSSION EARLIER
TODAY ABOUT THAT BECAUSE WE'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF WORKING ON
INFORMATION THAT'S BEING
DEVELOPED BY DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES TO ASSESS ALL
THE STATE OWNED PROPERTIES OF
WHICH THE DISTRICT AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS ARE A SUBSET OF
THAT.
AND THAT IS ONE OF THE FACTORS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS HOW
BEST TO WE ADDRESS.
THAT BALANCE BETWEEN HAVING
PROPERTIES THAT MIGHT HAVE
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES.
BUT COUPLED UP TO THE FACT THAT
IF WE DO THAT ARE WE POSITIONING
OURSELVES TO NOT HAVE BEEN
INADEQUATE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
SHOULD THAT OCCUR.
SO YEAH I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER
FOR YOU BUT I HAVE AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THAT IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT -- WE
ARE CONSIDERING AS WE WORK
THROUGH THIS EXERCISE OF
ASSESSING THOSE PROPERTIES AND
WHAT THE POTENTIAL IS FOR USING
THEM.
AND OBVIOUSLY IF OF THE SHELTERS
ARE COMPLETELY OCCUPIED AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE A USABLE
LOCATION FOR SAID IT JUST
BECOMES A BURGER CHALLENGE
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT A STAGING
AREA OR LOCATION -- BRINGING ME
THE FIRST RESPONDERS TO COME.
TO AN ESTABLISH FALLEN
OPERATIONS WHICH HAVE TO FIND A
DIFFERENT LOCATION FROM IT SO
IT'S JUST A QUESTION OF A PRIOR
WHICH HIRES PRIORITY FOR THE A
LOCAL FOLKS ARE THERE OF USE OF
THE SHELTER SAID AND THAT
POPULATION BASE SIR.
OKAY ANY FINAL THOUGHTS FROM.
AND IT BUT I THINK WE'LL BOTH
STICK AROUND THREE YOUR PANEL
DISCUSSIONS IN CASE ANY
QUESTIONS COME UP AND HE NEEDS
MORE INFORMATION FROM US. TO BE
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH GEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY -- PANEL TO IS GOING
TO DISCUSS FAIRS AS A STAGING
AREA EMERGENCY SHELTER FOR
ANIMAL PEOPLE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS -- AND THE INFLUX ON FAIR
GROUNDS AND THAT'S GOING TO BE --
REBEKAH BARTLEY CEO OF CINEMA
COUNTY FAIR AND EVENT CENTER.
EARLY MORE DEPUTY GENERAL
MANAGER OF DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS
STEEP KENNY CEO BUTTE COUNTY
FAIR AND RICK PICKERING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR.
WELCOME EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU -- BECKY BARLING CEO
OF THE SNOW MY COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS A THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
NOT ONLY ON EVACUATIONS BUT ON
EVERYTHING ELSE YOU DO TO
SUPPORT AGRICULTURE SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE TIME.
I USED TO SAY THAT I WAS
PROBABLY THE ONLY FAIR MANAGER
THAT HAD THE DISTINCTION OF
BEING THREE THREE EVACUATIONS
AND UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE CASE ANYMORE -- IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE I ACTUALLY
WAS -- THE CO -- WITH THE DEL
MAR FAIRGROUNDS RACETRACK.
AND WE DID EVACUATION IS THERE.
A TWO THOUSAND ANIMALS AT THAT
TIME. TWO THOUSAND SEVEN WE
EVACUATED -- OVER TWO THOUSAND
ANIMALS ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED PEOPLE.
SO -- DEFINITELY A REAL EYE
OPENER AND EXPERIENCE. TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN I WAS --
SEVENTEEN I WAS THE CEO OF THE
SOME COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS.
AND DURING THOSE WILDFIRES AS
YOU ALL REMEMBER WE EVACUATED
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE AND
A FIVE HUNDRED ANIMALS.
OF HAD ABOUT FIFTY NINE HUNDRED
CAL FIRE FOLKS -- NATIONAL GUARD --
RED CROSS SO HEAD A LITTLE
EXPERIENCE IN IN THIS YEAR NOT
WILDFIRES BUT TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN WE DID EVACUATIONS FOR
FLOODS IN THE CURRENT BILL AREA.
SO -- AS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
MENTIONED -- FAIRGROUNDS NOT
ONLY DO FAIRS AN INTERIM OF ANTS.
AND PROVIDE ALL KINDS OF
ENTERTAINMENT AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SMALL BUSINESSMEN AND WOMEN
WE ALSO PROVIDE -- MAZING
SERVICE AND EVACUATIONS --
CALIFORNIA NETWORK AFFAIRS
PROVIDES ALL OF THOSE THINGS
YEAH ON FAIRS.
OUR GREAT OF FOR MAKE
EVACUATIONS BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE IN THE BACKGROUND
WE'RE WE'RE OF IT MANAGERS -- WE
HAVE HOUSING FOR LARGE ANIMALS --
HORSE STALLS ARENAS SMALL ANIMAL
HOUSING FACILITIES WE HAVE THE
TEAMS THAT ARE SKILLED -- IN IN
A VENN COORDINATION WHICH DURING
EVACUATION LIKE THIS REQUIRES A
LOT OF SKILL AND KNOWLEDGE WITH
THAT -- WE ALSO HAVE EXISTING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH AW
ENFORCEMENT AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES HONOR WE USE UTILIZE
THOSE SERVICES ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
ALL THE FAIRS NETWORKS HAVE
TEAMS THAT ARE SKILLED IN
HANDLING LIVESTOCK.
AND RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE GAY
COMMUNITY.
THAT ASSIST GREATLY IN FINDING
OF VOLUNTEERS TO HELP IN YOUR
ANIMAL EVACUATIONS.
WE HAVE EXISTING TEAM TO HANDLE
JANITORIAL AND MAINTENANCE FOR
ALL -- SO OPERATIONS -- MY TEAM
PARTICULARLY -- NOT ONLY IN DEL
MAR BUT ALSO IN SONOMA HELPED
ESSENTIALLY -- FOR ALMOST A
MONTH -- CAL FIRE WITH MOVIE IN
A MOVE OUT OF SUPPLIES AND ALSO
WITH RED CROSS.
AND THEN ALSO CLEAN THE
RESTROOMS ARE PICKING UP GARBAGE
IN THE TYPICAL THINGS THAT YOU
DO A FAIR.
BUT DURING EVACUATION.
RED CROSS IF YOU DON'T KNOW ARE
BASICALLY ALTHOUGH IN TWO YEARS
AND THEY'RE TURNED OVER ON A
REGULAR BASIS SO THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF CONSISTENCY.
SO -- AT THE FAIR BECOMES REALLY
THE OVERSEER OF THE OPERATIONS --
WHICH IS INTERCALATED DISCS THE
SUCCESS OF WHAT HAPPENS FAIRS%
HOLD DOWN THE FORT UNTIL THE
CALVARY GETS THERE.
FAIRGROUNDS ARE NOW MAKE
EVACUATION SITES AND IT AND
INITIALLY -- IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN OF THE THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY -- YES THEY HAD
PLANNED ON SMALL CENTERS -- HIGH
SCHOOL GYMS AND CHURCHES AND
THAT KIND OF THING AND THEN
REALIZED QUICKLY THAT IT WASN'T
BECOMING A MAKE EVACUATION AND
INITIALLY TOLD US NO WE'RE NOT
GONNA BRING PEOPLE OF FAIR
GROUNDS.
AND WITHOUT OVER A DAY WE HAD
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED PEOPLE AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT SEEMS THAT NOW --
THESE WILDFIRES IN THESE
EVACUATIONS ARE SO ROBUST THAT
WERE INSTANTLY EVACUATED WHICH
WE WERE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE'VE HAD
SOME CHALLENGES WITH RED CROSS
SHELTERS I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
KNOW IT WAS KIND OF MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY BUT THEY DON'T ALLOW
ANY ANIMALS -- AND IS STORY
CLIFF YOU LOOK BACK AT WHAT
HAPPENED A KATRINA -- WHILE THE
PEOPLE STAYED IN THEIR HOMES
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO LEAVE THEIR
ANIMALS.
SO IN DEL MAR AND ALSO -- IN
SONOMA WE ACTUALLY ACTIVATED TO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SHELTERS WE
HAD A RED CROSS SHELTER.
THAT HAD PEOPLE WITHOUT A
ANIMALS AND WE HAD A SHELTER
THAT ALLOW PEOPLE TO COME IN
WITH THEIR DOGS AND THEIR CATS
AND OF COURSE WE SEPARATED --
YOU KNOW HE ANY ANIMALS THERE
MIGHT HAVE BEEN DANGEROUS WE
KEPT AWAY AND WE HANDLED THAT.
SO -- IT'S SOMETHING THAT RED
CROSS IS VERY STRICT ABOUT BUT
WE'VE ALWAYS FELT WERE OPENING
UP AND TAKING THESE PEOPLE AND
WE DON'T WANT EVAN CARS IN THE
PARKING LOT.
WE DON'T WANT HIM INTENSE WE
WANT TO MAKE IN IN THE BUILDING
SO THEY CAN HAVE THE SERVICES --
FAIRS DO NEEDED NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE'S A LOT OF
SUPPORT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT THE FUNDING THAT WAS
CUT FROM FAIRS.
AND YOU KNOW THAT'S MADE AN
IMPACT BUT WE REALLY NEED TO
LOOK AT NEW NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
TO HELP FAIRS -- AIR
CONDITIONING SYSTEMS RESTROOM
IMPROVEMENTS A ROBUST WIFI --
BROADBAND I'M ACTUALLY WORKING
WITH -- JOYS STERLING WHO'S ON
THE CDFA BOARD ON A FEW NO JOY --
TO GET BROADBAND OPENED UP AT
THE CINEMA COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS
AND THEN WORK ON OTHER
FAIRGROUNDS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SO -- MIGHT I KNOW THAT -- CDFA
IS WORKING ON THAT STRONGLY --
UTILITY IMPROVEMENTS -- MANY
FAIRS HAVE DIFFICULTY WITH THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT COME ON
SITES AND AND THE SEWER SYSTEM
IN THE WATER SYSTEMS --
FORTUNATELY FOR US AND I KNOW
UNTIL MORE THAN YOU KNOW THAT'S
NOT A PROBLEM THERE ARE SOME
FAIRS.
PAVING OF DIRT PARKING LOTS LOTS
AFFAIRS HAVE DIRT PARKING LOTS
WE COULD YOU KNOW HELLO A SYSTEM
THAT ALLOWED FOR US SPENDING FOR
LIGHT TOWERS AND GENERATORS
WOULD BE GREAT -- SATELLITE
CONNECTIVITY SEVENTY ONESELF OUR
CELL TOWERS WERE BURNED IN THE
CINEMA AND NAPA FIRE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SO YOU
CAN IMAGINE THE IMPACT FROM THAT
AS WE ALL LIVE WITH OUR CELL
PHONES.
EVACUATION SLIDE SUCH A SUPPLIES
WOULD BE GREAT ON THE
FAIRGROUNDS TO TO STAGE THOSE
CARDS COME FOR KIDS BLANKETS
PILLOWS -- WE ARE FORTUNATE IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN RED CROSS
WAS ABLE TO BRING SOME OF THESE
ITEMS AND QUICKLY.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY HAD.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO OPEN UP EVERYTHING THAT WAS
NEEDED AGAIN SOME ISSUES THERE --
ANIMALS FEEDING AND BETTING
WEEKLY RECORDED WITH A LOCAL
FEED STORE -- FOR FUNDING AND
WHEN PEOPLE CALLING ABOUT
DONATIONS WE HAD TO THE FUNDING
GO THERE -- BUT IT WOULD BE
GREAT TO HAVE SOME FUNDING
THROUGH THE STATE THAT'S
EARMARKED TO GET THIS MONEY SO
THAT THESE FAIRS CAN ACTUALLY
BUY THESE THESE ITEMS.
BUCKETS HOSES RAKES WHEEL
BARRELS VETERINARY SUPPLIES ALL
OF THOSE ARE REALLY
INTERCULTURAL -- TO THE
OPERATION -- SO FUNDING THAT
BECAUSE IT MECHANISM THROUGH THE
STATE -- TO ALLOW FAIRS TO
PURCHASE.
THESE ITEMS WOULD BE IT WOULD BE
A VERY KEY -- ADDITION TO HELP
FAIRS EFFECTIVELY WORK ON THE
EVACUATIONS.
AND THEN ABILITY TO GET
REIMBURSED QUICKLY FOR
EVACUATION SUPPLIES THAT THEY
DID HAVE TO SPEND.
WANTED TO SPEND A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT FEMA -- WE WERE I THINK
THE FIRST FAIRS IN THE STATE TO
BRING AND FEMA TRAILERS AFTER
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE HAD A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY OUR HAD NO
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH HIM IN
THAT REGARD HOWEVER -- THROUGH
THIS A FOUND OUT TO THERE'S LOTS
OF CHALLENGES WHEN FEMA.
GETS INDIVIDUALS INTO THOSE
TRAILERS.
THEY CAN REPLICATE THEIR RIGHTS
BUT IF THE IF THE PERSON DOESN'T
LEAVE THEY HAVE NO ENFORCEMENT
ARM A GOES TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WHICH IS A GIGANTIC BIG
BLACK HOLE -- AND WE ARE NOW I'M
ACTUALLY GOING TO COURT TOMORROW
TO TRAIN INVICTA FEMA --
INDIVIDUAL THAT WAS REPLICATED
MONTHS AND MONTHS AND MONTHS AGO
WHO JUST WON'T LEAVE.
SO THAT BECOMES A COST AND
EXPENSE TO THE FAIRGROUNDS AND
FEMA HAS REALLY NO ABILITY TO DO
MUCH ABOUT THAT THEY DON'T DO
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
ON AB THAT GOES INTO THAT -- AND
I HAD A COMMENT OR A
CONVERSATION WITH -- THEIR
TOURNEY ASKING THEM WHY THEY
DIDN'T DO THAT AND THEY SAID
IT'S BECAUSE WE WANT TO PROTECT
THE PRIVACY AND THE RIGHTS OF
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN
THERE THE PROBLEM IS THAT THEY
PROTECTING THE BAD PEOPLE AS
WELL -- WE'VE HAD DRUG DRUG
DEALERS OVERDOSES PROSTITUTION --
WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOMELESS -- IT WAS SURPRISING TO
ME THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT I
KNOW FRIENDS AND FAMILY NOT
FAMILY BUT FRIENDS THAT LOST
THEIR HOME IN THE FIRES.
THAT WENT DOWN TO APPLY FOR FEMA
UPS A SUPPORT AND WHEN THEY GOT
DOWN THERE SOMEBODY ELSE AT ALL
WE'RE ALREADY APPLIED FOR THEIR
HOME.
SO LOTS OF FRAUD HAPPENING AND
THE VETTING SYSTEM IS IS NEEDS
WORKS -- LOTS OF STORIES WITH
THAT -- SORT OF IN CLOSING
ACCOUNT WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
AYE OUR PREVIOUS -- SPEAKERS
TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW THE FARES
HELLO YES I THINK THERE REALLY
NEEDS TO BE.
A BETTER COORDINATION BETWEEN --
YES AND FAIRS AND MAYBE THERE'S
A LADY I GUESS ON POSITION AT
CDFA THAT COULD HELP WITH THAT.
I THINK THAT WOULD REALLY BE --
IMPORTANT BECAUSE DURING THOSE
EVACUATIONS THEY COME IN ALL OF
A SUDDEN -- YES NEED SOMETHING
WE'VE GOT CAL FIRE YEAH AND
EVERYBODY'S TRYING TO JOCKEY TO
GET WHAT THEY NEED.
IF THERE IS A BETTER
COORDINATION AND LIAISON WITH
THAT THAT WE WORKED IN ADVANCE
OF THAT I THINK IT WOULD MAKE A
BIG DIFFERENCE.
SO I'M GOING TO PASS IT ON HERE
TO MY LIFE FORMER FOR OTHER
MANAGERS AND TO BE OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS LATER THANK YOU IS
MORE.
THANK YOU I'M I'M CURRENTLY MORE
AND I'M CURRENTLY THE DEPUTY
GENERAL MANAGER AT THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS -- BUT I'M REALLY
HERE TO SPEAK TO YOU ON TWO
COMPONENTS BECAUSE FORMALLY I
WAS THE CEO AT THE NAPA COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS WHICH IS IN
CALISTOGA.
I WE GET REFERRED TO AS NAPA
OFTEN -- BECAUSE THIS DISORDER
THAT WAY -- BUT IT'S REALLY THE
THE SMALLER FAIRGROUNDS UP IN
CALISTOGA -- BEFORE I REALLY
SPEAK ON MY POINTS I JUST WANT
TO KIND OF REITERATE BUT BACK HE
WAS STATING ABOUT WHAT HOW
INTEGRATED WE ARE I THINK THAT'S
PART OF WHAT REALLY GOES ON THE
SONG ABOUT THIS INDUSTRY IS HOW
INTEGRATED WE ARE WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
IN OUR PARTICULAR SITUATION IN
CALISTOGA IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN IN RESPONSE TO THE
VALLEY FIRES THE FIRST PHONE
CALL THAT I RECEIVED WAS
ACTUALLY FROM BACKING AND HER
TEAM IN SAN DIEGO.
SAYS AND THE QUESTION WAS WHAT
DO YOU NEED.
DO YOU NEED PEOPLE DO YOU NEED
RESOURCES DO YOU NEED MONEY DO
YOU NEED EQUIPMENT AND THEY WERE
ON A PLANE.
I THINK THAT SAME DAY MAYBE
THAT'S LATE IS THE NEXT MORNING --
TO COME IN TO HELP AND SO PART
OF IT IS THIS NETWORK THAT WE
HAVE IS AN INDUSTRY.
ALONG WITH OUR OTHER INDUSTRY
PARTNERS WHICH IS REALLY HOW WE
WERE SUCCESSFUL -- IN CALISTOGA.
SO -- I ALSO IN THOSE TWO
CAPACITIES REPRESENT TWO OF THE
COMPONENTS -- THERE'S ONE SMALL
IN THE CITRUS FAIRS OF THE
INDUSTRY AND THAT IS --
CALISTOGA IS A COUNTY OWNED
FACILITY NAPA COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS
IS -- SO IT'S A LOCALLY OWNED
WHEREAS THE DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS
IS IT JUST IS THE TWENTY SECOND
DISTRICT ASSOCIATION.
AND BUT BOTH OF THOSE ALL OF THE
FACILITIES REALLY WERE KIND OF
FOUNDED AROUND THE THIRTIES --
AND WITH THEIR IF THE FACILITIES
BUILT OUT THROUGHOUT THE FIFTIES
AND SIXTIES HERE WE ARE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN AND WE
STILL HAVE MANY OF THOSE SAME.
BUILDINGS AND STRUCTURES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT -- AND THAT WAS
REALLY DONE THROUGH COURSE
RAISING FUNDING SO PART OF WHAT
I ALSO WANT TO JUST IMPRESS UPON
YOU IS THE REALLY.
OUR APPROACH AS AN INDUSTRY HAS
ALWAYS BEEN WEARING INDUSTRY WE
ARE THE CALIFORNIA NETWORK OF
FAIR GROUNDS IT REGARDLESS OF
WHAT OUR GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE IS
AND WHO OWNS THIS AND THOSE
RULES ARE ASIDE ESPECIALLY WHEN
E'RE UTILIZED IN THE CASE OF
EMERGENCY RESPONSE -- FOR KIND
OF FOLLOWING UP ON SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT -- KEVIN MASSA HER
AND MITCH.
MEDIC OF THAT I HOPE I
PRONOUNCED THAT CLOSE -- JUST TO
THANK THEM FOR THEIR ONGOING
SUPPORT -- BUT ALSO I WANTED TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF THE
BACKGROUND OR UNDERSTANDING OF
OF FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE OF THE
FAIRGROUNDS -- THROUGH
THROUGHOUT THE FUNDING FOR FAIR
GROUNDS.
ESPECIALLY IN MORE RECENT
DECADES EVEN THE LARGER FAIR
GROUNDS -- THE DELL MARS -- THE
AND ORANGE COUNTY IS AND SO ON
RECEIVE A SMALLER PORTION OF THE
FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN AVAILABLE
TO THE INDUSTRY LARGER PORTION
GOING TO THE SMALLER FAIRS ARE
MORE RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND PART OF THE IDEA BEHIND THAT
IS THAT AS HE'S LARGER
FAIRGROUNDS THERE'S MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO IN ESSENCE
GENERATE THE FUNDING NECESSARY
TO PUT BACK INTO THE FACILITIES.
BUT AS TIMES HAVE CHANGED -- AND
REGULATIONS OF CHANGE AND THINGS
LIKE THAT EVEN THAT IS GETTING
CHALLENGING FOR SOME OF OUR
LARGER FACILITIES.
AS JUST AS AN EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW
IN DEL MAR AND WE HAVE A FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT -- THAT
WERE ABOUT HALF WAY THROUGH THAT.
FOR LACK OF GETTING TO
SCIENTIFIC IS BUILDING AN
ULTRAVIOLET AND BIO FILTRATION
SYSTEM SO THAT WE CAN PROCESS
OUR STORM WATER.
NOT JUST CHARGE IT -- INTO THE
RIVERS ARE THE OCEANS ANYMORE
AND THAT SO WE CAN STAY IN THE
BUSINESS OF HORSE RACING HORSE
SHOWS AND LIVESTOCK SHOWS.
THAT THERE'S NOT REALLY REVENUE
GENERATOR FOR FOR STORM WATER AS
AS YOU WELL KNOW SO.
AND THEN FOR THE SMALLER
FAIRGROUNDS -- FROM KIND OF THE
MID NINETEEN NINETIES TO TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THEY RECEIVED ON
AVERAGE ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS.
SO YOU REALLY HAVE THIS THIRTY
FORTY FIFTY YEAR GAP OF THAT
TYPE OF FUNDING AND THEN I'M
SURE AS YOU KNOW A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS DOES NOT GO A
LONG WAY WHEN IT COMES TO SEWER
SYSTEMS.
RUSLAN BUILDINGS HVAC SYSTEMS
AND SO ON BUT IT WAS LEAST WAS
BETTER THAN NOTHING.
AND THEN WE HAVE A PERIOD OF A
FEW YEARS WITH NOTHING AND SO
THAT THE FUNDING THAT WE
RECEIVED IN THE LAST FEW YEARS --
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WITH
THE VERY MUCH APPRECIATED VERY
MUCH NEEDED BUT IT'S REALLY JUST
THE TIP OF THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG FOR US.
SO -- AND UNLIKE FIRE CAMP
OPERATIONS IT WAS ALLUDED TO
EARLIER THAT AS FAIR GROUNDS WE
RECEIVE PAYMENT FOR THE USE OF
OUR FACILITIES IN THESE
EMERGENCIES NOT ENTIRELY.
YES IN A FIRE CAMP OPERATION AND
THAT'S WERE -- YES AND CAL FIRE
DO YOU PAY RENTAL FEE FOR THAT
MORE AND MORE ARE FAIR GROUNDS
ARE UTILIZES EVACUATION CENTERS
AND WHAT WE GET IS A
REIMBURSEMENT OF ACTUALLY GUNS
EXPENSES INCURRED.
WHAT WE DON'T GET IS ANY KIND OF
MAKE UP FOR THE LOSS OF REVENUE
THAT THE FAIRGROUNDS ITSELF
WHICH IS HAVE TO BE SELF
GENERATING TO SUPPORT AND PAY
FOR ITS EMPLOYEES IT'S UTILITIES --
ITS ONGOING OPERATIONS AND BE
THERE FOR COMMUNITY.
THAT'S JUST THAT'S A LOSS FOR US --
OF THE BACKYARD HE SPOKE TO DEL
MAR'S ROLE IN -- WHICH LED TO
THEIR ABILITY TO HELP US OUT SO
MUCH IN CALISTOGA SO IN
CALISTOGA IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN A LITTLE SLEEPY
CALISTOGA UP NORTH.
THERE WAS A SMALL FIRE THAT
BROKE OUT IN NAPA COUNTY WAS THE
BUT CANYON FIRE.
AND SO WE WERE ACTUALLY
ACTIVATED OUR FAIRGROUNDS IS
ACTIVATED FOR NAPA COUNTY
RESIDENTS.
WELL WHAT HAPPENED WAS THE
VALLEY FIRE HAD BROKEN THAT SAME
DAY ACTUALLY JUST A FEW HOURS
EARLIER AND SO WHEN THE SOCIAL
MEDIA WENT OUT THE EVACUATION
CENTER OPENING CALISTOGA THOSE
RESIDENTS UP ON UP ON THE
MOUNTAIN IN ESSENCE IN LAKE
COUNTY.
I MEAN IT WAS TWO LANES ON A TWO
LANE HIGHWAY I'M COMING INTO
CALISTOGA AND SO WE WENT FROM A
POPULATION OF FIVE THOUSAND IN
OUR TOWN TO A POPULATION OF
ABOUT -- SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
PRACTICALLY OVER NIGHT AND WAS
REALLY ONE OF THE MORE RECENT
FORAYS INTO THIS MASSIVE INFLUX --
AN EVACUATION CENTER --
INITIALLY THERE WERE SOME
CHALLENGES BECAUSE WHAT WAS
BEING REPORTED AS A RED CROSS
WAS ON SCENE BUT WHAT WAS BEING
REPORTED OUT WAS THAT WE HAD
TWENTY THREE PEOPLE.
IN THE EVACUATION CENTER.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THEY WERE
TWENTY THREE PEOPLE INSIDE.
BECAUSE THE OTHER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE HAD CHOSEN TO
STAY OUTSIDE IN TENTS IN CARS --
BECAUSE TO STAY WITH THEIR
ANIMALS TO STAY WITH THEIR
ENTIRE FAMILY TO STAY IN ESSENCE
WITH THEIR THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD.
SO IT WAS A LITTLE BIT DELAYED
IN GETTING SOME OF THE THE
RESOURCES IN SIMPLY BECAUSE OF
THAT -- THAT PROCESS THAT EXISTS
WITH -- WITHIN RED CROSS.
DID YOU HAVE AVAILABLE IN THE
SHELTER FOOD HOW MANY BEDS WERE
AVAILABLE IN THE SHELL -- THERE
WILL HELP FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE WERE BEING ASKED TO
LEAVE THEY WERE BEING TOLD THAT
THEY HAD TO LEAVE THEIR PETS AND
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU I
PERSONALLY HAVE NOT BEEN THROUGH
THE HAVING TO FLEE MY HOME WITH
THE CLOTHES ON MY BACK.
AND PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS IN MY LIFE OF MY PETS AND
MY CHILDREN.
AND TO HAVE A RIDE SOMEWHERE AND
BE TOLD WELL HERE FILL OUT THIS
FORM AND YOU CAN ENTER BUT YOUR
ANIMALS THE MOST NEAR AND DEAR
THINGS YOU HAVE NO IDEA IF YOU
HAVE A HOME LEFT.
IF ALL THIS FAMILY PHOTOS YOUR
HEIRLOOMS.
CLOSER TO AT WHATEVER YOU HAVE
THE MEMORIES IF THEY'RE GOING TO
BE THERE OR NOT AND WE JUST
IMAGINE THAT WAS VERY
DEVASTATING SO AS THE FAIR
GROUNDS WE STEPPED INTO THAT
ROLE.
AND WE SERVED THREE THOUSAND HOT
MEALS A DAY OUR COMMUNITY MADE
INTERNATIONAL NEWS FOR THE
HOSPITALITY THAT WE SHOW TO
THESE TO IN ESSENCE THESE
NEIGHBORING FOLKS NOT EVEN OUR
OWN COMMUNITY TECHNICALLY.
IF PEOPLE WANTED TO GET INTO
BOUNDARIES WE DIDN'T KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT WE WERE EVEN
GOING TO BE REIMBURSED ARE
COUNTY EVERYBODY'S TRYING TO
WORK OUT THE DETAILS OF THE AMMO
USE AND THINGS THAT
UNFORTUNATELY WEREN'T IN PLACE
QUITE YET.
SO IT'S REALLY QUITE THE
UNDERTAKING AND WE WEREN'T
SERVING BOLOGNA SANDWICHES AND
PEANUT BUTTER AND JELLY
SANDWICHES WE WERE SIR I CAN
ATTEST TO THAT.
I MEAN IT WAS REALLY JUST AND I
THINK IT'S KIND OF RAISE THE
AWARENESS OF JUST HOW MUCH WE
CAN REALLY HELP TAKE CARE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES IN THESE TIMES OF
NEED IT WAS JUST IT WAS VERY
EXPOUNDING THING THE AMOUNT OF
COMMITTEE SUPPORT THAT YOU SEE
COMING OUT.
AND COOKING AND HELPING AND AND
IT IS AN IMPERFECT BECAUSE OF
THIS ROLE WE PLAY WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE A TRUST WITH
THEM WE CELEBRATE THEM ALL THE
TIME WHETHER IT'S AT OUR FAIRS
OR THE OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT
TAKE PLACE ON OUR GROUNDS THE
KING THING YEAR AS THE WEDDINGS.
THE FUND RAISERS SO THERE'S
ALREADY THIS RELATIONSHIP AND
OUR COMMUNITY CAME OUT OF THE
WOODWORKS TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
COMING IN WITH A BAD.
WITH YOU TENSE AGAIN FOOD A CALL
WENT OUT THAT WE NEEDED
BATTERIES NEXT THING YOU KNOW A
DURACELL TRUCK SHOWS THAT DIDN'T
KNOW THEY HAD.
ONE SEMIS PULLING IN WITH THAT
AND THEN NOT THAT ROLE WE PLAY
IS FAIR GROUNDS WHERE WERE USED
TO MANAGING EVENTS WERE USED TO
MAINTAINING PUBLIC SAFETY
THROUGHOUT THOSE MAKING SURE
FIRE LANES STAY OPEN AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
AND SO GETTING THINGS PLACED IN
SUCH A WAY THAT WE'RE MAXIMIZING
THAT SPACE FOR ALL PARTIES IF
CAL FIRE HAD NEEDED TO COME IN
WITH A A FIRE CAMP OPERATION WE
HAD SPACE SET ASIDE FOR THEM.
THE SHELTER OPERATION WE WE WERE --
WE OPEN AS AN EVACUATION CENTER
AND THEN WE RAN AS A SHELTER FOR
FOURTEEN DAYS.
AND IT'S NOT TOLL ON OUR
FACILITIES THAT'S REALLY THAT
THE CRUX OF OF WHAT I'M HERE TO
TALK ABOUT.
BECAUSE OUR FACILITIES WEREN'T
BUILT FOR THAT YES THEY'RE BUILT
FOR INFLUXES OF LARGE PEOPLE BUT
NOT SUSTAINING THEM NECESSARILY.
AND SO AGAIN THREE ABOUT A
THOUSAND THREE TIMES A DAY ABOUT
A THOUSAND PEOPLE FOR A HOT WELL
COOKED MEAL.
WELL OVER THE COURSE OF THAT OUR
KITCHEN SEWER SYSTEM FAILED.
IT'S UNDERNEATH A CEMENT FLOOR
IT CAN'T BE REPAIRED IN THE
MIDST OF THIS SO TEMPORARY FIX
WAS PUT IN PLACE FOR IT. FOUR
YEARS LATER THAT TEMPORARY FIX
IS STILL THERE BECAUSE WHAT IT
WILL REQUIRE IS.
POTENTIALLY TEARING DOWN THE
BUILDING BUT AT LEAST TEARING UP
THE FLOOR TO GET TO THAT FIX AND
YET THAT'S A BUILDING THAT OUR
COMMUNITY ALSO RELIES ON FOR
THEIR EVENTS AND ACTIVITIES AS
WELL -- WE HAD -- WE HAD ISSUES
OF OUR SWAMP COOLERS WERE --
TURNED ON WITHOUT WATER.
SO THEY BURNT UP IT WAS ABOUT A
HUNDRED FORTUNATELY OUR COUNTY
DID PUT IN AN INSURANCE CLAIM
FOR US TO REPLACE THOSE BUT THAT
WAS ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR PROJECT TO REPLACE THAT.
SO WE DON'T NECESSARILY AND A
LOT OF OUR FACILITIES DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE PROPER
VENTILATION HEATING AND AIR
CONDITIONING IN THE COURSE OF
THOSE FOURTEEN DAYS WE WENT FROM
EXTREME HEAT TO POURING FREEZING
RAIN.
AND PEOPLE INTENSE AND IN CARS
OUTSIDE AND TRYING TO COME UP
WITH -- FACILITIES TO PUT THEM
IN -- SOME OF OUR OTHER
CHALLENGES WERE THINGS LIKE
PROPERLY FUNCTIONING GATES AND
PERIMETER FENCE LINES AND THINGS
AND AND A LOT OF FAIR GROUNDS
HAVE THIS BECAUSE AGAIN THERE'S
BEEN ONLY SO MUCH MONEY YOU'VE
GOT A SELF GENERATED TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS IN YOUR SEWER
SYSTEMS FAILING OVER HERE SO
MAYBE.
YOU DON'T GET OVER THERE TO
REPLACE THAT GATE BUT BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE THE ADEQUATE
PROTECTION AND SECURITY FOR
EVACUEES BECAUSE YOU ALSO DO YOU
WIND UP WITH A MIGRANT --
REVELERS. TO FIND OUT -- THERE'S
MEALS THERE'S CLOTHING ITEMS AND
THEY'RE JUST THEY'RE LITTLE
OPPORTUNISTIC AND SO YOU KNOW WE
WOUND UP WITH A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF HOMELESS POPULATION OR ARE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S ARE SAYING.
THEY'RE NOT HERE BECAUSE OF THE
FIRES WERE FAMILIAR WITH THEM IN
IN OTHER AREAS OF OUR OF OUR
COMMUNITY -- YOU ARE RESTROOMS
IN OUR SHOWERS THAT WE HAVE ON
HAND AND WHILE IT'S GREAT THAT
THE CALVARY IS COMING IN THESE
OTHER RESOURCES WERE DEPLOYED
SOME OF THE ISSUES WE HAVE IS
FAIR GROUNDS A GO BACK TO THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
NEW TECHNOLOGIES NEW POWER
DEMANDS ON SOME OF THOSE AND
WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN ACTUALLY
PLUG AND PLAY THAT SYSTEM IN.
THE NEED FOR WIFI FOR JUST ABOUT
EVERYTHING TO OPERATE INCLUDING
THE LAUNDRY FACILITY THAT OUR
RIGHTS.
COME IN BEING ABLE TO TO
MAINTAIN THAT AND THEN ON TOP OF
IT AGAIN -- THAT LOSS OF REVENUE
THAT WE SUFFER AS EVACUATION
CENTER AND YET LET ME BE CLEAR
WE ARE ALL HAPPY TO SERVE IN
THAT CAPACITY.
EVERYBODY THE COMMUNITY RESPONSE
PEOPLE COME OUT BUT AFTERWARDS.
AGAIN BECAUSE WE ARE SELF
GENERATING THOSE FAIR GROUNDS
ARE THEN FACED WITH MANAGING THE
FINANCIAL IMPLICATIONS THAT LOSS
OF REVENUE AND THAT COULD MEAN
BUDGET CUTS IT COULD MEAN
LAYOFFS IT'S HOW DO YOU GET
THROUGH THE HOW DO WE RECOVER
FROM THIS -- LONG TERM.
THE ONE THING THAT HAPPENED AS
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AS WELL
AS AS WE PRESS FOR MORE
INCLUSION AND ARE COUNTY -- YES
AND ACTUALLY STATE -- YES CAME
TO VISIT -- REALLY EVERYONE DID
WAS JUST SUCH A CRISIS A TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN BUT AFTERWARDS
GONNA DEBRIEFING ON AT THE
COMMENT WAS THAT WAS A ONCE IN A
LIFETIME EXPERIENCE [inaudible]
THAT.
THERE'S NO PRESIDENT BEFORE
THERE WON'T BE AGAIN WE HAVE ALL
JUST LIVED THROUGH THE MOST
INCREDIBLE LIKE FIRE AND
DEVASTATION TO HIT.
AND THEN CAME TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN AND THE ATLAS PEAK
FIRE AND THE TUBS FIRE BOTH
BROKE OUT IN NAPA COUNTY AND YOU
KNOW THE DEVASTATION THAT AS A
CARRIED ITS WAY OVER TO CINEMA
COUNTY.
WE WERE ONCE AGAIN.
AN EVACUATION CENTER THAT
ACTUALLY TRANSITION MORE INTO AN
INFORMATION CENTER AS POWER WENT
OUT AND IS THE CELL TOWERS WENT
OUT SO IN NAPA COUNTY EIGHTEEN
T. IN ESSENCE FAILED IN CINEMA
COUNTY VERIZON FAILED.
SO WE BECAME THE INFORMATION
CENTER FOR ANYBODY IN OUR
COMMUNITY COMING TO FOR ANY KIND
OF INFORMATION BECAUSE OTHERWISE.
THE THE CITY'S ICS WOULD HAVE
JUST -- I YOU SEE WOULD HAVE
INUNDATED JUST WITH PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET INFORMATION SO
THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE DO
BECAUSE AGAIN WE MANAGE THE
FENCE AND WE MANAGE -- WE MANAGE
PEOPLE.
SO THEN OF COURSE WE ALL KNOW
HAPPEN IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
I'M AND LET STEVE SPEAK TO THAT --
A LITTLE BIT MORE BECAUSE HE WAS
MOVED.
SADLY MUCH MORE INTIMATELY
INVOLVED IN THAT THEN I WAS BUT
SOMETHING ELSE TO KEEP IN MIND
IS THAT WHILE WE SPEAK A LOT
ABOUT THE WILD FIRES BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN SO MUCH OF
OUR RECENT HISTORY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE ALSO IS FAIR GROUNDS BEEN
UTILIZED IN FLOODS IN POWER
OUTAGES -- EPIDEMICS Là MANY
YEARS AGO AND THINGS LIKE THAT
AND WE CONTINUE TO SERVE IN THAT
WAY -- SO.
EVEN THOUGH I WE TEND TO TALK
ABOUT IT IS OUR FAIRGROUNDS
THERE YOU ARE FAIR GROUNDS THERE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS THEY ARE
CALIFORNIA'S FAIRGROUNDS.
NEWS HOPE THAT YOU'LL KEEP THAT
IN MIND AS YOU KNOW YOU TO
LIBERATE ON HOW BEST TO INVEST
IN ALL OF US.
THANK YOU VERYMUCH.
HI MISTER KENNY.
SO THE BUTTE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS
IS ANOTHER COUNTY.
PROPERTY -- IT IS RUN BY FIVE
ONE C. THREE NON PROFIT HAS BEEN
FOR DECADES -- THE WORLD DOESN'T
REALLY KNOW THAT JUST FOR AROUND
EVERYBODY JUST THE IN GREATLY
IT'S PROBABLY THE SOCIAL CENTER
OF THE OF THE REGION BUT OUR
SMALL TOWN OF FIVE THOUSAND
THREE AGRICULTURALLY DOMINATED --
AND THEN -- ON THE NOVEMBER
EIGHTH -- FIRE BROKE OUT AT SIX
THIRTY I THINK BY NINE THIRTY WE
GOT THE FIRST CALL THAT WE WERE
GONNA BE A LARGE ANIMAL HELTER.
AND NINE FORTY FIVE WE GOT THE
CALL WE'RE GOING TO BE
RECREATIONAL TERROR -- THE FOR
OTHER EMERGENCY SITUATION.
BUT AS YOU MENTIONED WELFARE
PEOPLE AND IT'S JUST.
IN THIS SORT OF A WAY OF JUST
ANOTHER EVENT TO ME NOT TO MAKE
IT SMALL BECAUSE IT CERTAINLY
WASN'T BUT WHERE THINGS NEED
POWER AND WATER YOU PUT THINGS
THAT.
NEED POWER AND WATER AND NOT
ROCKET SCIENCE TWO PEOPLE IN THE
FAIR INDUSTRY IT MIGHT BE IF YOU
HAD A CO IT COMPLETELY
VOLUNTEERS -- WITHIN FOR WE HAD
A SEVENTY SEVEN DAYS WE OPERATE
IS A LARGE ANIMAL SHELTER -- WE
HAVE A NEW I THINK IT'S CLOSER
TO SEVENTEEN HUNDRED BELIEVES
FIFTEEN HUNDRED ANIMALS THERE
INCLUDING TWO HUNDRED HORSES
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
WAS AN AMAZING THING SINCE WE'RE
NOT REALLY PREPARED FOR SYSTEM --
BUT I'LL TALK ABOUTTHAT IN A
SECOND -- WE HAD EVERY HORSES
MULES DONKEYS LLAMAS PIG SHEEP
GOATS TURKEYS CHICKENS DUCKS
RABBITS AND OTHERS --
FORTUNATELY -- BUTTE COUNTY
ALREADY HAS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
WAS PREPARED FOR LARGE ANIMALS
SO -- THEY WERE AN INTEGRAL PART
OF THIS BUT THEY WANT THE WHOLE
STORY -- UC DAVIS CAME
IMMEDIATELY TO THE RESCUE IN
PLAYED A BIG ROLE -- WITHIN
HOURS ARE FARMING COMMUNITY WAS
BRINGING IN EXTRA PENS WE HAD SO
MUCH FEW FOOD. FOR THESE ANIMALS
THAT AT THE END OF THAT SEVENTY
SEVEN DAYS WE WERE GIVING THE
PEOPLE OVER THERE PICKING UP
THEIR ANIMALS AN OFF THE LAST
FOR A COUPLE MORE GO BACK IS
INCREDIBLE WHAT CAME OUT -- IF
WE GET PANELS THAT CAME OUT FROM
THE STATE FAIR I MEAN IT IS.
THAT THE COMMUNITY WAS JUST A
FABULOUS THING AND THAT AND THE
LARGE ANIMAL SHELTER REALLY
SHOWED FOR THAT -- WE'LL GET TO
SOME OTHER ISSUES A DIRECT
LARGER SO CERTAIN -- THEN IN THE
HUMAN SIDE AS I SAID WE WERE
CALLED INTO PLAY IT BEFORE TEN
O'CLOCK ON ON FIRED A IN -- THE
FIRST SHELTER WAS ACTUALLY THE
GM THAT WE LEASED TO THE LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR THE HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND IT WAS JUST YOU CERTAIN
GIVEN TO THIS -- DESPITE OUR
LEASES AND ALL THAT SORT OF
STUFF WHICH WE LEARN SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT LATER -- BUT THAT WAS
HAD A CAPACITY OF TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND OR TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY PEOPLE -- ABOUT A WEEK
AND A HALF LATER DO THE ANIMALS --
THE COUNTY HAD.
SEEN ALL THE SHELTER JUST POP UP
IN A LOT OF ONE PEOPLE THAT
WOULD LEAVE THEIR PETS.
AND THEY WERE NOT MEETING ANY
SORT OF CODE -- HEALTH CODE
REQUIREMENTS SO THEY TOOK.
OVER ANOTHER ONE OF OUR
BUILDINGS AND FOR THE FIRST TIME
ACROSS ACTUALLY ATTEMPTED TO RUN.
A SMALL ANIMAL SHELTER BY
ATTEMPTED TO RUN.
THEY PRESENTED IT LIKE THEY WERE
GOING TO RUN IT BUT ACTUALLY
THEY GAVE IT DID YOU MEAN TO SAY.
SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT IN AN
AGRICULTURAL WORLD IMAGINE YOU
DO UNDERSTAND THIS THE MAIN
SOCIETY AND THEN POSSIBLY THE
NORMAL AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY ON
EXACTLY THE SAME MINDSET SO THAT
WAS REALLY INTERESTING HAVING
THOSE RIGHT NEXT TO EACH OTHER.
HE SAID THAT VERY WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- WE HAD --
A QUARANTINE FACILITY -- PUT UP
WITHIN ABOUT SEVENTY TWO HOURS
TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE TWENTY TO
THIRTY PEOPLE -- WE HAD A VERY
LARGE RV INTEND VILLAGE THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY SPREAD OUT ALL OVER
THE GROUNDS BUT WITHIN ABOUT A
DAY AND A HALF WE HAD TO GET THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT OUTTHERE.
AND PUT A MODEL ONE PLACE
BECAUSE WHAT WE ALL LEARNED
ABOUT LATER WAS THE DRUG
TRAFFICKING IN ALL THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WENT WITH THAT WERE
REALLY RAMPANT AND WE NEED.
TO PUT IN A BOX AND CAN BE A
WATCH OF WE ULTIMATELY HAD --
AND HOW YOU IDENTIFY PEOPLE
LATEST SELF IDENTIFIED IF YOU
WILL SO PEOPLE SO THIS
INTERESTING THING ABOUT RED
CROSS -- THEY DON'T ACTUALLY OWN
THE PEOPLE THERE OUTSIDE THE
GIVE THEM SERVICES BUT THEY
DON'T MANAGE THEM.
SO WHICH WAS AN APPARENT FOR A
DAY AND A HALF PROBABLY -- AND
SO THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT WERE
LIVING OUT THERE THAT ACTUALLY
PROBABLY WON'T EVEN AVAILING
THEMSELVES OF SERVICES THEY WERE
JUST THERE BECAUSE THEY WERE
HOMELESS AND TAKE.
THAT THEY COULD GET SOME BENEFIT
OUT OF IT TEHAMA A LOT OF AND
GET FREE TENTS AND BLANKETS AND
THAT SORT OF THING.
OF THERE WAS A LOT OF FREE FOOD --
BROUGHT IN WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
AND THEY WERE LIVING LARGE FOR
FOR AWHILE -- THERE WERE -- OVER
FIFTY STAFF BETWEEN RED CROSS
AND SECURITY HOUSE ON THE GROUND
IN OUR BUILDINGS -- NO IDEA HOW
MANY VOLUNTEERS BUT HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS -- PROBABLY A COUPLE
HUNDRED ON BOTH SIDES EACH ARE
OVER THE PERIOD THE HUMAN
CHARTER LASTED THIRTY DAYS AND
BASICALLY -- BECAUSE OF SOME
COMMUNITY ACTIVITIES --
PARTICULARLY WITH HIGH SCHOOL IN
THE GYM -- IT BECAME APPARENT TO
THAT IT WOULD BE BEST IF THE
THAT PART OF THE SHELTER WAS
RELOCATED TO SILVER DOLLAR.
AND SO IT IT MOVED THERE AT THAT
TIME -- WHAT WHERE WE RETAIN A
LARGE ANIMALS FOR A LONG TIME
AFTER THAT WAS ACTUALLY HANDLED
AT A PRETTY HIGH LEVEL WITH RED
CROSS WASN'T SOMETHING THAT? FOR
ROASTED -- AT THE PEAK OF USE ON
A PERCENT OF HER GROUNDS
FACILITIES WERE USED -- CARLENE
GAVE A SPEECH A FEW YEARS AGO
AND SHE SAID IF YOU EVER GET A
DISASTER MAKE SURE ON THE GROUND.
AND SO I TREATED LIKE I'M
RUNNING AT ALL AND AT THE END WE
HAD GIVEN IT ALL UP IT WAS.
QUITE AMAZING -- THIRD AT ALL
HOW MANY ACRES YOU FOR ONCE --
JUST UNDER -- FORTY THERE WERE
SOME REALLY AMAZING THINGS COME
OUT OF WITH ALLUDED TO IT BEFORE
BUT THIS NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA
FAIRS THAT WERE IN AND AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE EACH HAVE
AROUND IT AND AND EACH ONE OF US
REPRESENTS COMMUNITY IN.
TOGETHER THAT'S A VERY LARGE
COMMUNITY -- TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OUT REACH -- BOTH CDFA AND SEE
IF AS A SENSE STAFF DOWN IN THE
FIRST WEEK TO JUST HELP WITH THE
CRAZINESS OF ADMINISTRATING.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS -- AND WE
HAD THREE DIFFERENT FAIRGROUNDS
BRING DOWN SEND ON THEIR
FACILITY CREWS -- AT VARIOUS
TIMES STILL KIND OF BAYLOR OWN
LITTLE TRUE OUT FROM.
BEING GROUNDING IN IN THE NEW OR
WHATEVER ELSE IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
FROWNING AT THE TIME.
UC DAVIS AS I MENTIONED IT'S
BEEN A LOT OF HELLO TREMENDOUS
MY RESOURCES UP THERE THEY'VE
ALSO DONE QUITE A BIT OF STUDY
WORK ON THAT.
PARTICULAR PROJECT IN SHOULD
HELP WITH FUTURE DISASTERS --
EVERY SERVICE CLUB EVERY.
CHURCH GROUP EVER READ THE CITY
SERVICES.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT EVERYBODY
POURED OUT -- FROM DURHAM OR A
BILL -- BIG SCREEN LADY.
DOWN IN A LIVE OAK IT WAS A
LITTLE A LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT CAME FORWARD -- IN AND IN A
LITTLE THE ONE LAST LITTLE
AMAZING SIGHT POINT FORGET SOME
OF THE NEGATIVE STUFF -- WE HAD
GOTTEN A GRANT.
THROUGH THIS IS -- FAIR FUNDING
TO UPGRADE TO MORE WIRE --
LEXICAL SERVICES AND WE REPLACED
FIVE PANELS. FOR TRANSFORMERS IN
TWO OF THE LARGE SERVICE PANELS
I'M AND THAT WORK IT WAS
COMPLETED ON THE DAY WE OPENED A
SHELTER.
KIND OF LIKE THERE'S THERE'S
SOME BEING CONTROLLING THESE
THINGS AND I WAS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL WE WOULD NOT HAVE
ENABLE HANDLE WITH FEDERAL.
FORTIES AND FIFTIES POWER PANELS
AND AND HOME TRANSFORMERS --
SIGNIFICANT BURDENS -- PROBABLY
THE BIGGEST ONE THAT WE'RE STILL
LIVING WITH IS THE DAMAGE THAT
IS CAUSED BY -- OPERATING THE
SHELTERS AND RETAIN -- OLIVER
DIRT ROADS AND SOME OF OUR
ASPHALT ROADS SOME RAFFLE ROSE
RETURN IN THE DIRT AND ARE DIRT
ROADS ARE TURNING THE BIG HOLES --
THE GOOD NEWS IS THIS WEEK WE
STARTED REBUILDING THIS ROUTE SO
IT TOOK THAT LONG FOR THE
FUNDING TO COME BUT THEY WILL BE
BETTER THAN THEY EVER WERE SO
THAT THAT'S A THAT'S THE GOOD
NEWS -- FUNDS FOR SOME OF THESE
REPAIRS ARE REALLY SLOW AND AND
AND NOT KNOCKING A PROCESS BUT
AS A SMALL NONPROFIT WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ON SOMEBODY GIVES US
THE MONEY SO.
THERE WILL BE SOME THINGS THAT
MAY.
WAIT FOR A QUITE AWHILE TILL
SOME OF THIS FUNDING COMES IN
AND WE'LL JUST HAVE TO DO THAT --
I MENTIONED THE SEVERE DRUG
ABUSE SITUATION WE HAD IT DID
NOT SEE THAT ONE COMING --
ACTUALLY SOME OF THE VERY FIRST
PERSONS THAT WERE IN THERE THE
TENSE ARRIVE BEFORE THE ARMIES
AND THEY MOSTLY ALL PROBABLY
FELL INTO THAT CATEGORY.
ONCE WE FIGURED IT OUT -- IN
THIS WAS THEY WERE TALKING CAM
FINDING SYRINGES AT EIGHT THEY
IMMEDIATELY BROUGHT IN SHOWERS
AND RESTROOMS AND THAT SORT OF A
INTO IN THEIR PORTABLE ONCE
FEMUR RED CROSS -- YEAH I WAS IT
WAS CALLOW YES THAT RESPONDED
THAT I BELIEVE FOR THE MOST PART
AND COUNTY.
AND WITHIN TWO DAYS THEY HAD TO
DO THE FIRST DUMP RUNS TO THE
SANITATION DEPARTMNT WITH THE
WATER AND IMMEDIATELY IT WAS ALL
TREATED AS BIO PLACED.
FROM THAT POINT FORWARD AND THAT
WAS AN EYE OPENER THE WHOLE TOWN
AND REALLY WE JUST DON'T SEE
THAT SORT OF THING AND SO WE WE
GOT OUR EYES OPEN THAT DAY --
VERY LONG HOURS FOR A VERY SMALL
STAFF THERE ONLY THREE FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES AT THE FAIRGROUNDS
[inaudible]
HE HAD. FOUR FIVE MORE SEASONAL
WORKERS THAT WE BURNED OUT
WITHIN A MONTH -- THERE ARE.
THAT.
IS THE DAMAGE THAT MIGHT TAKE A
WHOLE NOTHER YEAR TO ACTUALLY
WORK THROUGH ANY START THING
ABOUT ALL THE PEOPLE THAT ALL
THE RESEARCH THAT WENT INTO
VOLUNTEERISM ALL THE FARMERS THE
BROTHELS EVERYBODY'S GOT THIS
FATIGUE.
FROM AND THAT DID THAT EXISTS --
AND AND WHILE AS A COMMUNITY WE
CELEBRATE OUR SUCCESSES ON AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT STILL
LINGERING THAT THE HAPPINESS
WEARS OFF AND YOU STILL HAVE
THAT -- FROM A FAIR NETWORK
POINT OF VIEW WHAT I THINK I'VE
GOTTEN OUT OF IT -- IS
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS WHEN
IT WERE REPEATING THIS OVER AND
OVER THAT REALLY IS THE PLACE --
WE AS AN EXAMPLE WE'RE GOING TO
THE PROCESS WE MAY END UP WITH A
FEMALE GRANT TO PUT INTO
EMERGENCY GENERATORS ON TO THE
BUILDINGS THAT I GOT A NEW POWER
PANELS.
THAT WOULD PROBABLY HAVE LESS
AND SOME OF THE BURDEN EITHER ON
THE CAPACITY OF THE OUTSIDE
PEOPLE TRAINING POWER OR IF WE
TRULY HAD.
A FOLLOW UP EMERGENCY LIKE BAD
TURN OFF THE POWER WE WOULD AND
IN THREE BE ABLE TO HANDLE IT --
BUT IT'S IT'S EVERYTHING --
POWER POWER BOXES THAT WERE USED
BY THE PEOPLE'S SLEEPING THE
TENTS IN THE RV'S.
OUR PANEL'S EVER PLACED THERE IN
THE FIFTIES I MEAN HOW SAFE CAN
AB AND IN THE RAIN THERE IS A
PRICE ON HIS GUY.
AB GIVEN ELECTRIC SLEEPING
BLANKET A SLEEPING BAG.
AND IT'S RAINING IN THE AS A
PLUGGED IN AND I'M THINKING.
TRONG WITH THIS PICTURE.
I COMMENTED TO HIM I'M NOT SURE
QUITE UNDERSTOOD.
WHILE I WAS THERE -- I THINK
ALSO AS A AS AN INDUSTRY WE'VE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THE THREE
OF US HAVE BEEN REALLY ENGAGED
IN THIS BUT THERE'S ABOUT.
THIRTY PEOPLE PROBABLY THE SAID
IN OUR INITIAL MEETINGS.
AND AND THE CITY OF A AND SAVE
US A WERE INVOLVED IN IT BUT WE
WE ARE WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A DISASTER TEAM PUT
TOGETHER -- ONE COULD RESPOND
AND SAY FOUR HOURS YOU KNOW THAT
THEIR ME A CALL SERVICE
SOMEWHERE AND WOULD HAVE A ON
INVENTORY OF ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
CAN SERVE DIFFERENT FUNCTIONS.
BECAUSE IT TOOK YOU KNOW FIVE OR
SIX DAYS TO GET THIS THING
RUNNING RIGHT BUT IF THEY WERE.
THREE CEOS AND THREE OFFICE
MANAGERS AND THREE FACILITY
MANAGERS.
IS THAT ONE WE PROBABLY COULD
HAVE DONE IT WITHIN A DAY
BECAUSE IT'S HE JUST CAN'T GET
EVERYWHERE AT ONCE -- I'M I'M
SURE ANY ANY FAIR MANAGER ANY
FACILITIES PERSON IF YOU HANNAH
MAP WHAT THE FAIRGROUNDS LOOKS
LIKE DURING A FAIR.
CAN GO AND FIGURE THIS OUT IT'S
NOT THAT HARD SO WE WE JUST NEED
THAT RESOURCE THAT WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT A STRIKE TEAM BASICALLY OF
FAIR MANAGERS OR STRAIGHT TEAM
OF STATE OFFICIALS AND IT WELL
IT WOULD BE IT WOULD.
IT WOULD BE PEOPLE THAT ARE
FAMILIAR WITH FAIRGROUND SO IT
WILL PROBABLY GO PRETTY DEEPLY
IN THE FACILITY SIDE OF THINGS --
THEY WERE GETTING TO THE CRUISE
A CAME OUT AND HELPED US I MEAN
WE HAD SOME VERY EXPERIENCED
CREWS CAME OUT FROM LARGE FAIRS.
AND YOU KNOW YOU BRING FOR
PEOPLE THAT ALTHOUGH AS MUCH AS
OUR LEAD GUY.
AND THEY GO FIND THEIR OWN
PROJECTS TO FIX AND THEY'LL HAVE
TO DO IS GIVE AN ACCOUNT AT THE
HARDWARE STORE THE STUFF IS
GETTING DONE -- THAT ALLOWED US
TO TAKE CARE SOME SAFETY ISSUES
THAT WE MIGHT STILL BE DEALING
WITH NOW IF THAT HAD COME SO --
BUT IF THEY WERE THERE FROM THE
BEGINNING THAT WE COULD MAYBE
PREVENTED SOME OF THOSE PROBLEMS
MAYBEWE COULD SET O. G. THOSE
FAR FOUR PANELS OVER THERE NEED
SOME WORK LET'S JUST.
NOT EVEN USING FOR THE NEXT
FORTY EIGHT HOURS AND FIX THEM
FIRST.
THAT KIND SORT OF THING -- AND
THEN ALSO THE RAPID ACCESS -- TO
ADDITIONAL EQUIPMENT -- RED
CROSS.
AND CALLOW YES WHEN THE TWO
DIFFERENT FORKLIFTS FOR THE
EIGHT OUR SMALL FLEET OF ANCIENT
FORKLIFTS.
AND NEITHER ROOM CAME WITH THE
WITH THE LIFT COULDRETAIN THE
ROTATING LISTS.
SO YOU CAN'T GET TRACTION ARE
BROWN'S YOU CAN'T MOVE YOU CAN'T
REALLY MOVE MUCH OF ANYTHING
WITH THOSE -- AND THE NEWEST
FORKLIFT WE OWN IS -- SEVENTY
NINE AND THAT PERISHED IN THIS
BATTLE -- WE ARE NOW ACTIVELY
SEEKING USED ONE TO REPLACE IT
AND THE OTHER TWO ARE CRIPPLED
FROM IT AND AND THAT'S THOSE ARE
DATED A OPERATING MACHINES WE
NEED ALL THE TIME.
SO COME BY A FAIR TIME IN TWO
MONTHS WE HAVE TO SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM -- BUT IT IT REALLY IS
MORE TO THE IMMEDIATE NEED OF
THE DISASTER NOT SO MUCH OF THE
FAIRGROUND THAT HAD.
HAD THERE BEEN SOMEWHERE TO
APPROPRIATE NEW FORKLIFTS
OCCURRED JUST WHOOPED IN FOR
THIRTY DAYS AND THEN GONE BACK
TO WHERE THEY LIVE EVEN IF IT
WAS RENTED BY SOMEBODY BUT THEY
HAVE TO BE SET UP TO WORK ON THE
FAIRGROUNDS WILL GO ON TURF.
BE ABLE TO GO IN THE WET IN BE
ABLE TO OPERATE THIS IS A THE
NEED -- WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
ACQUIRING A LOT OF LIVESTOCK
PANELS BUT THE NEED FOR PANELS
IS SO IMMENSE IN SUCH A SHORT
TIME.
THAT NUMBER OF COURSES
DESCENDING ON OUR PROPERTY IN
SUCH A SHORT PERIOD TIME WAS --
THE PROPERTY HANDLE THAT FIND
THAT THE EQUIPMENT WAS IN IN
SHORT SUPPLY AND AND WE ARE
DOUBLING AND TRIPLING ANIMALS
WHICH PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
FOR A DAY OR TWO UNTIL.
TRUCKLOADS CAM -- TO TAKE CARE
OF IT.
GENERATORS TRACTORS TENTS LIGHT
TOWERS ALL THE SAME SORT OF
STUFF THAT EVERYBODY WOULD NEED
IF IF IT IF IT WERE.
GIVEN TOWARD AROUND THE GROUNDS
AND WE COULD SAY WELL OF A FLAT
BED CAME UP FROM THE CENTRAL
PART OF THE STATE.
AM STOP AT THREE THREE
FAIRGROUNDS ON THE WAY UP HERE.
AND EACH HADSOME PIECE OF
EQUIPMENT MEANT FOR DISASTER
THAT WAS SAVED FOR THAT THEY
START ON THE TRUCK AND BRING IT.
INTO THE NEXT FAIRGROUNDS THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN
A REALLY GOOD THING TO PLAN --
FOR THAT WAS CARRYING HIM MY
MARK ALL.
RECORD WITH ONE MORE THING.
WHEN NEW AREA THE FAIRGROUNDS
RECENTLY HAVE GOTTEN INTO SPACE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA --
WITHOUT A LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITH
CAL FIRE WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE RECENT EVACUATION
CENTERS BUT IT WAS THE P.
JEANNIE BASE CAMPS WHICH IS
REALLY -- WORKING WITH PRIVATE
ENTERPRISE -- FOR THE SAKE OF
SOME OF THE RESPONSE --
ORIGINALLY THESE BASE CAMP
AGREEMENTS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
WERE PUT INTO PLACE FOR IN THEIR
MIND YOU KNOW AFTERWARDS FOR
THEM TO COME IN RESTORE POWER
AND THINGS LIKE THAT -- IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN AS YOU I'M
SERVE WELL AWARE PM P. JEANNIE
HAD TO CLEAR ALL OF THE THE
LINES AND SO WHAT THEY DID IS
THEY ACTIVATED MANY OF THESE
BASE CAMPS CALISTOGA WAS ONE OF
THOSE.
AND UTILIZED -- SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF OUR PROPERTY FOR
ABOUT THREE MONTHS BUT ONE THING
THAT'S INTERESTING AND DEALING
WITH PRIVATE ENTERPRISES WHEN IT
FILES FOR BANKRUPTCY.
THE FAIRS LEFT WITH AN IRA YOU.
AND THAT THAT CAL STARTED
FAIRGROUNDS IS STILL TRYING TO
COLLECT ABOUT A SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR DEBT FROM P. JEANNIE. FOR
THE USE OF THE FACILITY IN
RESPONSE TO THIS SO THAT'S I
THINK THAT'S JUST SOMETHING ELSE --
MAYBE TO PERHAPS TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION AND A LESSON FOR
ALL OF US IS HOW DID HOW WILL IT
WORK WITH THESE PUBLIC ASSETS.
AND AND PRIVATE ENTERPRISE WHEN
WE DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER YOU
KNOW.
HOW THEIR BUSINESS -- MAY GO IN
THE FUTURE.
AND RIGHT NOW UPSTAIRS AND
UTILITIES ARE HAVING A A HEARING
ON ON ON WELL.
MY U. S..
AND JUST HE RICK OF JUST GIVING
ONE SECOND.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE THE NEXT.
CHALLENGE FOR FAIRGROUNDS IS THE
PLAN WITH PGA NEED TO CUT
SERVICES CUT TRANSMISSION --
DURING A YOU KNOW EVENTS THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY BE A WILDFIRE --
WE ACTUALLY HAD EVACUATIONS LAST
YEAR WHEN THEY DID THAT AND
THEY'RE LOOKING NOW.
IN CINEMA COUNTY AT ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT
WOULD LOSE SERVICES SO.
IT'S A IN THE COUNTY LOOKED BACK
TO US SAYING YOU KNOW CAN YOU
BRING PEOPLE IN CAN YOU CAN YOU
PUT IT IN YOUR FACILITIES CAN
YOU HOUSE -- CAN YOU.
TAKE CARE OF DURING HEAT EVENTS
THAT KIND OF THING SO IT'S NOW
ANOTHER.
LAYER OF EVACUATIONS THAT'S GOOD
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO BE
COMING DOWN AND YOU'LL HAVE
BACKUP GENERATORS YEAH NO.
OKAY.
SOME OF ITS MAJOR FALLING BACK
CATEGORY OF WHERE THE POWER GET
CAT YEAH RIGHT YET THAT'S WHERE
THESE FOLKS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
COMING.
A DISTINGUISHED HERE THANK YOU
FOR GRACIOUSLY SHARING YOUR TIME.
STAFF TIME AS WELL.
RICK PICKERING COUNT YOUR
CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR NEXT
POSITION.
MY BACKGROUND IS ACTUALLY A
MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENT IN LA IN
ORANGE COUNTY BEFORE GETTING
INTO THE ORANGE COUNTY FAIR.
WHICH IS THE DA AND THEN THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY FAIR WHICH IS A
NON PROFIT ON COUNTY LAND AND
NOW YOUR STATE FAIR.
THE BACK DURING MY CITY
MANAGEMENT DAYS THE CIVIL UNREST
WHAT WAS YOUR FURNITURE RIGHT
IT'S VERY ACCURATE.
I HAD THAT EXPERIENCE AS WELL AS
EL NINO AND ONE MEDIA AND THE
FLOODING IN LA IN ORANGE COUNTY.
BUT HISTORICALLY.
THE STATE FAIR WAS CREATED IN
EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR IN THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF MEETING THE
BUSINESS INTERESTS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WHAT HAD JUST HAPPENED AS WE
BECAME INCORPORATED AFTER THE
GOLD RUSH OUR POPULATION TRIPLED.
IN ONE YEAR.
PEOPLE LEFT THE FARMS A LEFT THE
RANCH IS THE STATE LOOKED AROUND
AND SAID OH MY GOODNESS.
I DON'T THINK THESE RESULTS
TERMS THEY SAID WE HAVE TO FEED
ALL THESE PEOPLE THAT HAVE NOW
COME HERE.
THE STATE HAD A CRISIS THAT HAD
EMERGENCY OF PEOPLE COMING FOR
GOLD BUT THEY LEFT THE FARMS AND
THEY LEFT THE RANCHES THEY
ABANDONED THE SHIPS IN THE
HARBOR IN SAN FRANCISCO.
SO THE THE MERCHANDISE ITEMS
YEAH THE PHONE JUST SEEN THE
PICTURES OF THAT -- BUT NOW WE
DIDN'T HAVE FOOD.
AND FOOD.
PRICES JUST SKYROCKETED SO THE
STATE LOOKED AROUND IN EIGHTEEN
FIFTY FOUR THEY CREATED THE
STATE FAIRGROUNDS AND THE FIRST
STATE FAIRGROUNDS YOU KNOW IS
CAPITAL PARK.
SO YOU CAN WALK TO THE
HISTORICAL PARTS OF THIS
BUILDING AND SEE THE OLD CAPITOL
PARK.
ON AND THEN THE STATE SAID SO WE
WANT THE STATE FAIR TO BE THE
PINNACLE OF ANIMAL HUSBANDRY AND
PRODUCTION TECHNOLOGY. TO
PERPETUATE THE BUSINESS INTEREST
TO THE PEACE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT EMERGENCY AT
THAT POINT IN TIME WAS FEEDING
PEOPLE.
THE STATE THEN LOOKED AROUND AND
SAID HOW DO WE TAKE THIS
KNOWLEDGE AND SPREAD IT ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE WE'VE SET UP
THIS NETWORK OF COUNTIES.
LET'S CREATE FIFTY FOUR DISTRICT
AGAS SO SHE HINS SMALL STATE
AGENCIES.
PLACED ONE IN EACH COUNTY
ADDITIONALLY IT'S MORPHED OVER
TIME AND THEN.
WE CAN START GETTING PEOPLE BACK
IN THE FARMING BACK AND ANIMAL
PRODUCTION BACK INTO FEEDING.
LOCALLY AND THEY DID THAT TO
THIS CONCEPT OF COOPERATION AND
EDUCATION BUT IT WAS ALSO.
COMPETITION AND THEN YOU SHARE
THE RESULTS OF YOUR COMPETITION
AND THE PEOPLE WANNA EMULATE
THAT SUCCESS SO AS YOU TALK TO
THE FAIRS THAT HAVE ACTUALLY.
BEEN PROVIDING THIS LEVEL OF
DISASTER SERVICES WE'VE LEARNED
A LOT FROM EACH OTHER -- WE'VE
SHARED IDEAS WE SHARE DOCUMENTS
WITH -- YES AND CERTAINLY WITH
APART THE FOOD AGRICULTURE.
BUT BUT TAKING THAT CONCEPT OF
WHERE WE ORIGINALLY CAME FROM.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE WE FOUND
OURSELVES AGAIN AND JUST.
IN RECENT YEARS I BEING USED TO
DEAL WITH SOME OF THE MERGING
SEES THAT PREPARE FACED BY THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT THAT.
CALYX WILL BE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY THAN SOME OF THE
FAIRS YOU'VE HEARD FROM.
A WE ARE AN INDEPENDENT UNFUNDED
STATE AGENCIES SO WE'RE NOT
TUCKED UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AGRICULTURE.
WE SET OUT HERE AS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION -- AND AND
BECAUSE OF THAT WE ALSO HAVE A
DIFFERENT WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH -- YES AND FOOD NAG VERY
POSITIVE RELATIONSHIPS -- SO --
YES IS OPEN THIS UP SEVERAL
TIMES IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
THE OROVILLE DAM INCIDENT WE
WERE IN MEDIATIVE ACTUATION SITE
BASED ON HOW WATER WOULD COULD
HAVE POTENTIALLY PHONE -- FOR
ANIMALS FOR PEOPLE.
THE FIRE SEVERAL DIFFERENT FIRES --
THAT THERE'S OTHER THINGS WE GET
OPENED UP FOR THAT.
THE GENERAL PUBLIC DOESN'T SEE
ACROSS THE STREET FROM CAL EXPO
IS THE GOLD COUNTRY.
ACHEI NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RED
CROSS HEADQUARTERS.
SO WHEN THEY HAVE HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE FLOODING INTO CALIFORNIA
FLYING INTO THE AIRPORT DRIVING
IN AS VOLUNTEERS WERE THEY KEEP
THEM WHERE THEY STAGE A MULTI
STAGE ONLY COUNT LIKE SPOT.
SO WE CAN PICK UP FOR FIVE
HUNDRED RED CROSS VOLUNTEERS IN
A MATTER OF A DAY OR TWO AND
THEY'RE ALL WONDERFUL PEOPLE
LEAVING THEIR THEIR LIFE BEHIND
ON HOLD IN THE MIDWEST AND
COMING TO HELP US IN CALIFORNIA --
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A PLACE
WHERE THEY CAN BE FED AND THEY
CAN BE REDEPLOYED -- EIGHT
COMPUTERS.
WIFI ACCESS AT SUTTER SUBTLY --
YES HAS WORKED WITH US AND AND
PERHAPS DIFFERENT WAYS -- FOR
EXAMPLE ON ON ONE DAY DURING THE
OROVILLE DAM INCIDENT WE
DISTRIBUTED SIXTEEN THOUSAND
LUNCHES.
ANOTHER WORDS A COLLECTION HUB
AND THEN A REDISTRIBUTION OUT TO
TWO OTHER FAIRS -- WE TALKED
ABOUT THE CONCEPT OF LOANING
EQUIPMENT OUT OR SENDING A LARGE
ANIMAL PANELS A COUPLE
TRUCKLOADS UP.
UP NORTH.
DURING ONE OF THE FAIRS ONE OF
THE FIRES WE TOOK ONE OF OUR
BACKUP RADIO SYSTEMS.
AND DROVE IT UP TO CALAVERAS
COUNTY AND SET UP AN ENTIRE
RADIO NETWORK COMMUNICATION
BECAUSE CELL TOWERS WERE GONE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT COULD TALK THE
FAIR PEOPLE COULDN'T TALK
BECAUSE THEY TYPICALLY AFFAIR
WILL RUN A RADIO SYSTEM DURING A
FAIR.
AS SO THOSE TYPES OF THINGS
FAIRS FAIR.
SO SO WE LOOK AT THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS.
AND THEN WE LOOK AT CAL EXPO AND
IT'S AN PART OF ITS IN THAT
CONCEPT IN TWENTY TEN STUDY THAT
YOU HAVE HERE.
BUT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
DETERMINED CAL EXPO IS THE
NATIONAL PHARMACEUTICAL
STOCKPILE FOR ALL OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THE EVENT OF A
PANDEMIC.
SO WHAT WOULD THEY EXPLAIN IT TO
US OF THE ZOMBIE APOCALYPSE
HAPPENS THEY WILL FRIENDS OFF
CAL EXPO.
AND ALL THE HOSPITALS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE
THEIR SUPPLIES FROM THAT FEDERAL
PHARMACEUTICAL STOCKPILE -- THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY
TO THE SENATE IN THE ASSEMBLY
HAS DESIGNATED CAL EXPO NOW AS A
FALL BACK CD GOVERNMENT. FOR
CONTINUITY PURPOSES SO THE
CAPITAL HAS EMERGENCY EVACUATION
HALF THE MEMBERS AND STAFF
ADMINISTRATION GO TO HIGHWAY
PATROL HEADQUARTERS HALF GO TO
CAL EXPO.
SO BECAUSE OF THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED A FAIR AMOUNT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY FUNDS TO THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICE THAT
HAS ALLOWED US TO ENHANCE OUR
OUR WIFI IS SUPER SPEED NOW.
BECAUSE ALL EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM MORE LIKELY MIGHT GO TO
CALYX WILL WITH THE COMPUTER OR
PHONE INDEED TO CONDUCT THE
STATE'S BUSINESS.
SO A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THERE --
CALYX WILL ALSO HAS SOME OF ITS
OWN POWER GENERATION ABILITY HAS
A ONE MEGAWATT PHOTOVOLTAIC
PROJECT THAT'S BEEN AROUND A
LONG TIME.
AND WE'VE BEEN NEGOTIATING WITH
OUR LOCAL UTILITY COMPANY AND
TGS FOR POTENTIAL FIFTEEN
MEGAWATT SYSTEM THAT WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE DEEP BATTERY STORAGE.
SO NOT ONLY COULD WE PRODUCE IT
BUT WE CAN BECOME IN ESSENCE A
MIKE REGRETTED AS AS A FALL BACK
SEE THE GOVERNMENT FOR THE STATE
SO THOSE TYPES OF NEGOTIATIONS.
I CONTINUE TO TAKE PLACE.
CALLASPO BY STATUE ALSO HAS ITS
OWN POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THOSE POLICE OFFICERS ARE WITH
US PART TIME FULL TIME SEASONAL
WE HAVE OUR OWN JAIL FACILITIES
ARE OFFICERS ACTUALLY HAVE
STATEWIDE POLICING AUTHORITY.
SO WE DO ASSIST OF THE COUNTY
THE CITY THE PARK RANGERS AT
CENTER ON CERTAIN ENFORCEMENT
AND WE ARE PART OF THE CIVIL
UNREST PLAN FOR THE SACRAMENTO
REGION IN FACT WE'VE MOST
RECENTLY WERE.
CALLED UPON BY THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO TO SUPPORT THEM WITH
SOME OF THEIR CIVIL UNREST -- SO
THEY ACTUALLY USE CAL EXPOSE THE
STAGING LOCATION FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE AT THE MALL.
AND AND A LOT OF THOSE TYPES OF
DETAILS ON CALLASPO'S DESIGNATED
BY SAM CISCO BAY AREA AS A KEY
TSUNAMI RECOVERY FACILITY YOU
MENTIONED THE FLOODING A LITTLE
BIT EARLIER.
HOW FAR WOULD THE TSUNAMI WAVE
COME THROUGH THE BAY AREA TO
FAIRFIELD IT'S ULTRA THEY
BELIEVE CAL EXPO IS FAR ENOUGH
AN ELEVATED SLIGHTLY HIGH ENOUGH --
THAT WE'D BE A KEY FACILITY IN
THE EVENT OF A TSUNAMI IN THE
BAY AREA -- CALYX WILL LIKE
OTHER FAIRS HAS QUITE A WORKED
WITH FEMA TO ESTABLISH FEMA
TRAILERS FOR HOUSING OF OF SOME
OF THE FAMILIES.
AND WE'VE.
WHILE THE RELATIONSHIP INITIALLY
IS VERY POSITIVE WITH FEMA ONCE
THEY'RE DONE THEY LEAVE.
AND THEN.
EVERYTHING IS LEFT BEHIND.
AT THE THE CONCEPT OF RED CROSS
WONDERFUL VOLUNTEERS TRAIN SITE
MANAGERS IN MANY CASES BUT THEY
ROTATE BECAUSE OF THE LENGTH OF
THE CRISIS ON THE COMING FROM
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
YOU MAY HAVE A OUTSTANDING
SHELTER MANAGER FOR A DAY OR TWO
AND THEN THE NEXT DAY YOU'RE
STARTING FROM SCRATCH.
THIS FROM SCRATCH MEANING HERE'S
THE RESTROOM HERE'S THE SIGNED
AGREEMENT.
THERE'S ALSO NO INSURANCE THAT
COMES WITH A DEAL WITH RED CROSS.
IN FACT IT SAYS THEY'RE NOT
INSURANCE INSURING YOU.
IN OUR CASE -- WITH RED CROSS WE
RENTED THE SAME ISSUES WITH A
SMALL ANIMALS AND LARGE ANIMALS
THAT'S NOT.
IN THEIR PURVIEW BUT BECAUSE
WE'RE AN INDEPENDENT STATE
AGENCY WE WERE ABLE TO GET THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
INVOLVED IMMEDIATELY AND CAL --
YES LEGAL COUNSEL INVOLVED AND
CAME UP WITH SOME LIGHT CAME UP
WITH SOME INSURANCE DOCUMENTS SO
THAT IF YOU SIGN THE DOCUMENT
YOU COULD BRING YOUR PET AND BUT
IT'S BASICALLY OF YOUR PASSWORD
TO BITE SOMEBODY ELSE.
I HAVEN'T MENTIONED YET THAT.
ALL OF US.
ENSURE THE PROPERTIES AND
FACILITIES WITH NO FUNDING FROM
THE STATE.
SO IN THE CASE A CAL EXPO OF A
DOG BITE SOMEBODY IT'S CAL
EXPOSE SELF INSURED BY.
THE POLICY CALLASPO'S PAID FOR
ON ITS OWN.
SO THERE IS NO INSURANCE FOR
THESE FAIRS SO WHEN SOMETHING
HAPPENS WE GET SUED. FOR EXAMPLE
OF A SHELTER OPENS UP AND AND
LOCAL HOMELESS COME IN.
A RED ROSS IS VERY CLEAR THEY
THEY WILL NOT PICK AND CHOOSE.
YA COME WHICH IS GREAT BUT ONE
RED CROSS LEAVES WHATEVER IS
LEFT IS LEFT.
SO THEN AS A STATE AGENCY ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS WE'VE BEEN
LEFT WITH HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
THAT ARE NOW HOURS.
UNTIL WE CAN WORK WITH THE LOCAL
COUNTY THE LOCAL CITY LOCAL
SOCIAL SERVICES AND TRY TO
ASSIST THOSE.
AND YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT WHEN A
HOMELESS PERSON GOT INTO THE
SHELTER NEXT TO A FAMILY.
THE FAMILY.
IS ALREADY GOING THROUGH DRESS
AND STRESS AND NOW THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THAT PERSON WHO'S
JUST NOT QUITE.
WHAT THEY'RE USED TO IN THEIR
FAMILY ENVIRONMENT AND THEIR
KIDS ARE PANICKED TO PETS ARE
PANICKED -- THE THE THE RED
CROSS WORKERS ARE.
ALL YOU GUYS DEAL WITH THAT.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THEIR SKILL
SET THEIR WONDERFULLY
WONDERFULLY BIG HEARTED PEOPLE --
FROM CAL EXPOSE POINT OF VIEW.
WE DECIDED THAT BECAUSE WE'RE AN
INDEPENDENT STATE AGENCY
ALTHOUGH WE HAD ASKED EDS AND
OTHER AGENCIES TO DO A
INFRASTRUCTURE FACILITY A SMALL
CESSNA THEY SAID.
YOU'RE NOT PART OF US A SO WE
HIRED ZERO WEST ZERO WEST CAME
IN THIRD PARTY COMPANY APPROVED
BY A D. G. S. DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AGRICULTURE.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN THEY DIDN'T
INFRASTRUCTURE FACILITY
ASSESSMENT AND DETERMINED A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OF INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
TO PREPARE CAL EXPO FOR THE NEXT
FIFTY YEARS.
SO THAT'S POWER WATER SEWER A
LOT OF THAT TYPE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S ALSO CHANGES
AND SEISMIC STANDARDS ENERGY
REQUIREMENTS A NUMBER OF OF
OTHER THINGS THAT WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO BUT WHEN YEAR.
YOUR WERE AS GOVERNOR BROWN SAID
IF WE DON'T FIX THE ROOF WE
REALLY DON'T CARE WHAT THE WALLS
LOOK LIKE.
SO SO THAT'S THE TYPE OF CONCEPT
THE TALENT THERE -- AS PART OF
THE STATE'S TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY STATE BUDGET AND
IT CAME FROM THE ASSEMBLY
SUBCOMMITTEE BUDGET.
SOME WOMEN COOPER AND WITH WITH
MUCH OF YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL
INSERTED FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
INTO THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BUDGET OF THE STATE FOR CALYX
BLOW.
ON AND WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
AND WE'RE GOING WE'RE GOING
RIGHT DOWN THE LIST OF PROJECTS
THAT THAT THIRD PARTY STUDY SAID
YOU NEED TO DO THESE FIRST.
AND MOST OF THOSE ARE GEARED
TOWARD EMERGENCY SERVICES.
IT TOOK THE STATE.
THIS IS NOT A CRITICISM IT'S
REALITY IT TOOK THE STATE SIX
AND A HALF MONTHS TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MOVE SIX FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO CAL EXPO.
BECAUSE WE DON'T EXIST.
IT'S IT'S BAFFLING WE WORKED
WITH WELL SOME OF THOSE A
TRANSITION TEAM TRANSITIONING OF
GOVERNOR'S OTHER BUDGET ISSUES
THAT WERE OUT THERE.
BUT THERE'S NOT A SINGLE LINE
ITEM IN THE IN THE STATE BUDGET
IN ANY DEPARTMENT FOR CALYX WELL
IN THE STATE FAIR.
SO WHILE -- YES WAS COOPERATIVE
FOOD NAG WAS COOPERATIVE
DEPARTMENT FINANCING WAS VERY
COOPERATIVE THEY ALL SCRATCH
THEIR HEADS AND SAID.
I GUESS THE ONLY WAY WE CAN DO
THIS IS TO WRITE A FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR CHECK TO CAL EXPO
AS A VENDOR TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO.
WE APPRECIATE THE CREATIVITY
THAT GOT THERE.
BUT WHEN WE ASKED THE QUESTION
IS IF THIS BODY WANTED TO MOVE
SOME FINANCES TO CAL EXPO THE
ANSWERS YOU DON'T EXIST THERE'S
NOT A SINGLE LINE ITEM WE CAN
PUT IT.
THAT EXIST SEEMS LIKE THAT THAT
COULD BE CORRECTED IN AND WE'RE
TALKING TO GOOD PEOPLE ABOUT
THAT SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
ON THAT.
IN SECRETARY ROSS FROM FROM MY
POINT OF YOU COULD NOT BE A
BETTER CHEERLEADER FOR FAIRS.
AND WHAT WE DO -- I WOULD SAY
SHE WOULD.
SAY SOMETHING SIMILAR TO YOU
IT'S THE STRUCTURE THERE'S A
STRUCTURAL CHALLENGE.
SO WHEN WE WHEN WE MEET WITH
BODIES LIKE THIS WE REMIND FOLKS
THAT.
THE INSURANCES OF THESE LANDS
AND STRUCTURES OWNED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN OUR CASE
IS PAID FOR BY OUR ABILITY TO
SELL CORN DOGS.
MY POLICE OFFICERS ARE PAID FOR
BY MY ABILITY TO SELL COTTON
CANDY.
OF THE FIVE HUNDRED EVENT DAYS A
YEAR BASICALLY GO TO ENSURE THE
PROPERTY PAY FOR THE UTILITIES.
COVER ALL THE PAYROLL ALL THE
OLD TAB.
WE'RE THE ONLY FAIR IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT PAYS PRO RATA.
SO FIGURE THAT OUT THE SERVICES
WE PROVIDE TO SUPPORT THE STATE
WERE THEN BILLED ABORTION PRO
RATA -- THE MOST RECENT BILLING
FOR THE LOAN BETWEEN THE STATE
AND PURRS -- WE RECEIVED A ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
NOTICE FROM FINANCE SAYING
HERE'S YOUR ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE YOU'RE
PART OF THAT.
PAY BACK RIGHT BUT WE DON'T
EXIST BUT YOU BILL US.
SO JUST UNIQUE THINGS LIKE THAT
ON OPERATIONAL FUNDING WHICH
WE'VE MENTIONED.
CALYX WELL AND MANY OF THESE
OTHER FAIRS GET CHARGED FEES FOR
SERVICES BY OTHER STATE AGENCIES.
SO CAL HR'S ASSISTING WITH THE
RECRUITMENT.
WE FAIRS ARE PAYING CAL HR IN MY
CASE [inaudible]
IF.
IN ALL THE FAIR SKATE OR ALL THE
DA CASES THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL'S OFFICE DOES OUR
PLANCHETS.
ISSUES A PERMIT AND MY CASE FOR
THOSE FIVE HUNDRED EVENT DAYS WE
CAN BE PULLING FOR FIVE FIRE
PERMITS PER WEEKEND.
PER PER ONE PER PROMOTER FROM
CAL FIRE AND WHILE THE GREAT TO
WORK WITH ITS TWO HUNDRED PLUS
DOLLARS AN HOUR -- AND WE
UNDERSTAND THEY NEED TO BE A FEE
FOR SERVICES TO STATE AGENCIES.
BUT THOSE OTHER STATE AGENCIES
ARE PROFOUNDLY SUPPORTED BY THE
GENERAL FUND.
SO YOU HAVE NON GENERAL FUND
SUPPORTED STATE AGENCIES PAYING
FEES TO CAL H. R.. TO IN MY CASE
OFFICE OF TECHNOLOGY.
THEY'LL COME OUT AND SAY -- WE
NEED TO TO TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR
COMPUTERS AND MAKE SURE YOU'RE
NOT DOING ANYTHING WRONG AND
HERE'S AN EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
BILL.
HI OUCH AND THEN TWO YEARS LATER
WELL YOU GUYS YOU JUST CAME UP
ON THE ROTATION AGAIN HERE'S
ANOTHER HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
BILLS FOR US TO LOOK AT YOUR
COMPUTERS.
AND WE SAY BUT YOU DON'T
PROVIDERS COMPUTERS.
IMMATURE AN INDEPENDENT STATE
AGENCY WE NEED TO BILL YOU.
AND IT I DON'T WANNA MAKE IT
SOUND LIKE.
IT ALL GLOOM AND DOOM SB
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE IS HELPFUL.
IN FACT WE HAD WORKED WITH --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY AND MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR SEVERAL
YEARS AND JUST TO GET THE POLICY
DECISION TO ALLOW PART OF THE
SALES TAX TO COME BACK TO
SUPPORT THE NETWORK AFFAIRS.
THE EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IS
THREE QUARTERS OF 1%.
SO IF YOU WERE TO TAKE THAT AND
MULTIPLY IT TIMES THE STATE'S 6%
WHAT SIX TIMES EIGHTEEN AND THAT
WOULD BE ON A LOW NUMBER.
SO SUDDENLY THE FARES ARE
GENERATING MORE THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND THIS IS SELF IDENTIFYING
SALES TAX IT WASN'T EVEN WASN'T
EVEN THE FORM THAT ACTUALLY
TRACKED IT WAS SELF IDENTIFY --
SO IT'S A GREAT INVESTMENT FOR
THE STATE AND COMPLIMENTS TO THE
FAIR MANAGERS -- THE PARTNER
FOOD AGRICULTURE THE CALIFORNIA
AFFAIRS HAVE BEEN ABLE. TO ONE
STAY IN EXISTENCE.
BUT THERE ARE THERE ARE
CHALLENGES WHEN IT COMES TO THE
THESE TYPES OF EMERGENCIES
YOU'VE HEARD A COMMON THREAD OF
VETERINARY SERVICES.
BEFORE THE COMMON THREAD OF OF
HOW TO HANDLE ANIMALS.
AND THAT THAT LITTLE LEGAL
AGREEMENT WE CAME UP WITH WE'VE
SHARED WITH PARTLY FOOD
AGRICULTURE THEY'VE SURE THAT
NOW WITH A NUMBER OF OTHER FAIRS.
TRYING TO PROTECT THE FAIR FROM
AN ANIMAL THAT HURT SOMEBODY
ELSE BECAUSE THE LAWSUIT GOES
BACK TO THE FAIR AND TO THE
FAIRS INSURANCE COVER.
COVER -- IT DOESN'T GO -- TO YES
WERE FOOD NAG SO THAT'S A COMMON
THREAD -- YES ESTABLISHES AN
OFFICIAL CAST MEMBER WHEN
THERE'S A CRISIS AND YOU HAVE TO
TRACKING NATURALLY TRACK YOUR
EXPENSES TIED TO THAT TASK
NUMBER.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT TASK
NUMBER YOU HAVE NOTHING TO CLAIM
REIMBURSEMENT.
FOR IF YOU START A COUPLE OF
DAYS AHEAD OF TIME GETTING READY.
YOU CAN'T RECOVER COST INTO THE
YOU HAVE A TASK NUMBER IN HAND.
OTHER BECAUSE OF OUR LOCATIONS
MANY TIMES WERE ASKED TO OPEN UP
OR GET READY TO OPEN UP.
AND WE WILL BE OPEN WITH PEOPLE
THERE AND NOT HAVE IT TASK
NUMBER.
NOW WITH CLEARLY UNDERSTAND IN
THE SCOPE OF CONCERNS AND
PRIORITIES DEALING WITH
POTENTIAL LOSS OF LIFE AND
PROPERTY -- YES FOOD NAG AND
EVERYONE ELSE WAS FOCUSED ON THE
CRISIS BUT IT A FAIR THAT THEN
HAS TO COME UP WITH A WAY.
TO PAY FOR THINGS.
OF WE SCRATCH OUR HEADS AND GO
AWAY I HOPE WE CAN GET
REIMBURSED ON US.
SO A NUMBER OF THE COLLECTIVE
PHONE CALLS WE'VE HAD WITH FOOD
NAG AND ALL WE ESOS.
OKAY NOW HOW DO WE HAVE TO TRACK
THIS AND HOW CAN WE SUBMIT IT TO
YOU AND HOW QUICK CAN WE GET
REIMBURSED BECAUSE OUR CASH FLOW
MAKES A WORLD.
AND PAYS THE INSURANCE PREMIUMS --
SO GOOD THINGS IN CASE THE STATE
FAIR NINETY TWO OFFICES OF THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY HAVE COME
OUT TO VISIT US.
IN THE LAST TWO YEAR FACT
SEVERAL OF YOUR MEMBERS PLAYED
SOCCER NOT TOO LONG AGO AT CAL
EXPO.
IT'S GOING TO CONGRATULATE THE
WINNING TEAM.
ALL THE TEAMS.
ONE AND TWO TO THE OFFICE.
ALMOST EVERY OFFICE STAFF MEMBER
THAT COMES OUT SAYS.
NO YOU GUYS ARE FULLY FUNDED BY
THE STATE YOUR STATE AGENCY THIS
IS STATE LAND.
AND WE START WALKING HIM THROUGH
SOME OF THE THINGS WE SHOULD
CREEK SHARED WITH YOU AND YOUR
GRACIOUSLY ALLOWED US TO TIME TO
DO THAT.
AND THEY SHAKE THEIR HEAD ANGLE
HOW ARE YOU STILL IN EXISTENCE
AND THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE WON'T
BE.
THIS MODEL FOR ALL THE FAIRS
CANNOT BE SUSTAINABLE VERY FAR
INTO THE FUTURE WITHOUT SOME
TYPE OF A FUNDING MECHANISM TO
SUPPORT HIM.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF OF MOVING
US UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
ARE MOVING A SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THERE WE REALIZE THE STATE HAS A
NUMBER OF FISCAL ITEMS TO DEAL
WITH.
AND WE'RE NOT SAYING WE'RE
BETTER THAN EDUCATION OUR ROADS
OUR PRISONS ARE ANY OF THOSE
THINGS WE'RE JUST SAYING
SUDDENLY BECAUSE WE'VE STEPPED
INTO THE SUMMER AGENCY SERVICES
ROLE -- HEY REMEMBER US TOO AND
THE FACT THAT YOU'VE GIVEN US SO
MUCH YOUR TIME TODAY THANK YOU.
WE WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT.
OKAY SO.
I'M SO COMMON THEMES.
GOD REQUEST NOT TAKING ANIMALS.
PROBLEM AS SOME KIND OF STRIKE
TEAM THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
HAVE -- TO BE ABLE TO DEPLOY AS
NEEDED.
MORE MONEY MORE MONEY.
MORE MONEY.
LOCATION OKAY.
YEAH THAT SOME MOST OF IT UP YES
I THINK SO AND AND I I THINK
ALSO -- IS I MENTIONED EARLIER
IT MAYBE THERE'S A DEDICATED
PERSON ARE SOMEWHAT DEDICATED
PERSON WITHIN CDFA THAT OVER
WOULD OVERSEE EVACUATIONS AND
COORDINATE WITH FAIRS WITH --
YES BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A
GAP THERE -- YOU KNOW CLEARLY
THERE'S A LOT OF OPERATIONAL
ISSUES AND AND I WAS VERY.
CAUTIOUS NOT TO COME IN WITH A
WHOLE LIST OF THESE THIS IS
TERRIBLE AND THIS HAPPENED TO
THIS WAS AWFUL BECAUSE A LOT OF
WONDERFUL THINGS REALLY DO
HAPPEN THOSE ACTIVATIONS -- BUT
THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES AND I
DO THINK WE NEED TO COME
TOGETHER WITH CAT YOU KNOW WITH
CALLAWAY YES AND CAL FIRE.
AND THE FAIR NETWORK AND REALLY
COME TOGETHER AS A REAL STRONG
TEA.
OKAY.
I THINK IT'S AN INDUSTRY WE HAVE --
BECAUSE WERE BOOTS ON THE GROUND
THERE'S A LOT OF THERE'S EVEN
MORE WE COULD HAVE ADDED TO THIS
THE DONATIONS THAT FLOODED IN IN
THOSE TIMES -- AND HOW HOW THAT
GETS MANAGED OR OR HASN'T BEEN
MANAGER THINGS LIKE THAT THAT WE
CAN JUST CONTRIBUTE -- IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WERE IT'S REALLY AN
OCC A COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT ALL
THAT'S TAKING PLACE -- ON ON OUR
FACILITIES IN THE QUE AND
WHETHER IT HAPPENS AT OUR
FACILITIES ARE HAPPENS AT A HIGH
SCHOOL OR CHURCH THE GETS
ENGAGED I THINK YOU WERE SEEN
SOME.
OTHER COMMONALITIES WITHIN
EVACUATIONS AS WELL OF THE
VALLEY FIRE THE NUMBER OF
DONATIONS THAT CAME INTO BECAUSE
THEY AREN'T NEW BRAND NEW AND
BRAND NEW PACKAGING -- WERE
TURNED AWAY BY RED CROSS -- IN
THE END AFTER HOSTING
APPROXIMATELY.
AVERAGE OUT ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE A NIGHT FOR FOURTEEN DAYS
AND THEN TAKING ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING THEY WANTED --
THROUGH -- YOU PS -- WE HE AND
ANOTHER ORGANIZATION THE CENTER
FOR VOLUNTEER NONPROFIT
LEADERSHIP WE'RE ABLE TO
COORDINATE WITH THEM ABOUT.
THIRTY THE BIGGEST LONGEST SEMIS
THE CALIFORNIA ALLOWS FULLY
STOCKED WITH THE DONATIONS THAT
WERE STILL LEFT ON OUR LITTLE
SEVENTY ACRE FAIR GROUNDS --
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO STORE IN
HOUSE FOR THE FUTURE NEEDS OF
LAKE COUNTY AND AND NOT FIRE SO
THEY'D SO DONATION MANAGEMENT
THE ANIMAL MANAGEMENT THE
LIVESTOCK MANAGEMENT OF IT JUST
WE'VE WITNESSED A LOT -- AS AN
INDUSTRY THAT WE'VE SHARED WITH
ONE ANOTHER AND I THINK WE'RE
READY TO SHARE THAT WITH
EVERYONE. TO WHICH WOULD YOU AND
I BECAUSE I ASKED THE THE
DEPARTMENT FOLKS WHAT WHAT WITH
THE OVER THE COUNTER WITH THE
FEAR PEOPLE SAY IS THERE BUT
THEY DO TO THE BEST OF WHAT THEY
NEED THE MOST HELP WITH.
SO I WOULD SAY.
A WHAT WE DO THE BEST IS IS IS
EVENTS.
AND OF OF DECORATION IS LIKE A
LARGE EVENT YOU'RE TAKING CARE
OF PEOPLE YOU'RE FEEDING PEOPLE.
YOU'RE TAKING CARE OF JANITORIAL
YOU'RE DOING ALL OF THE SERVICES
THAT YOU DO YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
HAVE A LARGE FAIR YOU HAVE A
LARGE IN TERMS OF THAT -- WHAT
WE HAVEN'T DONE IS HAVE PEOPLE
STAY OVERNIGHT HAVE YOU KNOW
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE STAY
OVERNIGHT AT YOUR FACILITY?
SO THAT'S DEFINITELY BEEN A A
LEARN A BIG LEARNING CURVE.
AND THEN -- THE INFRASTRUCTURE I
THINK THAT'S WHERE CHALLENGES IS
THAT REALLY IS IS IS SUPPORTING
THAT IN.
HE'S FROM FAIRGROUNDS TO
FAIRGROUNDS DEL MAR BUDGETS
EVERY YEAR FOR AT LEAST WHEN I
WAS THERE WAS A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR JUST A SPIN
ON EVACUATION SEPARATE FAIR WILL.
MOST FAIRS DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT --
REIMBURSEMENT -- WE SENT A A
BILL TO A RED CROSS FOR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A YEAR LATER
WE GOT A NOTE BACK THAT SAID
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DONATION.
SO YOU KNOW THERE'S THAT
FINANCIAL ASPECT OF IT BUT I
THINK IT YOU KNOW AS A WHOLE I
THINK WE DO AN AMAZING JOB.
OF THE FAIR NETWORK OF HAVING
THAT TEAM TO PRODUCE AND TO DO
IT PUT AN EVENT ON THIS
EVACUATION OF AT WHAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO IS IS
HAVE THE STRENGTH IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND HOW ABOUT FOR THE STATE BUT
THE STATE AGENCIES WHAT COULD
THEY DO BETTER AND WHAT DO YOU
THINK THEY DO REALLY WELL I
THINK IT'S A COORDINATION I
THINK IT'S THE UNDERSTANDING --
I KNOW THAT -- CDFA THROUGH F.
ANY REALLY TRIED OTHER BEST A
STATE CERTAINLY DURING OUR FIRES
TO STAY CONNECTED WITH ALL OF OF
OF ALL THE FAIRS -- BUT I THINK
BETTER COORDINATION AND
UNDERSTANDING.
BETWEEN -- CALLAWAY US AND CDFA
AND AFFAIRS AS TO WHAT RE REALLY
NEED BECAUSE I KNOW THERE WERE
CHALLENGES WHEN WE CALLED F. ANY
IT CDFA INSIDE CAM.
CALLOWAY US DO THIS AND THEY
WERE SO.
BOGGED DOWN BY DEALING WITH ALL
THE OTHER FAIRS YOU KNOW
RESPONSE WAS DIFFICULT TO GET
BACK NOT TO SAY THEY WERE TRYING
THEIR BEST IT'S JUST.
IT'S JUST KIND OF THE
OPERATIONAL AND STAFFING
INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK IS A
CHALLENGE -- I WOULD PART I
WOULD ECHO THAT AND SAY THAT
WOULD -- WHAT WE DO REALLY WELL
AS WE SERVE?
WE SERVE PEOPLE I MEAN THERE
WERE PUBLIC SERVANTS I'M JUST
LIKE YOU ARE AND AND WE SERVE
REALLY WELL AS AN AS AN INDUSTRY --
WE'RE IN AN INDUSTRY THAT'S A
VERY MUCH ENGAGED IN THE
BUSINESS OF READING PEOPLE AND
AND THEIR NEEDS AND THEN IT
ENDED AND ADJUSTING TO THAT --
YOU KNOW HUMAN BEHAVIORS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT AND SO WE HAVE
AN INNATE ABILITY TO QUICKLY
RESPOND TO THEIR NEEDS.
ON THE SIDE OF OF WHAT WE NEED
YES IT'S IT'S MONEY -- YOU KNOW
IT'S FUNDING FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
BUT I THINK ALSO TRAINING AND I
THINK AS FAR AS THE OTHER STATE
AGENCIES IT'S REALLY THE
FAIRGROUNDS INDUSTRY.
FALLS IN THE PRE PLANNING
EFFORTS AS WELL -- SOMETIMES
THERE'S THERE IT BECOMES
CONFUSION OR OF THE LINES IN THE
BOUNDARIES IS THIS THE DA IS
THIS ACCOUNT E. FAIRGROUNDS IS
THIS THE CITRUS FAIRGROUNDS WHO
REALLY HAS THE ULTIMATE
AUTHORITY TO ACTIVATE THAT
PARTICULAR SITE -- WHO KNOWS IT
BEST AND BESIDES US AND I THINK
THERE ARE ALSO REALLY INCREDIBLE --
TRAININGS AND STRUCTURES WITHIN
CAL WE **** AND WITHIN CAL FIRE
AND THEIR SYSTEM THAT WE USE THE
FAIRGROUNDS COULD LEARN BECOME A
PART OF THOSE TRAININGS -- ADAPT
TO SO THAT OUR SYSTEMS PLUG AND
PLAY WITH VERY WELL TOGETHER --
YOU KNOW WHEN THEY'RE SOARING
OUT DIFFERENT TERMINOLOGY WE'RE
STRUCTURED IN THAT SAME WAY.
HI I'M I WOULD BE A BROKEN
RECORD SAY ALMOST ALL THE SAME
THINGS -- BEING INCLUDED IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS GOING FORWARD --
ARE FOR GRANTED NEVER BEEN
CALLED INTO PLAY.
WE LEARNED A LOT I THINK SOME OF
THE THINGS WE EXPERIENCE MIGHT
NOT BE MIGHT BE THE RELATIVELY
UNCOMMON THING.
AND WE DON'T KNOW THE ACCESS ALL
IN COMMON US BUT BUT IF WE'RE
USES A CASE STUDY RIGHT NOW
BEFORE WE ALL FORGET WHAT
HAPPENED -- THAT WOULD PROBABLY
BE REALLY VALUABLE TO OTHER
SMALL.
RURAL FAIRS THAT DON'T
FAIRGROUNDS THAT DON'T HAVE.
DEEP POCKETS DON'T HAVE.
EXTRA PIECE OF EQUIPMENT LINE OR
WHATEVER.
IF WHAT I WOULD HOPE TO DO ONE
THING I APPLIED FOR A MOMENT WE
HAVE GOT A GRANT FOR IT YET WAS
TO ACTUALLY.
GET SOME FUNNY TO HAVE A
PROFESSIONAL EMERGENCY PLAN DONE
FOR OUR GROUNDS.
SO WE CAN TURN AROUND WITH WITH
THAT EXAMPLE IN PLACE AND THEN
SURE WITH THE INDUSTRY BECAUSE
THEY'RE PROBABLY HALF OF THE
FAIRGROUNDS THAT WOULD GO --
THERE'S SOME REALLY GOOD COMMON
SENSE STUFF TO COME OUT OF THIS
IN THE SUMMER LIKE JUST KNOWING
THE CALLING AND SAID. TWO YEARS
AGO SAYING JUST YOU KNOW --
UNDERGROUND LIKE YOU DO WITH
FEDERAL.
IF YOU IF I DIDN'T HAVE THAT
RINGING IN MY EARS WE WOULD ADD
A PROBLEM THERE AND AND THAT'S
THAT'S A PLACE WHERE I THINK WE
CAN REALLY.
SCORE SOME POINTS WITHIN THE
WITHIN THE COMMUNICATION PROCESS
IF.
IF GALLO YES WAS INVOLVED IN
THAT RECROSS WAS A MODEL THAT
AND THE ANIMAL SHELTER PEOPLE
INVOLVED AND YOU SEE DAVIS.
COME UP WITH ONE PLAN FOR ONE
PLACE AND THEN OTHERS CAN USE AS
A MODEL AND ADAPT FROM.
BOTTOM LINE WHERE EVENT PEOPLE.
FOR PUBLIC SERVICE -- WERE INTO
FOOD PREP FOOD HEALTH AND SAFETY
TOILETS EIGHTY A LOGISTICS LAY
OUT THE OVERNIGHT IS A WRINKLE
THE DRUG USE OR MENTAL MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES ARE RECALL.
THE TRAUMA COUNSELING FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING IN THAT OF LOST
EVERYTHING IS NOT A SKILL SET OF
OURS AT ALL.
OUR VETERINARY SERVICES
TYPICALLY ARE GEARED MORE TOWARD
REGULATIONS FOR COMPETITIVE
ANIMALS.
OUR VET SERVICES TYPICALLY ART
GEARED TOWARD A RESCUE ANIMAL
PER SE.
SO THOSE TYPES OF THINGS BE VERY
HELPFUL.
AND A HUGE HUGE COMPLIMENT TO
FOOD NAG N. TWO OH YES AND CAL
FIRE CLOSER DOING SO MANY THINGS
RIGHT SO WE DON'T WANT TO GIVE
THE IMPRESSION I DON'T THINK ANY
OF US WANT TO GIVE THE
IMPRESSION THAT.
THE SKY HAS FALLEN AND WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO.
I THINK MOST OF US ARE SAYING
WE'RE CONTINUING TO BUILD THIS
AIRPLANE WALLETS AND FLIGHT.
GET GOOD KNOWLEDGE.
AND NOW I JUST REAL QUICK WITH
THE WORKING WITH LOOKING AT
MENTAL HEALTH AND DRUG AND
TRAUMA AND ALL THAT.
HOW I MEAN ARE YOU WORKING WITH
THE COUNTIES WITHOUT A DOOR
VOLUNTEERS ARE WHO IS PROVIDING
THE SERVICES AND I GUESS WHAT'S
THE AVERAGE LENGTH OF STAY?
IT JUST DEPENDS.
IT REALLY DOES SO -- IN OUR IN
OUR CASE IN SNOW AS WE WORKED
WITH -- CATHOLIC CHARITIES THAT
CAME IN AND WERE VERY HELPFUL
WITH OUR OUR HOMELESS FOLKS --
IT HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE WITH OF
FOLKS THAT ARE IN THE FEMA
TRAILERS BECAUSE FAMOUS NOT
SKILLED IN THAT AREA EITHER --
SO WE HAVE WORKED THROUGH
VARIOUS AGENCIES TO TRY TO WORK
WITH SOME OF THE INDIVIDUALS --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A PARTICULAR
WHAT HAD PARTICULAR WOMAN THAT
WAS ON THE VERGE OF ALZHEIMER'S
AND STARTING TO YOU KNOW GO DOWN
THAT PATH -- SO YOU KNOW THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THOSE CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS A DEAL WITH THAT
HAVE BEEN VERY HELPFUL.
COUNTY HELPED US -- WE ARE
COUNTY FACILITY SO THE COUNTIES
HELP US WITH SOME OF THAT BUT
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT.
THAT NEED TO BE IN THIS MIX --
BECAUSE IT IT'S IT'S IT'S
PREVALENT IN EVERY SINGLE
EVACUATION.
ANY KIND OF TRAUMA IS GOING TO
BRING UP I MEAN FOR YOUR PEOPLE
RIGHT YEAH GE RIGHT AND IN THE
CASE OF CALISTOGA IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THAT PART OF
WHAT -- SO OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER I'M DISPATCH BASICALLY
OUR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
TEAM AND DISPATCHED OUR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TEAMS AND THEY
WENT THROUGH AND MET WITH.
A REPRESENTATIVE -- FOR ANY
FAMILY AND DID A QUé OF FULL
HEALTH ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE
BECAUSE IT WHAT IS IT YOU KNOW A
FEW DAYS INTO IT YOU'RE STARTING
TO SEE SOME OF THE SIGNS AND YOU
AREN'T SURE.
AND ESPECIALLY AGAIN WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE LEFT WITH NOTHING THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THE
MEDICATIONS WITH THEM EVEN.
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
ILLEGAL DRUG USERS -- BUT YOU
KNOW GETTING THEIR THEIR
MEDICATIONS TO THEM AND THE
RIGHT ONES AND YET THEY DON'T
HAVE ID.
NECESSARILY THEY HAVE NOTHING TO
SHOW -- WHO THEY ARE MAIL
SERVICE WHAT'S THE PROBLEM --
HOW ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO GET
THEIR MAIL WITHOUT AN ID THAT
SAYS THAT THEY ACTUALLY LIVE AT
THAT ADDRESS IT'S WHERE YOU KNOW
THE FRAUD AND THINGS LIKE THAT
COME INTO PLAY -- BUT I THINK --
WITHIN THE INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN --
ENGAGED IN THESE YOU KNOW
EVACUATIONS IN SHELTERS IN THAT
THE RECENT YEARS -- THERE ARE
SOME MORE INTEGRATED RESOURCES
AND IT INVOLVES EVERYTHING FROM
COMMUNITY AND NONPROFIT GROUPS
TO OUR LOCAL YOU KNOW COUNTY
SERVICES -- AND THEN AS THE
FAIRGROUNDS REALLY JUST THE HOST
OF THAT AND WORKING WITH THEM IF
FOLKS NEED TO BE MOVED AROUND
CREATING QUIET SPACE -- WE HAD
AND SOME INCIDENTS ARE YOU WE
HAD SOME AUTISTIC CHILDREN AND
AND ADULTS THAT WERE STAYING
THERE AND CREATING SPACE IS NO
SENSORY SPACE FOR THEM AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
NEWER ISSUES THAT HAVE HAVE COME
TO LIGHT THAT AGAIN I THINK JUST
OUR INCLUSION IN YOUR PRE
PLANNING EFFORTS -- TO REALLY BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT THAT AND AND
MEDICAL WE REALLY HAVEN'T TALKED
ABOUT THAT -- I KNOW IN DEL MAR
WE IT WILL WAS REALLY DAYS
BEFORE HE REALLY GOT INTO STRONG
MEDICAL TEAM AND THAT A FRIEND
THAT'S A PHARMACIST AND WE WERE.
SHE WAS LIKE WORKING WITH PEOPLE
WHO DIDN'T HAVE THEIR WHODID
HAVE THE PRESCRIPTIONS AND SAID
OKAY.
HERE'S WHAT YOUR MEDICATION IS
WE CAN WERE HERE'S WHAT WE GOT
WE GOT BETTER AFTER A WE DON'T
HAVE WHATEVER THIS IS WE CAN YOU
KNOW WORK THAT COMPOUND THAT
AROUND TO MAKE IT WORK -- IN THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FIRES AND
SONOMA -- MY PARTNER ACTUALLY IS
A PHYSICIAN AND SHE WHAT HAD
HAPPENED TO BE ON VACATION THAT
WEEK.
WORKS FOR KAISER AND CAME AND
BOTH OF US WERE IN MY OFFICE
SLIPPED MY OFFICE FOR SEVEN DAYS
BUT SHE WAS COORDINATING MEDICAL
THERE FOR ALL THE PEOPLE IN.
AND WHAT HAPPENS IN THESE
SITUATIONS IS MOST LIKELY.
THIS ROOM.
IF YOU'RE AN EVACUATION YOU
WOULDN'T GO TO AN EVACUATION
CENTER YOU HAVE FRIENDS AND
FAMILY HAVE THE MEANS TO RENT A
HOTEL ROOM OR SOMETHING.
SO THE PEOPLE THAT END IN THESE
BUT END UP IN THESE EVACUATION
SITES ARE MORE THE OF ME NO MORE
DISTRESSED FAMILIES OR THE LOWER
INCOME MORE PEOPLE WITHOUT
HAVING YOU KNOW DON'T HAVE ANY
CONNECTIONS AND AND AND THEIR
NEEDS ARE MORE.
AND MORE CHALLENGING BUT I DO
HAVE A GOOD STORY WOULD LIKE TO
END WITH SO IT WAS A COUPLE DAYS
INTO EVACUATION WE HAD ABOUT A
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN OUR LARGE
HALL.
AND PART OF THE PROBLEM I DID
TALK ABOUT -- RED CROSS QUICKLY
IS THAT THEY WON'T GIVE THE
NAMES OF ANYBODY THAT'S IN THERE
OF ACTUATION CENTER.
SO IN THE FIRST DAY WHEN THE
FIRES ARE ALL AROUND STE US
NUMBER COUNTY AND SO MANY PEOPLE
ARE REGULATED LOVE WHEN YOU'RE
CALLING US.
OUR PHONES WERE RINGING OFF THE
HOOK TRYING TO FIND PEOPLE WHO
WERE IN EVACUATION CENTER AND WE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY NAMES SO.
IT TOOK A COUPLE DAYS FOR THIS.
THIS GAL TO FIND HER MOTHER IN A
REGULATION SITE SO SHE SHOWED P
THEN SHE SAID MOM YOU KNOW
THEY'LL BE YOU KNOW HUG AND
EVERYTHING AND SHE SAID OKAY
LET'S GO WHICH SAID NO COME BACK
TOMORROW HAVING TOO MUCH FUN.
SO THERE ARE SOME POSITIVE
STORIES WITH THINGS THAT YOU
KNOW THAT HAPPENED AT THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THANK YOU FOR YEARS
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
AND OUR FINAL PANEL IS GOING TO
BE -- HOW DO WE MOVE FORWARD TO
ENSURE FAIRS CAN CONTINUE? TO BE
STRONG PARTNERS WITH LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL EMERGENCIES.
DEAR SERVICES DURING DISASTERS
AND I THINK WE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT THAT ALREADY.
MICHAEL PARKS BOARD MEMBER
FOURTH.
DISTRICT AB SNOW MY COUTY.
CONLIN CALIFORNIA FAIRS ALIGNS
FROM DIXON CLIFF MUNSON -- FROM
SISKIYOU AND KEVIN CON -- FROM
THE ROLE REPRESENTATIVE
CALIFORNIA.
WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
VERY HONORED TO BE HERE AND BE A
PART OF THIS TODAY -- CAN'T HELP
BUT EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE AND
PRIDE FOR THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
OF OUR INDUSTRY THAT HAVE GONE
BEFORE THEY'VE DONE A PHENOMENAL
JOB TACK COMMUNICATING EXACTLY
WHAT GOES ON IN THESE PROPERTIES.
AS YOU MENTION MY NAME IS MIKE
PARKS I'M WITH THE CINEMA MARIN
FAIRGROUNDS I AM A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
PROBABLY SOMETIMES A LITTLE
UNIQUE TO HAVE A BOARD MEMBER I
SPEAK IN THIS CAPACITY BUT I
HAVE A FAIR AMOUNT OF EXPERIENCE
BOTH WITH THAT FARE.
AS WELL AS IN THE FAIR INDUSTRY
MYSELF.
IT'S BEEN MY HONOR TO SERVE ON
THAT BOARD AND I I'VE HEARD A
LOT OVER.
BOTH THE ABOUT THE LAST FIVE SIX
YEARS AS OUR NATURAL DISASTERS
HAVE KIND OF RUN ROUGHSHOD OVER
THIS COUNTRY.
IS UNPRECEDENTED EVENTS.
WE HAD A WHOLE LOT OF
UNPRECEDENTED EVENTS OCCUR OVER
THE LAST SIX SEVEN YEARS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
YOU'VE HEARD -- ALL OVER THE MAP
ENCOMPASSING DIFFERENT STORIES
ON WHAT'S HAPPENED ON PROPERTIES
BIG AND SMALL -- FACILITIES THAT
HAVE -- PREPARED PLANS THAT JUST
WEREN'T BIG ENOUGH IN FACILITIES
THAT HAD NO PREPARED PLANS ARE
PROPERTY AND PETALUMA WHERE THE
SNOW MARIN FAIR BUT WE OCCUPY
SPACE IN PETALUMA.
AND WE HAD NEVER BEEN AN
EVACUATION CENTER BEFORE WE'D
ONLY BEEN A STAGING GROUNDS.
AND SO -- WHEN THE FIRES HIT ON?
SUNDAY OCTOBER EIGHTH OUR FIRST
NINTH -- WE HAD A COUPLE
EMPLOYEE SHOW UP HI JUST BECAUSE
THEY FELT LIKE IT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO TO OPEN THE GATES
AND WE BECAME ONE OF THE BIGGEST
EVACUATION CENTERS IN THE AREA.
NEXT TO THE CINEMA COUNTY FAIR
WE HAVE TAKEN A LOT OVERFLOW --
I SECURED MY FAMILY AND WENT
DOWN TO ASSIST OUR CEO -- IT
BECAME VERY APPARENT THAT THIS
WAS GOING TO BE A MASSIVE
UNDERTAKING.
WE HEAR A LOT OF THE
APPRECIATION FOR FAIRS AND ARE
ASKED YOU KNOW HOW DID YOU DO IT.
THE THE SIMPLE ANSWER IS WE WE
GO FAIR.
THAT'S IT THIS IS ACTUALLY WHAT
WE DO.
WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO
PREPARE.
AND WE NEED THESE RESOURCES WE
NEED THESE FACILITIES TO BE
UPGRADED SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO BE THIS FOR THE COMMUNITY.
WHEN WE OPENED ON OCTOBER NINTH --
WE HAD JUST GIVE YOU A LITTLE
SCOPE OF OF SIZE WE HAD A
DORMITORY WITH THREE HUNDRED
BEDS -- YES GODDESSES BEDS VERY
QUICKLY -- WE HAD -- DUE -- TO
THE VERY LARGE HEART OF A LOCAL
NURSE WHO DID NOT HAVE ANYWHERE
TO GO THAT DAY BECAUSE TWO OF
THE FOUR LOW QUERY HOSPITAL'S
READER ON FIRE OR EVACUATED.
SO SHE SHOWED UP AND STARTED TO
PUT TOGETHER A TRIAGE AREA WHICH
QUICKLY TURNED INTO.
BASICALLY A MAKESHIFT URGENT
CARE THAT RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT MUCH MORE THAN A FAIR
GROUNDS OR EVEN A RED CROSS
SHELTER -- WOULD BE ABLE TO
HANDLE AS FAR AS MEDICAL ISSUES
ARE CONCERNED.
WE ARE EVEN ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH --
TWENTY BEDS WITH IN THIS MEDICAL
FACILITY AND A SEPARATE FIFTY
BAD QUARANTINE AREA JUST IN CASE
OR USE FOR THE ELDERLY THAT MAY
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL NEEDS.
A CAFETERIA FEEDING OVER TWO
THOUSAND MEALS IT WAS MENTIONED
JUST PRIOR -- THESE ARE NOT SEEN
CUISINES OUT OF THE FREEZER --
THE OUTPOURING FOR THE COMMUNITY
IS SIGNIFICANT AND WE ATE LIKE
ROYALTY -- THEY DID A FANTASTIC
JOB IT'S SOMETHING THAT I'VE
HEARD OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED THAT -- THAT TYPE OF
SUPPORT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
HAVE TO MANAGE LOGISTICALLY WHEN
THAT AMOUNT OF PREPARED FOOD
SHOWS UP TO FEED YOUR CREW.
AND WHEN I SAY CREW WE'VE GOT --
YOU KNOW THREE HUNDRED FIFTY TO
FOUR HUNDRED EVACUEES AND BEDS
YOU HAVE PROBABLY DOUBLE THAT IN
VOLUNTEERS.
HOW DO YOU MANAGE ALL THAT?
VERY SIGNIFICANT UNDERTAKING
ANIMAL EVACUATION CENTER WITH
COMPLETE THAT MONITORING AND BIO
SECURITY HUGE ISSUE ONLY FAIRS
CAN DO THAT.
JUST PLAIN AND SIMPLE ONLY FAIRS
CAN DO THAT -- IT WAS MENTIONED
BEFORE -- THAN SOME OF THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SPECIES --
YOU HAVE YOUR NORMAL COWS HORSES
SHEEP GOATS BUT I ALSO WANTED TO
ADD IN AS WELL YAKS [inaudible]
THE MOOSE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE'S FAMILY.
AND THEY NEED A PLACE TO GO.
TO I ON OUR SPECIFIC PROPERTY --
AS WE WERE NOT A AS AS LARGE AS
OUR SISTER FAIR AND SANTA ROSA
SONOMA COUNTY FAIR -- FOR US ONE
OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE BECAME
DONATIONS AND YOU HEARD THIS
BEFORE.
WE HAD A CONSTANT FLOW FOR THE
TEN DAYS THAT WE WERE OPEN FOR
EVACUATION FOR PEOPLE MUCH
LONGER FOR ANIMALS WE HAD AT
LEAST.
DROPPING DONATIONS OFF WE HAD
CARAVANS OF U. HAUL TRUCKS FROM
A CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
STOCK TRAILERS WE HAVE
EVERYTHING -- THE HEARTS OPENED
UP THE PURSES OPENED UP.
BUT IT WAS WAY TOO MUCH THERE
WAS A LOT FOR US TO MANAGE AN
OUT REACH IN WHAT THE PUBLIC CAN
PROVIDE AT THOSE TIMES.
YOU NEVER WANT TO SAY NO THANK
YOU TO ANYTHING WHEN SOMEONE'S
DONATING IT BUT THE SHEER
LOGISTICS BEHIND THIS WE HAD
DISCUSSIONS BEFORE ABOUT
FORKLIFTS AND GARBAGE YOU'RE
DEALING WITH PERISHABLE PRODUCTS
WE SHOWED UP ONE DAY AND THAT
WAS A PALETTE OF BANANAS.
A FULL POWER TO BAN IS -- AND
AND WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THAT HOW
LONG IS IT GOOD FOR AND WHAT DO
YOU DO WHEN WHEN YOU'RE DONE
WITH THAT THE MANAGING THE
LOGISTICS IS JUST.
JUST STAGGERING -- WE WE WERE
ABLE -- TO PUT TOGETHER -- TO TO
THE LAY OF THE LAND OF OUR
PROPERTY WE ARE ABLE TO SEPARATE
OUT ARE EVACUEES FROM DONATIONS
WE'RE ABLE TO DO TRAFFIC CONTROL
READ RECEIVE TREMENDOUS HELP.
FROM THE COAST GUARD THEY WERE
ABLE TO DO TRAFFIC CONTROL FOR
US FOR A WHILE THEY WERE ALSO
ABLE TO HELP US.
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF POLICING
IN THE DORMITORIES -- AND THIS
IS BEFORE RED CROSS SHOWED UP
BECAUSE WE WERE NOT A
PREDETERMINED RED CROSS SHELTER
IN FACT THEY CAME MUCH MUCH
LATER.
SO WE UTILIZED -- COAST GUARD IN
PLAIN CLOTHES AS TO NOT.
DISRUPT DISTURB SCARE ANY OF THE
EVACUEES WE UTILIZED AN ARMED --
NATIONAL GUARD FOR OUR
PERIMETERS AND PULLED THEM BACK.
WE HAD -- OBVIOUSLY SHERIFFS AND
POLICE AS WELL -- BUT WE WERE
ABLE TO USE ALL THOSE ENTITIES
TO KIND OF MASSAGE THE SITUATION
MANAGE HOMELESS WHICH WERE
DEFINITELY WELCOME.
MANAGE ANY SORT OF EMOTIONAL
ISSUES -- MEDICAL ISSUES AND
SUCH BUT WE WE WE DID MANAGE IT
BUT IT IS A MASSIVE TASK -- WE
WERE ABLE TO PUT ON THINGS LIKE
CHILDREN'S ACTIVITIES INFANT
CARE AREAS MOBILE CLOTHES
WASHING OFFER A A MEETINGS FOR
THOSE THAT NEEDED IT -- FROM A
MANAGEMENT STANDPOINT WE TALKED
ABOUT -- STAFF BURN OUT AND
MANAGING THAT TYPE OF ALL HIM WE
WERE VERY LUCKY THAT THE C. E.
O. OF THE LAKE COUNTY FAIR WAS
VERY FAMILIAR WITH OUR PROPERTY
AND SHE CAME DOWN.
AND ACTUALLY RAN GRAVEYARD SHIFT
FROM US SO WE HAD A CEO WITH A A
BOARD MEMBER AND THE ENTIRE TIME.
AND THE CEO'S JOB IS TO MANAGE
THE PROPERTY THE BOARD MEMBER
WAS A JOB WITH THE BOARD MEMBERS
JOB SKEWS ME WAS TO PROTECT THE
PROPERTY.
AND HELP MANAGE THE OUTSIDE
ENTITIES.
IT BECAME VERY APPARENT THAT.
RED CROSS WAS NOT EXACTLY ON ITS
WAY REMEMBER -- AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WE ARE ALSO ON THE
BACK OF THE FIRES IN THE MIDWEST.
AS WELL AS HURRICANES -- DOWN IN
TEXAS AND IN THE EAST COAST.
IT WAS OCTOBER AND TOWARDS THE
END OF THE SEASON RED CROSS WAS
OUT THEY DID NOT HAVE AS AS WE
WERE NOT A PRE PLANNED LOCATION
THEY DID NOT HAVE STAFF TO SEND
TO US -- I WAS ABLE TO MAKE A
CALL TO A RETIRED RED CROSS
SHELTER MANAGER AN EVACUATION
SERVICES FOR THE COUNTY TO COME
DOWN AND ASSISTANCE JUST TO KIND
OF LAY THINGS DOWN BEFORE WE GOT
TO DEEP -- AND WE DIDN'T WANT TO
MAKE OURSELVES INTO A CORNER.
SHE WAS ABLE TO HELP -- ALLOW US
TO SEPARATE OUT THE COMMUNITY
ALLOW US TO KEEP PEOPLE HEALTHY
AND LET US KNOW WHAT RED CROSS
WE WOULD DO AND WHAT DOESN'T DO
AND I THINK THAT'S A COMMON
THEME HERE IS EDUCATION FROM
DIFFERENT -- EMERGENCY SERVICES
INCLUDING RED CROSS AND ANY
OTHER ENTITIES OF WHAT EXACTLY
THEY CAN DO AND CANNOT DO WE
HEARD ABOUT ANIMALS.
MEDICAL CARE THEY HAVE
LIMITATIONS ON MEDICAL CARE AS
WELL HE GOT TO THE POINT WHERE
THE MEDICAL CARE THAT WE WERE
OFFERING FAR EXCEEDED RED CROSS
AND WE NEEDED TO GET THEM TO NOT
PROVIDE MEDICAL CARE.
PHONE CALLS WITH NEW JERSEY
THEIR HEADQUARTERS SO ON AND SO
FORTH -- SO.
UNDERSTANDING WHAT EACH ENTITY
CAN AND CANNOT DO IS EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT AS UNDERSTANDING WHAT
EACH FACILITY CAN AND CANNOT DO --
GOING BACK TO THOSE DONATIONS WE
MAXED OUT ALL THE LOCAL
CHARITIES -- WE WERE SENDING
TRUCKLOADS FIFTY THREE FOOT SEMI
TRUCK LOADS -- PILOTED BY
MEMBERS OF THE TEAMSTERS THAT
SHOWED UP IN FULL FORCE AND WE
WERE SENDING IN AS FAR AWAY AS
SANTA CLARA TRACY STOCKED AND
JUST TO FILL OUT THE LOCAL --
THE LOCAL CHARITIES -- WHEN IT
BECAME TIME FOR LAKE COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS TO BE ACTIVATED AS A
SHELTER WE PUT TOGETHER A TRUCK
COMPLETELY STOCKED WITH
EVERYTHING THEY NEED AND SET IT
UP THERE BEFORE EVEN THE CEO
COULD GET THERE -- AS WE TALKED
ABOUT AS FAR AS RESOURCES IN MY
EXPERIENCE IN DEALING WITH THE
DIFFERENT ENTITIES -- THE IT IS
AN EMERGENCY SITUATION AND WE'RE
WILLING TO DO WHATEVER BUT THE
FAIRGROUNDS IS LEFT THERE TO PUT
THE PIECES TOGETHER AFTER. TWO
YEARS LATER AFTER THE TUBS FIRE
IN -- CINEMA COUNTY WE STILL
HAVE COSTS WE STILL HAVE DAMAGE
WE STILL HAVEN'T INFRASTRUCTURE
DECLINE -- THAT IS TAKING A LONG
TIME TO PUT BACK TOGETHER SO.
FOR THE FOLKS THAT RUSHED TO THE
AID.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THEY GET ATTENTION TO MAKE THEM
SO STEM CELLS HOLE AFTER.
I THINK THE THE LAST THING I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS -- THIS
PANEL THESE THREE PANELS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD FROM OUR ARE
MASTERS AT LOGISTICS AND I'M NOT
PUTTING MYSELF IN THAT CATEGORY
THESE FAIR MANAGERS -- YES AND
SO FORTH THEIR MASTERS AT
LOGISTICS -- LET'S BRING THEM TO
THE TABLE MORE LET'S PREPARE
WITH THEM MORE -- THE STAFFS
THAT THEY ARE DOING THIS WITH
ARE JUST SKELETON STAFFS AND
THEY'RE GOING FOR WEEKS IF NOT
MONTHS AND EVEN LONGER -- ALL
OUT OF THE GOODNESS OF THEIR
HEART AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE SUPPORT THEM AS BEST AS
POSSIBLE WITH THE RESOURCES THEY
NEEDED.
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE THIS
BECOMING -- UNPRECEDENTED.
WE LIKE TO SET RECORDS THESE
DAYS APPARENTLY AND I THINK
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF RECENT
CURRENT DATA. TO SIT DOWN
TOGETHER EVERYBODY INVOLVED AND
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I'M I'M KEVIN CAN I AM --
MARIPOSA COUNTY SUPERVISOR SINCE --
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND CURRENT
BOARD MEMBER AND PREVIOUS
PRESIDENT OF THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA RC
RC.
HEALING LISTENING TO TESTIMONY
I'M I'M STARTING TO BELIEVE THAT
THE VALUE AND IMPORTANCE OF THE
FAIR GROUNDS IS ALMOST INVERSELY
PROPORTIONAL TO THE POPULATION
OF OF SOME OF THESE COUNTIES --
IN AND YOU'LL SEE A LITTLE WHEN
I I SPEAK HERE THE PRIOR TO
BEING ELECTED AS COUNTY
SUPERVISOR I WAS THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT IS SOMEBODY
NATIONAL PARK MAJOR PART OF
MARIPOSA COUNTY -- OBVIOUSLY
WHEN YOU HAVE THESE EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS POLITICAL LINES TEND.
TO MELT AWAY AND I'M REMINDED OF
MY FIRST EXPERIENCE IN THE
EMERGENCY WITH MARIPOSA COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS -- NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN WE HAD A FLOOD OF THE
CENTURY AND YES SOMEBODY WHAT
ALL THE ROSE IN THE ASSEMBLY
WERE WIPED OUT WITHIN ABOUT
EIGHT HOURS.
I WE HAD NINE HUNDRED VISITORS
STRANDED AND AND MORE THAN THAT
OF EMPLOYEES AFTER FIVE DAYS AND
BEING UNABLE TO GET THEM OUT WE
HAD -- WE ACTIVATED THE MILITARY
I HELICOPTER PLATOON OUT OF Là
MORE NAVAL AIR BASE AND THEY
SURVEYED THE SITUATION AND SAID
WE HAVE TO GO TO THE MAYOR POST
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS THEIR FRESNO
AIRPORT IS TOO FAR THE DAYS ARE
TOO SHORT.
AND THEY TWICE LET OUT FROM LA
MORE AND HAD TO BE TURNED AROUND
BECAUSE OF BAD WEATHER AND
LIGHTNING AND AND THIS WAS AGAIN
FIRST AND SECOND OF JANUARY --
E. VENTURE LEE WE CHOPPED A ROAD
THROUGH GOT THE A CONVOY OUT AND
GOT THAT THESE FOLKS DOWN TO THE
FAIR GROUNDS WHERE THEY COULD
STAGE AND AND EVENTUALLY BE ON
THEIR WAY BUT A LOT OF THESE
WERE SERVICE WORKERS THAT HAD TO
BE.
HELPED THROUGH -- EIGHT ALL THE
THINGS YOU CAN IMAGINE -- OVER
THE COURSE OF THE NEXT MONTH OR
SO TO GET THEM RE SITUATED AS
THE PARK STATE CLOSED FOR ABOUT
FIVE MONTHS.
THEY AT THE FAIRGROUNDS WAS JUST
THE ABSOLUTE ONLY.
THE REASONABLE LANDING AND
HOUSING SPOT FOR THAT TO OCCUR
BUT THESE INSTANCES HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY BECOME MORE AND
MORE FAMILIAR WE'VE HAD.
FLOOD FIRE FLOOD FIRE -- ALMOST
EACH OF THEM IS A RECORD SETTING
A VAN TO OVER THE LAST JUST TWO
YEARS IN MARIPOSA COUNTY -- THE
FAR TOO MANY TIMES OVER THE PAST.
FEW YEARS WE'VE HAD A SLEEPY
SUNDAY AFTERNOON WITH A FEW
PEOPLE WANDERING AROUND THE
FAIRGROUNDS AND BY -- SEVEN
HUNDRED THE NEXT MORNING THERE'S
A THOUSAND FIREFIGHTERS STAGED
ON THOSE EXACT GROUNDS YOU KNOW
THAT JUST THE ABILITY TO DO THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN ORGANICALLY --
WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE IN THE
RELATIONSHIPS YOU WE WE ALL
EXTOLLED THE VALUE OF OUR FAIR
MANAGERS [inaudible]
THE THE SHIP AS A SHARE OF HUMAN
SERVICES -- YES PUBLIC WORKS CAL
FIRE AND MORE COMMUNICATE WITH
THE FAIR GROUNDS MANAGER ON A
CONSTANT BASIS IT'S THE ONLY WAY
WE SURVIVE WHILE.
I KNOW THAT'S NOT UNIQUE TO OUR
COUNTY I CAN ASSURE THE
COMMITTEE THAT THAT THAT TYPE OF
COMMUNICATION HAPPENS IN IN MANY
OTHER AREAS ESPECIALLY.
THE RURAL COUNTY SOME SPEAKING.
FOUR HERE IN IN BOARD OF
SUPERVISOR MEETINGS THE MARIPOSA
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS STATE OWNED.
IS BEEN RE FOR FOR TWO IS SACRED
GROUND -- IN MARIPOSA COUNTY AND
EIGHT WHILE IT'S IT'S CRITICAL
ASSET IN OUR ABILITY TO DEAL
WITH EMERGENCIES.
LIKE I DESCRIBED IT'S A RARE
WEEKEND THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
WEDDING A FUNERAL AND FFA OR
LIONS CLUB FUND RAISER OTHER.
SIGNIFICANT COMMUNITY EVENT ON
THE GROUNDS.
IT JUST GENERATIONS OF MARIPOSAS
OF GROWN UP ATTENDING SOCIAL AND
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS THERE
MULTIPLE TIMES A MONTH.
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE -- TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE FINANCIAL
INSTABILITY IS BECOME A MENACING
CLOUD HANGING OVER THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE FAIR GROUNDS
FOR FOR ALL THESE THESE
FUNCTIONS -- WITH WHEN THE
BUDGETS OF IN THE STATE BUDGETS
WERE CUT -- MER POSING AND
PARTICULARLY THE ROLE COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS WERE SIMULTANEOUSLY
FORCED INTO THIS ON COMFORTABLE
LEVEL OF BUDGET CUTTING AN
ENTREPRENEUR IS SOME AND THEY
THEY WEREN'T READY FOR EITHER --
MANY HAVE IN DURING A LEVEL OF
ATROPHY FROM SINCE THAT TIME
THAT THEY HAVE NOT RECOVERED
FROM AND AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
JUST BEING ONE VERY OUTWARD --
SIGN OF OF THAT DETERIORATION.
MARIPOSA COUNTY IN FOLLOWING
WITH THAT SACRED LANDSCAPE --
HAS ACTUALLY APPROPRIATED AS
LITTLE AS TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
AS MUCH AS A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND A YEAR -- FOR THE PAST
NUMBER OF YEARS IN ORDER TO JUST
KEEP THEM SOLVENT AND ARE AT A
MINIMAL LEVEL OF SERVICE TO
CONTINUE.
BECAUSE AS ISAID WITH THE THE
MARIPOSA POPULATION HAS JUST
GOTTEN FLAT OUT SCARED IN THE IN
THE FIRE BUSINESS.
AND THE ABILITY TO STAGE IN THE
AIR RIGHT ON THE EDGE OF TOWN --
SAVES LITERALLY HOURS IN TRAVEL
TIME FOR THE FIREFIGHTERS FROM
THE NEXT AVAILABLE PLACES A FAR
FAR INCIDENTS GET TOO LARGE THEY
HAVE TO MOVE TO MERCED AND
THAT'LL ADD ANOTHER.
YOU KNOW OUR OUR FIFTEEN MINUTES
TO THE TRAVEL TIME I MEAN WE ARE
HOPEFUL WITH THE PASSAGE OF
ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON THIS
COMMITTEE STAY AB FOURTEEN
NINETY NINE A COUPLE YEARS AGO
WE'RE STARTING TO SEE SOME.
BENEFIT FROM THAT -- HELPING
YEAH BROADBAND'S BEEN MENTIONED
SECURE WATER SUPPLY WASTEWATER
FACILITIES -- RC RC WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH SECRETARY ROSS
AFTER THE INITIAL BUDGET CUTS ON
SURVIVAL TECHNIQUES UP TO AND
INCLUDING WE WERE CLOSE TO
LEASING SOME OF THESE FAIR
GROUNDS -- TO ENTITIES LIKE
MARIPOSA COUNTY TO KEEP THEM
VIABLE -- THAT THAT DIDN'T WORK
OUT SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY IN PULLING
THAT AWFUL SO -- THANK YOU TALK
ABOUT THE TRUCK LOADS OF THINGS
THAT SHOW UP WE GOT A TRUCK LOAD
OF MY PILLOWS DELIVERED.
AND IT WAS LIKE FIVE THOUSAND
PILLOWS THAT JUST CAME OUT OF
THE BLUE TRUCK LOADS OF HEY FROM --
NEVADA OUT OF THE BLUE BECAUSE
THEY HEARD WE HAD YOU KNOW WHEN
WHEN THE THOUSAND FIREFIGHTERS
GET TO THE FAIR GROUNDS -- FOR
THE THE BIG INCIDENT THERE
GREETED BY DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
HORSES AND CATTLE AND LLAMAS AND
AND AND YOU NAME IT AT THE
FAIRGROUNDS IS JUST A YOU KNOW
INDISPENSABLE PART OF THE
COMMUNITY -- I I DID WANT TO
JUST MAKE THE POINT OF HOW MUCH
THESE RURAL COMMUNITIES.
STEP UP TO THE PLATE WHEN THE
FAIR GROUND IS THREATENED AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT IT DOESN'T GO
AWAY FROM US BUT ANY HELP WE CAN
GET ALONG THOSE LINES WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE.
BUT BUT WE'RE NOT ASKING WITHOUT
TRYING TO HELP ALSO.
I WE HAVE A CABIN UP. FOUR EAST
MADERA COUNTY SO I GO BY MAYOR
POSE -- FAIRGROUNDS REGULARLY
AND I CAN ATTEST TO HOW MUCH
ACTIVITY I SEE THERE YEAH IT'S
IT'S JUST A CONSTANT PART OF OUR
LIFE THERE.
THANK YOU.
HELLO OKAY THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US TODAY I'M PAT CONKLIN I'M
ACTUALLY THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAIRS ALLIANCE I'M
ALSO ON THE WESTERN FAIRS
ASSOCIATION BOARD AND I'M THE
MANAGER OF THE DIXON MAYFAIR --
JUST TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF
OVERVIEW ABOUT DIXON MAYFAIR
BECAUSE THE ONE THING THAT
HASN'T BEEN DISCUSSED MUCH TO
TODAY IS.
THE MEDICAL FACILITY PART.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE DIXON
MAYFAIR WAS EVACUATION SITE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES WE HAD TO AND FORTY OF
THEIR GUESTS -- DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED ADULTS COME TO THE FAIR
GROUNDS -- WHERE IN SOLANO
COUNTY THEY CAME FROM CINEMA
COUNTY?
SO THESE PEOPLE HAD BEEN
EVACUATED ONCE AND THE FIRE
MOVED.
AND THEY HAD TO MOVE THEM AGAIN.
AND THEY WERE THINKING ABOUT
TAKING A SOLANO COUNTY FAIR BUT
THE SMOKE WAS SO BAD THEY CAME
UP THE ROAD AND GOT TO DIXON.
NOW I GOT A CALL I THINK OF IT.
YOU KNOW -- FOR FORTY THAT THEY
WERE ON THEIR WAY.
SO WE WERE PREPARING AND WE WERE
HAVING A BOARD MEETING THAT
NIGHT TO MY BOARD BECAME AND I
SAID YOU HAVE TO HELP ME GET
STUFF OUT OF THE BUILDINGS.
NOW WE WERE THINKING TURN FORTY
PEOPLE HOUSE WITHOUT ONE BIG
BUILDING BUT WE DIDN'T KNOW OF
THAT THAT ABILITIES OF THE
PEOPLE COMING.
SO -- ALSO IN AMBULANCES AND
BOSSES AND EVERYTHING SHOWED UP
AND IT WITH AN ESCORT OF C. H.
P..
THEY CAME TO THE FAIRGROUNDS AND
THEY WERE -- BECAUSE ALL LEVELS
OF ABILITIES FOR THEIR SO OUR
MAIN HOME AND THE WHOLE HOUSE
PEOPLE THAT WERE ON RESPIRATORS
AND HAD TO HAVE ASSISTANCE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
OUR MADDEN DINING HAD -- PEOPLE
THAT WERE MORE SELF SUFFICIENT.
AND THEN SERVE WITH OUR DENVER
TEN HALL THEY HAD TO PUT
GENERATORS ON OUR BUILDINGS
BECAUSE YOU FOUND OUT TODAY WE
DON'T HAVE GENERATORS -- BECAUSE
WE CAN'T HAVE THAT EQUIPMENT GO
DOWN.
PEOPLE'S LIVES DEPENDED ON IT.
WE HAD -- C. H. P. ON THE
GROUNDS WE HAD A PHARMACY NOW
WHAT'S SO FUNNY IS THEY WOULD
CALL IT THEIR CAMPUS AND I
CALLED THE FAIR GROUNDS AND SO
WE ALL GOT ALONG AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY VERY GOOD FRIENDS NOW --
BUT THEY SAY WE GOT A PUTS A
STEP IN THE PHARMACY CONTINUE TO
LOCKING ROOM AND I SAID YOU MEAN
THE TICKET BOOTH.
SO -- WE'VE MADE EVERYTHING WORK
BUT WAS IT PERFECT NO.
AND THAT'S ONE THING WE HAVE TO
BRING THE TABLE TO IS WE NEED TO
BRING A DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICESINTO THIS
DIALOGUE BECAUSE WHEN I'M
STALKING THEM.
YEAH THEY'VE THEY'VE TALKED
ABOUT WHEN THEY HAVE TO EVACUATE --
WHERE THEY GONNA GO GROUP HOMES
THOSE THINGS THE -- THAT WE WE
HAVEN'T CONSIDERED -- AN
EVACUATION SITE IS IS.
HARD ENOUGH AS IT IS BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SPECIAL THINGS
THERE -- YOU KNOW WE HAD TO
UNDER FORTY GUESTS AND AND TWO
HUNDRED OF THEIR STAFF MEMBERS
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
AND THEY HAD THEY HAD A POP UP
FLU SHOT AREA.
BECAUSE WE WE'RE WE'RE ABOUT
SICKNESS -- WE HAD.
AT THAT MENTAL HEALTH CARE
GIVERS FOR THE STATE EMPLOYEES.
WE HAD A TALK I HAVE TO
MAINTENANCE WORKERS NOW THIS IS
OCTOBER SO A THAT'S THE YOU KNOW --
WE DIDN'T HAVE A LARGE STAFF AT
THIS TIME BUT WE DON'T A LARGE
SHOP ANYWAY THAT'S A SPACES.
BUT WE HAD TO MAINTENANCE
WORKERS AND ALSO IN THERE LIKE
ARE YOU GUYS GOING TO CLEAN THE
BATHROOMS I LIVE TWO PEOPLE WE
BETTER FIGURE THIS OUT -- SO
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
BROUGHT IN THERE BECAUSE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
SERVICES.
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER SO WE
HAD A DIFFERENT LEVEL WE HAD A
DIFFERENT -- EXPERIENCE BUT IT
YOU KNOW.
THE REALITY IS WE ARE SMALL A
MANY OF OUR FAIR GROUNDS ARE
VERY MALL AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
STAFFING HEARD THAT TODAY THE
STAFF IS AN ISSUE.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE TO WORK
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY IN
EVERYBODY'S EXHAUSTED.
EQUIPMENTS AN ISSUE OUR FORKLIFT
WITH ON ITS LAST LEG AND IT DID
HAPPEN TURNING THINGS THAT WE
TALKED TO SNOW MARIN ABOUT
TAKING.
THEY WERE GONNA READ THIS A
FORKLIFT BUT WE THINK WE BORROW.
THE TOURNEY MECHANISM SO WE
COULD DUMP THE TRASH SO THERE'S
A LOT OF THINGS SO TO WRAP UP
BECAUSE I DON'T TAKE A LOT OF
TIME BUT THAT IS SOMETHING WE
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT IS THE
MEDICAL PART OF IT WE WERE
MEDICAL FACILITY.
WE CAN LET PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
IT WAS VERY TO THE HOUSE ITSELF
INTO WE HAD A HOUSE THE STAFF.
AND MANY OF THOSE STAFF MEMBERS
BLESS THEIR HEARTS THEY LOST
EVERYTHING.
AND THEY STILL SHOWED UP THEY
DROVE THE SHOWED UP THE STATE ON
THE FAIRGROUNDS INTENSE IN IN --
WE HAD M. SO TENSE AND IN OUR
MAKESHIFT FACILITIES AND WHAT WE
DID THEY THEY STAY THERE WE HAD
NATIONAL GUARD THERE WHO SLEPT
IN OUR BARNES WE HAD THE CHP
THERE WE HAD EVERYBODY THERE.
AND AND SPEAKING OF DONATIONS
DONATIONS ARE A BLESSING BUT
THEY THEY FOR US WE CAN TAKE
THEM BECAUSE WE COULDN'T TAKE
THOSE -- ITEMS THAT WE WERE
AWARE OF AND THEN SOMETIMES FOR
DONATIONS THEY CAN BE A
HINDRANCE TO YOU GET A BUNCH OF
STUFF DROPPED OFF THAT.
YOU END UP.
DISPOSING OF LATER BECAUSE IT'S
NOT THE STUFF THAT PEOPLE NEED
SO THAT'S THE THING SO TO WRAP
UP I'D SAY WE NEED
INFRASTRUCTURE OF COURSE
IMPROVEMENTS I DON'T CALL
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE COULD TO ME
WHEN I HEAR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
I THINK A PAINT.
YOU KNOW INFRASTRUCTURE ANY
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS I DON'T
NEED DEFERRED MAINTENANCE I NEED
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS I NEED AN
H. BACK SYSTEM SO WHEN I HAVE
PEOPLE IN MY BUILDING THAT I DO
HAVE MEDICAL NEEDS.
THAT -- THAT THE THE AIR WILL BE
GOOD AND CLEAN AND AND YOU KNOW
AFTER NINETY DEGREES AND SWAMP
COOLER IS JUST REALLY NOT
EFFECTIVE.
AND WHEN WE ARE PEOPLE IN YOUR
BUILDING WITH RESPIRATORS IT'S
REALLY NOT GOOD SO WE WERE LUCKY
THE WEATHER HELD THEM ALL WE HAD
TO DO WAS TURN ON OUR HEATER.
NOW OUR HEATER IS EITHER ON OR
OFF THOUGH THERE IS NO -- REAL --
THERMOSTAT ON IT AND IF THOSE
JET HEATER SO YOU TURN ON A
CAN'T HEAR ANYTHING ANYWAY BUT
WHEN WE HAVE A CONTINUOUS
MUSIC'S ALLOWED BLOOM DIES OUT
ANYWAY SO MOST OF OUR OTHER
EVENTS IT WAS GREAT.
BUT AT THE SAID TODAY THIS IS
ANOTHER EVENT FOR US AND AND
WHAT WE REALLY GOT BEING AT THE
TABLE TO WITH.
THOSE WITH THAT -- DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER CINEMA DEVELOPMENTS THAT
ARE WAS THAT.
YEAH WE RUN AN EVENT SO LET US
HELP YOU AND WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THEM THINGS THAT THE BUREAUCRACY
WAS SLOWING HIM DOWN WITH LIKE.
THEY GOT TO THE FAIR GROUNDS
[inaudible]
AND AND THEY HAD HELP AT THE
TIME BUT THEN EVERYBODY LEFT.
AND THE MANAGERS OF SIGNAL
DEVELOPMENT CENTER WE'RE TRYING
TO MANAGE THE PEOPLE AND HELP
THE PEOPLE AT THE SAME TIME
TRYING TO MAKE AN EVACUATION
CENTER.
IT WAS NOT WORKING SO WE WERE
LUCKY THAT TO GET THE EAST BAY
INCIDENT COMMAND CENTER COMMAND
BUT WE ALSO AS A FAIR WERE ABLE
TO STEP IN AND SAY LET US HELP
YOU.
BECAUSE WE SIT IN MEETINGS AT
NINE O'CLOCK IN THE GO WE NEED
THIS THIS AND THIS.
AND TAKE A LONG TIME BECAUSE
PURCHASING TOOK FOREVER AND ALL
THE THINGS I SAID LET ME CALL MY
FRIEND I SAID BEFORE YOU ASK
ANYBODY LET ME CALL MY FRIEND.
SO WE CALL UP THEIR FAVORS AND
GET SPONSORS TO TREAT THE COMICS
BOXES WE GOT THOSE ALL DONATED
WE GET THINGS DONATED IN EIGHT
HATED O DO IT BUT WE SAID NO
LET'S HELP YOU BECAUSE THE
COMMUNITY.
WANTED HELP YOU AND I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
VALUE OF A FAIR GROUNDS IS THERE
COMMUNITY.
PEOPLE COMING IN TO SERVICE
EVACUATION CENTER ARE REALLY
FROM THE COMMUNITY.
AND WE KNOW WHO WILL GET THINGS
DONE AND WE KNOW THEY WANT TO
HELP I MEAN OUR ALLIED STORAGE
BROUGHT IN CAN CONNEX BOXES.
AND THEY WANTED TO HELP.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO HELP IN THE
ONE I KNOW HOW CAN WE HELP AND
THAT'S WHERE WE PROBABLY ARE
STRONG THIS IS BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A TIGHT A COMMUNITY.
DIXIE MAY FIRST IN THEIR HEART
OF FORTY FOUR YEARS YOU BACK
BEING CALL IN SOME FAVORS AND
MAKE IT WORK AND WE WANT TO HELP
EVERYBODY WE CAN.
SO CRITICAL NEEDS HVAC POWER.
I SAID I HAVE SAID FOR YEARS AND
I LAY IN BED I THE WEIRDEST
THINGS I DO WAKE UP AT THREE AM
AGO OH MY GOSH WHAT HAPPENS WHEN.
AND THE WHEN I THOUGHT ABOUT
THIS FIRST WITH WAS IN THE
OROVILLE DAM.
SO YOU'RE BACK AWAY TO BUNCH OF
PEOPLE AND YOU TOOK HIM TO CHICO
WITH THAT THIS OVERALL
FAIRGROUND SO IN A STORM.
CONCEIVABLY POWERS GOING TO GO
OUT.
THEN WHAT YOU GOT TO MOVE AGAIN.
TO GET A DISASTER WITHIN A
DISASTER AND WE'RE GONNA MOVING.
TO SO WE NEED TO HAVE.
POWER SOME SORT OF POWER EITHER
EITHER HAVE IT HOOKED UP SO WE
CAN TAKE POWER OR JUST.
BE PREPARED FOR THE POWER WE
HAVE TO HAVE POWER ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF THE P. GINNY'S
PROPOSING.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE GONNA
BE OFFER TWENTY FOUR TO FORTY
EIGHT HOURS EVEN MORE.
SO LET'S SAY WE ARE BACK WITH A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE TO DATE FAIR
YUBA SUTTER FAIRGROUNDS HALL PGD
SAYS UP PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFF SHUTS DOWN TO DATE NOW HAS
TO GO FIND.
GENERATORS MAYBE HE CAN GET THEM
BECAUSE IN IN DISASTERS THEY'RE
NOT SO READILY AVAILABLE.
SO NOW YOU GOT TO MOVE THESE
PEOPLE NOW YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
MOVE EVEN FARTHER AWAY FROM
THEIR HOMES.
AND THEIR RD TRAUMATIZED IT IS
IS [inaudible]
WATER SEWER.
OUR FAIRGROUNDS OUR OLD -- WHEN
THEY WERE BRINGING IN ALL THE
SHOWER FACILITIES WE HAVE LOTS A
SHOWER FACILITIES BROUGHT ON IN
AND -- BATHROOMS AND WE HAD TO
GET BLATTER'S BECAUSE WE WERE
SET WE WERE NOT SURE.
HOW WELL OUR SEWER IS GOING TO
HOLD NOW WE'RE READY FOR THE
FAIR WE GET SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WE HAVE A CONCESSION
TRAILERS AND WE KNOW WE CAN HOPE
FOR THAT BUT THEY DON'T RUN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY
[inaudible]
SO IT.
AN ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION WE MADE
SURE WE GOT BLATTER'S OUR
KITCHEN FACILITIES ARE USED TO
RUNNING TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
THEY'RE USED TO HAVING AN
OCCASIONAL ABOUT YOU KNOW A A
MAYBE EVERY WEEKEND ABOUT
BECAUSE WE HAVE THEM EVERY
WEEKEND.
BUT THEY'RE ONLY COOKING IN A
FOR FIVE SIX HOURS AT A TIME.
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
AND THEIR OLD -- AND THEY CAN'T
TAKE THE GREASE AND ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT PEOPLE LIKE TO DUMP
IT ON EVEN THOUGH WE TELL NOT TO
THEY STILL DO IT.
RESTROOMS AND SHOWER FACILITIES
NOW ALL WE HAVE ON OUR
FAIRGROUNDS ONE SHOWER WHEN SHE
OUR FACILITY -- SO AND IT'S GOOD
FOR WHAT WE DO BUT WHEN YOU
BRING IN PEOPLE AND THEY'RE
GONNA NEED SHOWER FACILITIES
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO BRING IN
SHOWER FACILITIES.
STAFFING AGAIN WILL WE HAVE TO
HAVE HELP WITH THE STAFFING AND
AND MAYBE SOME REALLY SOME FROM
SOME OF THE BUREAUCRACY THAT
DOES OUR STAFFING YOU KNOW -- WE
TALK ABOUT THE TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEES IN AND AND
RESTRICTIONS ON THEIR TIME WELL
WHEN WE BURN UP ALL OUR TIME.
IN AN EVACUATION THAT WE HAVE NO
TIME TO USE THEM.
FOR OUR AT OUR EVENTS THAT WE
NEED.
FOR I INTERNET COMMUNICATION
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO HAVE IT.
WE WERE MEDICAL FACILITY.
THEY NEEDED DEDICATED INTERNET
HAPA.
THE COULD NOT GET THEIR MEDICAL
RECORDS WITHOUT IT.
SO THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO SAY HAS
A BAD TO CARRY ON THEIR BOXES
AND SECURE THEM OF MEDICAL
RECORDS -- EQUIPMENT AGAIN WE
HAD NEED EQUIPMENT -- WE THERE
USED TO BE IN EQUIPMENT
REPLACEMENT FIND AT AFTER ANY
AND THAT WOULD ALLOW WE BE ABLE
TO PUT IN FOR IT AND GET
EQUIPMENT I HAD TO BE COUNTY
FAIR I WAS ABLE TO GET A TRACTOR
ONE TIME -- FUNDING FORKLIFTS I
KNOW OUR FORKLIFT FINALLY DIED
AFTER THIS -- EPISODE OF OF
DOING THIS AND BUT WE HAVE TO
HAVE EQUIPMENT TO TO HELP BETTER
SERVE TO BETTER SERVE WE'RE NOT.
SEEN FOR OWN FIT TO HELP US
BETTER SERVE.
STRIKES WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
DIALOGUE BEFORE THE DISASTER
STRIKES I MEAN I YOU KNOW -- AND
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW OUR
FACILITY LIKE WE DO YOU KNOW
PEOPLE COME ON THE FACILITY AND
THEY WANT TO DO ALL THE THINGS
AND YOU KNOW I HAD TRUCKS BEING
PUT IN THE WRONG PLACE THEM ALL
YOU.
THE SECOND HOLD YOU'RE PLUGGING
INTO THE POWER OF THE BUILDING
THAT.
HAS A GENERATOR AND WE NEED THAT
POWER TO HOLD SO DIALOGUE BEFORE
MAPPING OUT THE FAIRGROUNDS SO
WE KNOW I'VE BEEN TALKING OUR
FARMERS ABOUT GIVING.
ME THE DIMENSIONS OF WILL HELP
WALK PATHS IN THE PAST THE
TROUBLE NO THESE SO I CAN
DEVELOP PLANS AGAIN JUST HANDED
SOMEONE AND SAY HERE YOU GO --
EXPERTISE AND HELP WHEN WHEN WE
NEED IT THAT YOU KNOW -- LIKE
FIRE MARSHAL LISTINGS EXPERTISE
AND HELP CONTROLS WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE CONTROLS.
YOU CAN'T HAVE EVERYBODY COME ON
THE FAIRGROUNDS WITHOUT SOMEBODY
CONTROLLING IT EITHER AND IF
THAT'S OUR JOB AND WE NEED TO BE.
AWARE THAT THAT'S OUR JOB BUT
THERE HAS TO BE CONTROLS PEOPLE
NEED TO BE CHECKING IN PEOPLE
AND AND HAVING LISTEN THOSE
THINGS BECAUSE WE NEED CONTROLS
WE NEED TO KNOW WHO'S ON THE
GROUNDS AND AND WHY.
DONATIONS MANAGEMENT.
A YES NO PERSON HE'S GOING TO
SAY YES TO THIS OR NOTED THAT
THE PUBLIC AND INTERNET THOSE
THINGS.
UP ON NON CASH OF THINGS.
FIRE CODE WE NEED HELP WITH THE
FIRE CODE BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE SPENDING YOUR NIGHTS I
HAD THE FIRE MARSHAL COME ON THE
GROUNDS WHICH IS GREAT BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WHEN THEY GO TO SET UP.
THE SET UP IN THERE CAUSING
ACTUALLY A POTENTIAL.
I DISASTER YOURSELF BECAUSE YOU
CAN EAT YOU THEY'RE WALKING
DOORS OF THOSE THINGS SO FAR
MARSHALL COMES ON ONLY ONE MAKE
SURE WE ARE SAFE.
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
DISASTER WITHIN A DISASTER SO WE
NEED TO TALK TO THEM ABOUT WE
NEED -- YOU KNOW ONE THING THAT
CAME UP FOR US WAS AUDIBLE FIRE
ALARM.
STILL DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES BECAUSE THEY'RE
SPENDING THE NIGHT IN THE
BUILDING WHICH IS CODE YOU HAVE
TO HAVE AN AUDIBLE FIRE ALARM
THEY HAD TO TELL THEM HOW THEY
WERE GOING TO WAKE PEOPLE UP IN
CASE.
THE FIRE HAPPENED -- YOU KNOW
THOSE TYPE OF THINGS BUT WHAT WE
WHAT WE REALLY NEED IS THE THOSE
TYPE OF THINGS WE JUST NEED. TO
BE ABLE TO SERVE BETTER.
WE JUST NEED SOME HELP I WE WANT
TO SERVE AND WE'RE PROUD TO
SERVE I MEAN NOBODY'S PROUDER
THAN THE FEAR INDUSTRY DOES TO
SERVE IN THIS CAPACITY.
IS PROBABLY PROUD OF IN OUR
ANNUAL FAIR.
A PROUD TO DO THIS FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND TO FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT WE IS ABOVE AND
BEYOND YES WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
IT OUR OUR OUR STAFF WALKED
AROUND.
AFTER THIS JUST SO PROUD.
AND AND THE INDUSTRY'S PROUD SO
IN ORDER FOR US TO SERVE.
OUR CALIFORNIANS BETTER.
WE JUST NEED TO WORK ON THESE
THINGS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'M I'M NOT CLIFF MY JERSEY
YOU'RE NOT CLIP.
FROM SISKIYOU COWBOY HAT YEAH I
DO THE ONLY SIMILARITY -- MY
NAME'S DAVE BILL OF THE ON THE
AFTER MANAGER OF THE YUBA SUTTER
FAIR HERE YOU TO CITY.
SO AS YOU PROBABLY ALL KNOW --
WE WERE THE SITE -- THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CASCADE FIRE
IN THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CAMPFIRE EVACUATION CENTER --
FOR BOTH INCIDENTS -- REAL REAL
QUICKLY TO SUMMARIZE IT WE HAD
OVER THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE IN OUR
BUILDINGS OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
RV SPREAD OUT THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE FORTY TWO ACRES OF THE
FAIRGROUNDS -- THAT DONATION
CENTER THAT RECEIVED OVER I'M
TEN SEMI LOADS OF OF GOODS.
AND DURING THE ONSET OF IT WE
WERE FIRST OPENED UP WITH OUR
LOCAL -- YES THEN IT TRANSFERRED
INTO STATE -- YES AND THEN I
TRANSFERRED OVER TO RED CROSS --
SO WITH THOSE TRENDS THAT THE
WITH THOSE TRANSITIONS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES I WHICH WHICH EACH --
FOR GOING THROUGH AND CHANGE
MADE TRADE A LOT OF CHALLENGES --
WHEN THE CHANGES TOOK PLACE --
CURRENTLY NOW WE ARE STILL --
ACTING AS A FEMALE SITE -- FOR
FORTY PLUS -- RV TRAILERS --
SINCE THE CAMPFIRE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT -- AT LEAST
GREATEST THIS COMING DECEMBER.
SO WE'VE DEALT WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT -- AGENCIES -- AND I
AND AS I SAY HERE LISTEN TO ALL
THE TESTIMONY OF ALL THE
COLLEAGUES I TO COME BEFORE ME --
I THINK ONE THING STANDS OUT.
AND THAT THE CONSISTENCY OF THE
CHALLENGES -- WE'VE ALL MENTION
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS --
STE WE'VE ALL MENTION STAFFING.
THOSE TWO ARE ARE THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT REALLY SPEAK IT
THAT REALLY COME TO MIND -- WHEN
FIRST WHEN YOU OPEN UP THE --
EVACUATION CENTER -- AND AND
ALSO WOULD OCCUR WHEN YOU GO TO
CLOSE IT -- BUT I THINK THAT
SPEAKS VOLUMES IN TERMS OF JUST
HOW IMPORTANT -- AND HOW
CONSISTENT THESE CHALLENGES ARE
IN THE NEEDS TO REALLY FACETIME
ON HEAD ON AM.
I THE NUMBER SO TO CUT PERINEAL
LOOKING FORWARD.
HOW DO WE GET HOW DO WE MOVE
FORWARD HOW ARE WE MORE HOW DO
WE BECOME I'M MORE PREPARED FOR
THE NEXT ONE BECAUSE IT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN -- I HAVE ONE WORD
PREPAREDNESS AND THIS
PREPAREDNESS IN TERMS OF
IMPROVING OUR FACILITIES.
AND YOU KNOW WE'VE ALL MENTION
AGE BACK SYSTEMS WE HAVE FOR
HEATERS IN OUR MAIN EXHIBIT
DONATE SIXTEEN THOUSAND SQUARE
FOOT BUILDING THAT HOUSE OVER
THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE. TWO OF THE
FOUR WORK.
THE ON THE OTHER TWO ARE IN
REPAIRABLE.
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE PLACED
IN CORNERS OF THE BUILDING
WITHOUT ANY TYPE OF CENTRAL -- I
HAVE -- DEPOSITS OF THE AIR.
AND THOSE CORNERS GET HOT DRESS
IT ONLY GETS COLD.
AND THOSE BUILDING DOES HEATERS
ARE PROBABLY OVER SIXTY SEVEN
YEARS OLD WE DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY FINANCIALLY TO BE ABLE TO
UPDATE AS BUT HERE THE LAST TWO
YEARS WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN IN
EVACUATION CENTER -- FOR THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND WHEN I
TALK ABOUT LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
PAT JUST GOT DONE TALKING ABOUT
IT THIS WE TAKE GREAT PRIDE IN
THIS THIS IS WE WE'RE HERE FOR
COMMUNITIES.
I'M IN THE RECENT EXPERIENCE
WE'RE HERE FOR OUR OUTSIDE FOR
OUR FOR THE NEXT COMMUNITY AND
YOU COUNTY THAT THE CAMPFIRE
DIDN'T TAKE PLACE AND SUTTER
COUNTY OR YOU THE COUNTY WHICH
WE REPRESENT.
BUT AGAIN WE TAKE GREAT PRIDE IN
MAKING SURE THAT OUR OUR HANDS
ARE OPEN -- JUST LIKE ANY FAIR
GROUNDS WOULD IN THE TIRES IN
THE TIRE NETWORK A CALIFORNIA
FIRES.
AND SO I THINK THAT SPEAKS
VOLUMES AGAIN ABOUT IN TERMS OF
WHERE WHERE ARE ON OUR OUR HEART
IS AND WE WANT TO BE THERE FOR
THE COMMUNITIES.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
PREPAREDNESS PLANNING I THINK IT
WE REALLY AGAIN WE NEED TO HAVE
A A PREPARED PLAN FOR EACH
BACKGROUNDS.
I KNOW WE DON'T I KNOW WE
DENNETT HOW WEAK STARTED ON ONE
YES NOW OF COURSE OF THE LAST
TWO YEARS -- BUT AGAIN I THINK
THAT'S WE CERTAINLY COULD USE
SOME HELP FROM THE STATE.
IN TERMS OF EITHER FUNDING FOR
SOMEBODY TO COME IN AND HELP
WITH THOSE -- THOSE THINGS THAT
PLANTS -- OR JUST SOME --
EXPERTISE IN TERMS OF HOW TO
DEVELOP THOSE.
AND THE CLEARLY HURT IN CONCERT
WITH YOU ALL YES YOU ARE THE
EXPERTS OF YOUR OWN FACILITIES
YEAH YES DEFINITELY BUT IN TERMS
OF THE OF I JUST OVERALL BASIS
OF THE PLAN ITSELF -- IT HAS
BEEN SPOKEN TO ABOUT BEFORE BUT
AGAIN PREPAREDNESS IN TERMS OF
COMMUNICATING IN COORDINATING
AMONGST DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
CALLOW YES LOCAL -- YES RED
CROSS -- WHEN WE WHEN WE
TRANSITION FROM EACH OF THOSE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES -- I'M ON THE
PHONE WITH CDFA I'M ON THE PHONE
WITH CARILLO YES I'M ON THE
PHONE WITH RED CROSS AND GETTING
MIXED MIXED COMMUNICATION AND
MIXED MESSAGES IN TERMS OF WHO'S
OPERATING THIS WHO'S IN CHARGE
OF WHAT -- AND AND WHEN RED
CROSS SHOWED UP WE DO MEAN WE
WEREN'T WE WERE THE LAST TWO TO
HEAR ABOUT IT OF COURSE.
SO I THINK SOMEBODY AT THE STATE
LEVEL WHETHER THAT'S THAT CDFA
OR YES THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE
A POINT OF CONTACT TO HELP IN
TERMS OF A LOT OF COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES
WOULD BE -- A GREAT HELP -- AND
AGAIN ALL OF THE EXITING WE HAD
A WHEN WHEN RED CROSS OR CALLOW
YES WHOEVER WANTS TO WHEN WHEN
THEY DECIDE TO LEAVE.
I'M WE NEED TO BE INFORMED OF
THAT -- WE WERE THE LAST TO BE
INFORMED OF IT AND OF COURSE --
HERE WE HAVE -- YOU KNOW OVER A
HUNDRED RV THAT WERE LEFT AT THE
SITE -- WANTING TO YOU KNOW NOT
WANTING TO GO TO A NEW SITE --
BUT YET WORD WHEN WE'RE GOOD
WE'VE BEEN THE BACK DE ACTIVATED
SO NOW WE'RE TRYING.
TO KILEY REMOVE -- EVACUEES --
IN A IN A MANNER THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ON THE FRONT PAGE OF
THE NEWS.
I'M SO THAT CREATES A LOT OF
ISSUES.
AND I GUESS I THINK THAT STARTS
WITH A LOT OF COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES
AND HAVING THAT POINT PERSON AT
THE STATE LEVEL -- HELP WHETHER
THAT'S AGAIN THE CDFA OR YES --
THAT WOULD BE AT A MAJOR HELP --
BUT AGAIN I I THINK -- AGAIN --
AS WELL IN PREPAREDNESS IS
HAVING THE MO YOU -- DONE WITH
EITHER YOUR LOCAL -- YASSER YOUR
STATE OR THE STATE -- YES OFFICE
PRIOR TO BE HAPPENING -- AFGHAN
DENTAL OF COURSE WITH THE EFFORT
FACED WITH RED CROSS BUT BEING
ABLE TO BE PREPARED FOR THESE
ACTUALLY HAVING HIM -- YOU IN
PLACE I WILL CERTAINLY HELP IN
TERMS OF ONE HAVING A POINT OF
CONTACT WITH THAT AGENCY AT THAT
TIME YOU'VE ALREADY SPOKEN WITH
THEM YOU'VE MET YOU'VE MADAM.
HERE SOMEWHAT AND AND YOU'RE
READY FOR THIS I KNOW IN OUR
EXPERIENCE I'D GROUP YOU KNOW ON
ON WITHIN THE FIRST COUPLE WEEKS
OF TAKING THE JOB I WENT MET
WITH MY LOCAL -- YES THAT ORTIZ
AND IT WAS EASY TRANSITION THE
VERY BEGINNING WHEN THEY TOOK
OVER IT WAS AFTER THEY LEFT.
AND WE'RE WITH CALORIE ASPER RED
CROSS IS WHEN ISSUE STARTED TO
ARISE IN TERMS OF THE
COMMUNICATION AND AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE.
SO AGAIN -- I'M I'M NOT GONNA BE
REDUNDANT WITH EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE HEARD I THINK EVERYBODY
SPOT ON IN TERMS OF THE
CHALLENGES -- I THINK EFFORT
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS ARE
GOING TO GO A LONG WAYS IN TERMS
OF NOT DOING PATCHWORK BUT DOING
IMPROVEMENTS SO WHEN EMERGED
VIRTUALLY DOES TAKE PLACE.
I WE CAN OPEN UP THE GATES IN BE
READY WITHOUT HAVING TO BRING
AND THIS PATCHWORK THAT
PATCHWORK THAT FIXED IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE -- THE
PUBLIC -- THE INTEGRATED MANNER
THAT WE AS A FAIR INDUSTRY --
PRIDE OURSELVES ON SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
WELL.
PRESIDENTE FANTASTIC JOB ALL OF
YOU AND I THINK -- MY HUGE TAKE
WORDS AND PICTURES BEEN TAKING
NOTES -- WE STILL HAVE SOME
PEOPLE FROM THE DEPARTMENT HERE --
AND I THINK WE'VE HEARD LOUD AND
CLEAR THAT WHAT WILL WHAT WE
KNOW RIGHT NOW MONEY IS NEEDED
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE BUT SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO I
THINK MORE QUICKLY -- IS AT
LEAST PUT TOGETHER TALK ABOUT
GETTING SOME POINT PEOPLE SOME
STRIKE TEAMS AND LIKE WORKING
GROUPS TOGETHER HOW DO WE BETTER
COORDINATE.
RIGHTS NOT IF THE NEXT ONE'S
GONNA KERR IT'S WHEN AND WHERE --
AND AS YOU'VE ALL SAID DIDN'T
YOU MOBILIZE.
IT TRULY FEELS LIKE YOU KNOW I'M
SORRY IT'S TAKEN THIS LONG TO DO.
A HEARING ON THIS ISSUE -- THAT
YOU TRULY ARE THE UNSUNG HEROES
OF SO MANY DISASTERS THAT ARE
OCCURRING AROUND OUR STATE.
AND WE KNOW WHERE I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE THIS HAPPENING ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY BUT THE AMOUNT OF
THE YOU KNOW THE FOR THE FLOODS
AND AND EVERYTHING WE'RE HAVING.
SO WE APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
TIME WE APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU DO ON THE GROUND AT THE
MASS COORDINATION THAT JUGGLING --
THE YOU KNOW THE WORK THAT GOES
WITHOUT THANKS A LOT AND WE KNOW
WHO YOU DO IT BECAUSE YOU CARE
AND YOU INVESTED IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES AND YOU'RE INVESTED
IN PEOPLE.
AND ANIMALS -- AND EVERYTHING
THAT GOES ALONG WITH THAT -- SO
WE THANK YOU FOR TAKING YOUR
TIME TO COME UP -- YOU'LL HEAR
BACK FROM US AGAIN YOU KNOW YOU
MAY NOT BE TOMORROW THE NEXT DAY --
BUT I HAVE CERTAINLY HEARD --
CERTAIN HURLEY FOR YOUR CONCERNS
AND AS WE ARE GETTING READY TO
MOVE IN A FIRE SEASON AGAIN IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US -- TO GET
TOGETHER MORE QUICKLY AND DON'T
YOU KNOW DON'T LEAVE YOU ALL
HOLDING THE BAG OUT THERE IN THE
FIELD.
BUT TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
PROACTIVE ON THE STATE SIDE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL ANA CDFA -- YES
WE'LL BE TALKING MORE LATER.
THANK YOU. TO CONCLUDE THE
HEARING